ESTABLISH A QUORUM. GOOD
MORNING TO ALL THAT. WHAT YOU
CAN DO ALL THE PUBLIC GOT IT
OKAY THIS IS OUR SIXTY SECOND
WARNING THE COMMITTEE WILL BE
STARTING IN SIXTY SECONDS
. FOR
GOOD MORNING THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON NATURAL RESOURCES
AND WATER WILL COME TO ORDER
WE'LL BE STARTING AS A SUB
COMMITTEE A GOOD MORNING IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERING SENATE
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING IN
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WITH SOME OF OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS PARTICIPATING REMOTELY.
OUR MEMBERS ATTENDING REMOTELY
TODAY ARE SENATOR STERN SENATOR
STERN IF YOU HAVE A STAFF
PERSON WITH YOU CAN YOU PLEASE
IDENTIFY THAT STAFF FOR NOW.
YES GOOD MORNING- SENATOR HENRY
STERN OF MY DISTRICT OFFICE AND
I'M HERE WITH MY DISTRICT
DIRECTOR JEREMY WOLFE. GOOD
MORNING SENATOR STERN IN
JEREMY. AND SENATOR STERN AS A
REMINDER PLEASE MEET YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I ASKED SAID
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT USE THE RAISE
YOUR HAND TO FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO UN MUTE.
PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE
YOU BEGIN SPEAKING. OUR I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN. STATE YOUR NAME AND
THEN YOU WILL BE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. IN WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE. FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS ONE EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE. SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. IN THE ACCESS
CODE IS. FIVE SEVEN ONE. EIGHT
EIGHT FOUR SIX AGAIN THE NUMBER.
1-844-291-6364 ACCESS CODE FIVE
SEVEN ONE. EIGHT EIGHT FOUR SIX
FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW THE TELECONFERENCES O
MARKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE. FOR THE COMMITTEES
WEBSITES WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT. AND
OPPOSITION. PRESS THIS ONLY ONE
TIME IN WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WAIT ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER. AT THAT TIME
YOU WILL BE ON YOU DID AND YOU
ARE NOW READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY. IN DEMAND WHO IS
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESSING CONDUCTOR HEARINGS
IN AS CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER
AS IS CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE
SOME LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS
WERE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE
OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
DUE TO THE PROJECTED LENGTH OF
TODAY'S HEARING WE MAY TAKE A
SHORT LUNCH BREAK TO BE
DETERMINED AS WE HEAR TESTIMONY
ON THE BILLS AND HAVE A
FORECAST. OF TIME REMAINING WE
ANTICIPATE A THIRTY MINUTE
LUNCH BREAK AND I'LL GIVE A-
HEADS UP LEAD AS WE APPROACH.
THAT TIME IF WE DO INDEED NEED
TO TAKE THAT BREAK AND THAT
BREAK IS ALSO OUT OF RESPECT
FOR THE STAFF WHO ARE WORKING.
TO PROVIDE THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FOR THIS HEARING
TODAY. SO MEMBERS WE HAVE FOUR
BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA. HELLO
QUORUM WE DO. BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATION ON THE BILLS LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM UNLESS THE
CONSULTANT TO PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL IN TURN ON YOUR
MICROPHONES FOR ROLL CALL
PLEASE. MONNING HERE I THINK
HERE JONES HERE JONES HERE
ALAN. BURGESS WE'RE JUST HERE
CABALLERO CABALLERO HERE
HERTZBERG HUESO JACKSON STERN
HERE TURN HERE WE HAVE. OKAY
NOW WE WILL HEAR FROM THE FIRST
AUTHOR- WE WELCOME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIVAS YOU MAY NOW
PRESENT AB. THREE ZERO ZERO
FIVE. THANK YOU US CENTER
MINING AND COLLEAGUES CHAIRMAN
STEARNS GREAT TO BE HERE THIS
MORNING. YOU KNOW AND I
CERTAINLY WANT TO THANK SENATOR
STERN AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR ALL OF THEIR- THE
CONSIDERATION AND ENGAGEMENT ON
THIS IMPORTANT BILL. IT'S AN
INFORMAL FAR DISTRICT AND- I
KNOW THIS IS NOT AN EASY TASK
WITH OUR- THE COMPRESSED-
LEGISLATIVE TIMELINE THIS IS A
ABOUT A BILL THAT HAS IT WAS A
HUGE UNDERTAKING SO I'M- VERY
THANKFUL. AND WITH THAT I'M
PLEASED TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS AS
DESCRIBED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS. THIS BILL ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE ZERO ZERO FIVE THE
EXPEDITED DAM SAFETY FOR
SILICON VALLEY ACT. LOOKS TO
RESOLVE A MAJOR ISSUE IN OUR
DISTRICT- AN ISSUE. THAT HAS
REGIONAL PUBLIC SAFETY AND
WATER SUPPLY IMPACTS AND
REQUIRES IMMEDIATE STATE ACTION.
THIS LEGISLATION SEEKS TO ENACT
pTHAT ARE NEEDED THIS YEAR TO
EXPEDITE NECESSARY SEISMIC
RETROFITS. FOR THE LEROY
ANDERSON DAMMIT BY THE SANTA
CLARA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT AND
IT ACCOMPLISHES THIS BY DOING
THE FOLLOWING FIRST CARE I'M OF
THE BILL. THANK SEVEN NOTED
PLEASE CONTINUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RIVAS FIRST THIS LEGISLATION
SEEKS TO EXPEDITE PERMITTING
AND EXPRESS PERMITTING BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
AND BY THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD WITH
ALL ASSOCIATED COSTS THAT WILL
BE COVERED BY VALLEY WATER- I
LIKE TO NOTE THAT BOTH AGENCIES
HAVE WORKED EXTENSIVELY WITH
OUR OFFICE ON THESE MEASURES.
SECONDED THE COMMITTEES- I WITH
WITH THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS
THIS LEGISLATION WILL AUTHORIZE
BEST VALUE CONTRACTING AN
EXPEDITED JUDICIAL REVIEW FOR
SEQUEL OF CLAIMS- THE EXPEDITED
JUDICIAL REVIEW WAS MADE
POSSIBLE WITH COMMITMENTS FROM
THE WATER DISTRICT VALLEY
WATER. TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
AND SUBSTANTIAL ENVIRONMENTAL
CONCESSIONS AND THE BENEFITS
INCLUDING REQUIRING THE PROJECT
TO DELIVER NET ZERO GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS. AS I MENTIONED
THIS IS A DIFFERENT ISSUE WITH
REGIONAL IMPACTS THIS DAM WAS
BUILT IN NINETEEN FIFTY AND
WHEN IT WAS BUILT IT WAS BUILT
TO THE SAFETY STANDARDS OF THAT
TIME- BUT AS WE KNOW THE DAM
WAS CONSTRUCTED ALONG TO
EARTHQUAKE FAULT LINES THE
CALAVERAS. A FAULT WHICH IS A
MAJOR BRANCH OF THE SAN ANDREAS
FAULT SYSTEM. AND THE DAM ALSO
SITS DIRECTLY ABOVE THE CAIRO
CREEK FAULTLINE- AND TODAY THE
STATE HAS SOME SERIOUS
STRUCTURAL INTEGRITY ISSUES- IN
THE EVENT OF AN EARTHQUAKE A
BREACH OF THE DAM AT FULL
CAPACITY WOULD BE CATASTROPHIC.
IT SHOULD BE MENTIONED THAT
WHILE VALLEY WATER CAN DRAIN
THE DAM- COMMITTEE V. EIGHT A
MAJOR RAIN EVENT THE WATERSHED
CAN REFILL THE MUCH FASTER THAN
IT CAN BE DRAINED. AND SO IF A
BREACH OF THE WERE TO OCCUR
IT'S PREDICTED THAT FROM THE
SIDE OF THE DAM FLOODING WOULD
EXTEND MORE THAN FORTY MILES.
FLOODING OVER A HALF DOZEN
CITIES AND TOWNS AND SUBMERGING
MUCH OF THE SILICON VALLEY.
MOST LIKELY THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
AT A MINIMUM WOULD NOT BE ABLE
TO EVACUATE. RESULTING IN A
SIGNIFICANT LOSS OF PROPERTY
AND POTENTIALLY LIFE. AND SO
THIS BILL IS AN URGENCY BILL
CONTAINS AN URGENCY CLAUSE.
BECAUSE ON FEBRUARY TWENTIETH
THE FEDERAL ENERGY REGULATORY
COMMISSION FOR. ISSUED A DAM
SAFETY DIRECTIVE- A DIRECTIVE
REQUIRING THE VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT. TO FULLY DRAW DOWN
THIS STARTING OCTOBER FIRST OF
THIS YEAR. THAT'S ACCORDING TO
THE FEDERAL ORDER THIS.
RETROFIT IS FOR EX NUMBER ONE
HIGHEST DAM SAFETY PRIORITY
PROJECT IN THE NATION. A
BECAUSE BASED ON NEW
INFORMATION REGARDING THE DAM
TO SEISMIC VULNERABILITIES THE
DAM SAFETY RISK IS ON
ACCEPTABLY HIGH. AND THIS
FEDERAL DIRECTIVE- TO BEGIN
TRADING THE LARGEST RESERVOIR
IN THE COUNTY SANTA CLARA POSES
MANY MANY CHALLENGES- THE
DRAINAGE WILL SEVERELY REDUCE
WATER RESERVES GROUNDWATER
BASINS COULD BE IMPACTED IN THE
COUNTY. AND FOR A STATE THAT'S
PRO TO DROUGHT THIS IS A HUGE
HUGE PROBLEM. AND SO AGAIN THIS
URGENCY LEGISLATION SEEKS TO
EXPEDITE PERMITTING CONTRACT
REQUIREMENTS IN ORDER TO
FACILITATE CONSTRUCTION
IMPROVEMENTS AT THIS. IT WOULD
ALSO CREATE OVER FIVE THOUSAND
GOOD PAYING JOBS AT A TIME WHEN
WE NEED THE MOST. THAT'S A WITH
ME THIS MORNING TO TESTIFY IS
THE CITY OF MORGAN HILLS MAYOR
RICH CONSTANTIJN. AND ALSO
VALLEY WATERS DIRECTOR OF STATE
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS BARTRAM
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND JUST BEFORE WE GO TO
THOSE WITNESSES. I DO WANT TO
SEE IF SENATOR STERN WHO WORKED
WITH YOU ON THE AMENDMENTS HAD
A COMMENT THAT HE WANTED TO
MAKE BEFORE WE GO TO- WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION.
SENATOR STERN DID YOU HAVE A
COMMENT ON THIS LEGISLATION.
SURE JUST BRIEFLY THANK YOU.
CENTER MONNING AND TO THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR. BEING SENT
TO A STEADY STEWARD OF THIS
BILL AND GETTING IT THIS FAR IN
A TOUGH CLIMATE. IT SAYS THIS
IS AN ISSUE THAT DOESN'T JUST
AFFECT- MORGAN HILL BUT IF YOU
LOOK AT THE FLOOD MAPPING THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT IT'S LIKE THE
ENTIRE REGION ALL THE WAY OUT
TO THE COOKED IN THE INLAND
COAST REGION- YOU HAVE TO. YOU
HAVE TO LAND AND- COMPLEX
PROBLEM HERE WE'RE YOU'RE
MITIGATING ONE MASSIVE CLIMATE
RISK WHICH IS OF FLOODING AND
INUNDATION BUT INTO ANOTHER IN
THE PROCESS WHICH IS LOW WATER
SUPPLIES DURING POTENTIAL
DROUGHT SO SPEED IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT HERE BUT I APPRECIATE
THAT THE AUTHOR THIS. RECOGNIZE
THAT- WE HAVE TO GO FAST BUT WE
STILL HAVE TO ACCOUNT FOR ALL
THE DOWNSTREAM ENVIRONMENTAL
RESTORATION NEEDS THAT WERE
SETTLED A WHILE AGO AND THAT
THAT NEED TO HAPPEN REALLY IN
PARALLEL I THINK WE LANDED IN A
REALLY GOOD COMPROMISE HERE AND
I APPRECIATE- NOT JUST TO THE
SANTA CLARA VALLEY- AUTHORITY
BUT BUT ALSO OUR OUR%
ENVIRONMENTAL STAKEHOLDERS WITH
CAL TROUT AND SOME OF THE
DOWNSTREAM ENTITIES TO MAKE
SURE THAT. WE GET MITIGATION
GOING- MOST OF ALL I WANT TO
SAY THAT- WITHOUT FEDERAL
ACTION WE WOULDN'T HAVE TO GO
TO WORK AT TO GET AM AND
LOFGREN AND ROLE T. YOU KNOW
WE'RE LUCKY TO SOME INNER
AGENCY MOVEMENT FEDERAL SO I
THINK THIS IS FOR. COP AND I
YOU WITH IS MEMBER AND AT
BEFORE THIS THING GETS TO THE
FOR I THINK ALL THE WOMEN OF
THE G. THERE ARE OUT ME AND NOW.
SHOULD BE. IN A- TEXT FORM SO
I'M I THINK COMMITTEE FEEL
CONFIDENT THAT WE GOT A GRANY.
TEXTURE FOR US. AND DURABLE
DEAL AND THAT I'LL I'LL SEE DO
THIS BY IN THE F THE TESTAMENT
ROBERT. HAGER OKAY THANK YOU
SENT STERN WE'RE GONNA TAKE A
QUICK. WE'RE GOING TO DO THE
REACH. ON OUR QUORUM- I WAS
INFORMED WE COULD NOT USE THE
REMOTE MEMBER TO ESTABLISH OUR
QUORUM SAYING ASK OUR
CONSULTANT TO PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL AGAIN TO ESTABLISH QUORUM.
MORNING HERE ON IN HERE JONES-
JONES HERE ALLEN. ALLEN HERE
BURGESS. URGES HERE CABALLERO
CABALLERO HERE HERTZBERG HUESO
JACKSON YES JACKSON HERE. THANK
YOU IS QUORUM IS ESTABLISHED
AND NOW WE WILL GO TO WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT LET ME JUST AGAIN
REMIND PEOPLE THE GROUND RULES
WE WILL ALLOW FOR MINUTES FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT TO DIVIDE
HOWEVER THEY CHOOSE AND FOUR
MINUTES FOR THE PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. WITH
THE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AFTER
THE PRIMARY TESTIMONY WE WILL
GO TO- OTHERS WHO'LL ADD ON
WITH NAME AFFILIATION AND
VOICING THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE
SUPPORT SIDE IN THEIR
OPPOSITION FOR THE OPPOSITION
SIDE. MODERATOR CAN YOU BRING
IN MAYOR RICH CONSTANTIJN MAYOR
CITY OF MORGAN HILL.
TRANSLOCATED DIRECTLY BELOW
ANDERSON DAM RESERVOIR IF THE
DAM FAILS WHEN IT'S AT FULL
CAPACITY A THIRTY FOOT WALL OF
WATER WOULD SWEEP THROUGH OUR
COMMUNITY IN FIVE TO FIFTEEN
MINUTES AND THAT'S JUST THE
BEGINNING OF THE DEVASTATION
THAT WOULD RUN NORTH THROUGH
SILICON VALLEY AND SOUTH TO
MONTEREY BAY. THE EARTHQUAKE
FAULTS ONE LOCATED ABOUT A MILE
AWAY FROM THE DAM AND THE OTHER
DIRECTLY UNDERNEATH THE DAM ARE
NOT DORMANT WE HAD A FOUR POINT
OH EARTHQUAKE EARLIER THIS
YEAR. IMAGINE WONDERING EVERY
TIME THE SHAKES IF A THIRTY
FOOT WALL OF WATER IS HEADED
YOUR WAY I CAN TELL YOU THAT
GETTING THIS M. REMOVED AND
REPLACED AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
IS A BIT HIGH FOR EVERYBODY
WILL UNDERSTAND WHAT THAT
STICK. THAT'S WHY THE CITY OF
MORGAN HILL STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. IN A TO PROTECT
LIVES PROPERTY. A REBUILT DOWN
OR STORE PRECIOUS WATER
SUPPLIES TO NOT JUST MIGHT
CITY. BUT ALMOST A DOZEN OTHERS
THROUGHOUT SILICON VALLEY. THE
DAM PROVIDES FLOOD PROTECTION
AND WATER FOR GROUNDWATER
RECHARGE WHICH SUPPLIES SHALL
COUNTY AGRICULTURE AND PREVENT
SUBSIDENCE AND ALL THE PROBLEMS
IT BRINGS. BOTTOM LINE IS WHY
WE NEED A NEW DAM IS THAT IT'S
EXPECTED POSSIBLE. THAT'S WHY
IN I WAS IN WASHINGTON DC THIS
PAST DECEMBER MEETING WITH
CONGRESSWOMAN THE AWKWARD AND
THE OTHER THREE MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS WHO REPRESENT OUR
COUNTY WHO ARE ALL WORKING HARD
TO MAKE SURE FEDERAL
REGULATIONS DON'T TIE THIS
PROJECT UP. IN RED TAPE FOUR
YEARS. I HAVE TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REVENGE WENT UP
THE BATTLE HERE IN SACRAMENTO
TO MAKE SURE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DOES ITS PART TO
PROTECT PUBLIC SAFETY AND THE
WATER SUPPLY. FOR THE TWO
MILLION PEOPLE. SANTA CLARA
COUNTY. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I
THANK YOU FOR GATHERING
COMMITTEE TODAY TO HEAR THIS
BILL AMID A PANDEMIC. THE WORK
THAT YOU DO IT'S IMPORTANT TO
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AND SO
IT AB THREE ZERO ZERO FIVE. THE
CHOICE BEFORE YOU IS TO
CONTINUE THE DELAYS OF ANDERSON
DAM PROJECT AND READ THE PUBLIC
SAFETY AND WATER SUPPLY. OR
VOTE HI. AB THREE ZERO ZERO
FIVE INCLUDING CRITICAL
PROVISIONS TO EXPEDITE JUDICIAL
REVIEW TO FAST TRACK A PROJECT
THAT WILL PROTECT HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WHO LIVE
AND WORK IN THE INUNDATIONS
OUT. ON BEHALF OF THE PEOPLE OF
MORGAN HILL I BOUGHT I URGE
YOUR IBOOK THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU MR
MAYOR IN WE WILL NOW GO TO
MISTER BARTON BROOM DIRECTOR OF
STATE GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
VALLEY WATER- MODERATOR COULD
YOU BRING MISTER BOWMAN AND YOU
HAVE ABOUT. ONE MINUTE FORTY
SECONDS REMAINING. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE BOARD BERMAN
REPRESENTING SANTA CLARA VALLEY
WATER DISTRICT ALSO KNOWN AS
VALLEY WATER I LIKE TO THINK
SENATOR STARTED THE COMMUNITY
FOR THEIR ENGAGEMENT ON THIS
CRITICAL DAM SAFETY BILL BAILEY
WATER SUPPORTS THE AMENDMENTS
IN THE BILL ANALYSIS WITH THE
TECHNICAL CHANGES AS NEGOTIATED
WITH CAL TROUT AND OTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL ADVOCATES AB
THREE THOUSAND FIVE WILL
EXPEDITE THE ANDERSON DANCE
SEISMIC RETROFIT PROJECT EIGHT
FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTY SIX
MILLION DOLLAR REMOVAL AND
REPLACEMENT OF THE EXISTING
DAM. WHICH IS VULNERABLE TO
FAILURE DURING. A LARGE
EARTHQUAKE. PROJECT WILL
INCLUDE DOWNSTREAM AND TO PUT
PER. AND FOR THE- IT ALSO WILL
CREATE FIFTY FOUR HUNDRED GOOD
PAYING JOBS BEGINNING IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. MAKING THE PROJECT
A WELL TIMED LOCALLY FUNDED
ECONOMIC STIMULUS. PATTERSON IS
THE LARGEST RESERVOIRS SANTA
CLARA COUNTY AND WENT FORWARD
HOPE ENOUGH WATER TO SUPPLY
NEARLY A MILLION PEOPLE FOR A
YEAR WHAT'S THE PROJECT HINGED
DOWNSTREAM ENVIRONMENTAL
ENHANCEMENTS ARE COMPLETED.
THAT THE HABITAT FOR FISHERIES
WILL BE SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVED
HOWEVER DELAYS ON THE ANDERSON
PROJECT ALSO DELAY
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPROVEMENTS
DELAY CRITICAL PUBLIC SAFETY
PROTECTION AND DELAY
RESTORATION OF THE REGION'S
WATER SUPPLY SECURITY. TODAY
THE COMMITTEE IS CONSIDERING
CRITICAL AMENDMENTS THAT ARE
THE PRODUCT OF EXTENSIVE
NEGOTIATIONS WITH NUMEROUS
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEES
ENVIRONMENTAL ADVOCATES AND
STATE AGENCIES- THE NEGOTIATED
AMENDMENTS. NOT ONLY REQUIRE
ANDERSON THE ANDERSON PROJECT
TO HAVE NET ZERO GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS BUT ALSO ACCELERATE
THE- ENHANCEMENTS FOR FUTURE.
MISTER BARNUM NEED. TO WRAP UP
PLEASE. THANK YOU- THE EDISON
PROJECT EXPEDITES PUBLIC SAFETY
ENVIRONMENTAL ENHANCEMENTS
WATER SUPPLY RIVER RELIABILITY
AND ECONOMIC STIMULUS- WE URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB TWO
THOUSAND FIVE THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND I'M JUST
GONNA NO THAT WAS ABOUT A
TWENTY SECOND OVER RUN I'M
GONNA FOR THAT SAME- EXTRA TIME
TO THE- OPPOSITION'S PRIMARY.
WITNESSES THEY SPEAK BUT NOW WE
WILL GO TO. OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT TO ADD NAME.
ORGANIZATIONAL AFFILIATION. IN
YOUR SUPPORT WILL LOOK FIRST TO
ANY WITNESSES IN THE HEARING
ROOM HERE IN FORTY TWO OH THREE
ANYONE HERE TO TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT. OF AB THREE ZERO ZERO
FIVE SEEING NONE WE WILL GO TO
ROOM. ONE FIFTEEN ONE TWELVE
I'M SORRY ONE TWELVE I SEE NO
WITNESSES. IN THE QUEUE THERE-
TO PRESENT TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
SO NOW WE WILL GO TO OUR PHONE
LINES AND MODERATOR AGAIN A
REMINDER PLEASE OFFER YOUR
NAME. ORGANIZATION AFFILIATION
IF ANY IN YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL WE'RE HEARING FROM
SUPPORTERS OF AB THREE ZERO
ZERO FIVE AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU MODERATOR. THANK YOU. AND
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE EIGHT ZERO
ZERO FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE ZERO ZERO
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND AN
OPERATOR WILL TAKE YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PROVIDE THAT TO YOU.
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND START WITH
MINE ONE EIGHTY. NINE ONE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING SENATORS LAURIE JOHNSON
ON BEHALF OF THE MARK MONTEREY
PENINSULA WATER MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT IN THE CITY OF
WATSONVILLE AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MICHAEL RAT AGAIN ON
BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS SANTA CLARA COUNTY
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. MY AND
TWO HUNDRED AND ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. OUR
SYSTEM HI ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
AND EARNED A REPORT ABOUT. TWO
HUNDRED AND THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE. GOOD MORNING CHEN
MEMBERS USES THOMAS GARCIA WITH
THE BALKAN GROUP ON BEHALF OF
OUR CLIENTS AND AGAIN WATER
COMPANY AND SUPPORT. NINE ONE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SH THANK YOU JEFF AND I AGREED
WITH ADULT IN GILBERT ROBESON
SMITH ON BEHALF OF THE SAMPLES
GO PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
ALSO IN SUPPORT. NINE SIXTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. CHRIS WROTE ON BEHALF
OF THE SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. IN ONE MOMENT FOR A
FEW MORE TO HAVE THEIR MY
NUMBERS GATHERED. ONCE AGAIN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
AB THREE ZERO ZERO FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ME JUST A MOMENT FOR THE
LINE NUMBERS. AND NINE THIRTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR JERRY THIS IS MARK
SPENCER MAKER CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE SANTA CLARA VALLEY OPEN
SPACE ABILITY AND SUPPORT. AND
NINE SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS TWENTY
JEREMY SMITH HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
OFTEN SUPPORT. ONE FOR A LAST.
NINE ONE FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS NATALIE MAC ON
BEHALF OF MID PENINSULA
REGIONAL OPEN SPACE DISTRICT
ALSO REGISTERING SUPPORT FOR
SAVE THE BAY IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE ZERO ZERO FIVE. THERE ARE
NO FURTHER LINES IN Q. THANK
YOU ONE MORE CHECK ANYONE
CALLING IN IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE ZERO ZERO FIVE MODERATOR
ONE LAST CHECK PLEASE. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE EIGHT ZERO
ZERO FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND ONCE
AGAIN. IF YOU WISH TO. COMMENT
IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE ZERO
ZERO FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. THERE
ARE NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE ZERO ZERO
FIVE. THANK YOU MODERATOR WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO THE LEAD
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION- WE
HAVE. PATRICK SALMON WELL OF
CALIFORNIA TROUT AND FOLLOWED
BY ANDY LIEBMAN BOMB- WITH THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA-
MODERATOR COULD YOU PLEASE
BRING IN. THE LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. AND
JUST A REMINDER FOUR MINUTES
AND TWENTY SECONDS IN
OPPOSITION TO BE DIVIDED
HOWEVER YOU CHOOSE. AND PATRICK
SEMINAL YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOU MAY BE ON
MUTE. GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON PATRICK'S
DANIEL THE BAY AREA DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA TROUT. CALDERON HAS
BEEN ENGAGED IN OPPOSITION AB
THREE THOUSAND AND FIVE FROM
THE START. AFTER MANY
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE MISS COMMITTEE AND THE
SPONSOR WE HAVE REACHED
AGREEMENT ON A FRAMEWORK FOR
AMENDMENTS RELATED TO THE
FISHERIES AND AQUATIC HABITAT
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT. FACED
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT TURNS AT
THE SANTA CLARA VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT HAS NOT IN HERE TOO
FOR NEARLY TWENTY YEARS. WE
TRULY APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RESISTANCE TEAM AND THIS
COMMITTEES WONDERS TO WORK WITH
CAL TROUT AND FINDING A PATH
FORWARD. AND SANTA CLARA VALLEY
WATER DISTRICT VERBAL COMMIT TO
MAKE RIGHT. WE AGREED THE ONLY
WAY ANDERSON DAM RIGHT DEPRIVE
IS NOW. TO PROTECT LIFE AND
PROPERTY. HOWEVER WE OPPOSED TO
THIS BASS UPON. EXPERT AND
CURTAIL PERMITTING REVIEW
PROCESS FOR A RESOURCE AGENCIES.
BUT DANGEROUS PRECEDENT FOR
MANY FUTURE RETROFIT PROJECTS
IN CALIFORNIA NOT ONLY IN THIS
COUNTY BUT STATEWIDE IN THE
NEXT DECADE. AND BY LOCAL
REGULATIONS. AND ALTERATION OF
THE STATE WATER BOARD
PERMITTING PROCESS THAT IS
ESSENTIAL TO MINIMIZE ADVERSE
IMPACTS ON BENEFICIAL USES
RIGHT TO ADEQUATELY PROTECT
PUBLIC TRUST RESOURCES. I NEED
FOR THE ANDERSON RETROFIT WOULD
PUBLIC NEARLY A DECADE AGO BUT
DISAGREE WITH THE IMPETUS FOR
THIS BILL AND THE STATED NEED
FOR EXPEDITED PERMITTING AND
REVIEW. THIS BILL ALSO
LEGALIZED THE SAME UNILATERAL
DECISION MAKING BY THE WATER
DISTRICT THAT IT NEARLY WIPED
OUT FEDERALLY THREATENED
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA COAST DEAL
AND IN COYOTE CREEK. AND
EXCLUDE THE CASE IN THIS ONE
PARTY TO WORK IN GOOD FAITH IN
THIS WATERSHED FOR NEARLY
TWENTY YEARS. WE WHOLE. SANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER READ THAT
SENATOR STERN AND THIS
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH US
AND DEVELOPING A FRAMEWORK
AGREEMENT WITH THE WATER
DISTRICT. AND COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THAT ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS. A SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND THEN WILL MOVE TO THE
SECOND PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION ANDY LEVON BOMB.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND SENATOR AND EVEN
BOMBS FROM THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
CALIFORNIA REGRETFULLY IN
OPPOSITION AB THREE ZERO ZERO
FIVE. OPPOSITION IS LIMITED.
AND I DID REVIEW AND E. EXCEL
WOUND PROVISION OF A ONE TWO
ONE WE CAN SIMPLY. OF A
JUDICIAL CAL ANNUAL SCHEDULE
FOR WILL BUT WE REGARDS TO THE
VIEW AND DAY AND- REVIEW. SHE
COULD GET THERE ARE IN UNDER
LAW UNDER PRESSURE EXPERTS TO
CHECK. ONE ONE SIX SEVEN ONE
EIGHT OF THE PUBLIC RESOURCE
CODE IN BOTH THE- COURT AND THE
FOURTEENTH HE'LL- BE BELIEVE
GETS YOU HIGH AND SHALL DAYS
FINALLY IS ON. UNREAL IF SHE-
AND IF PLACE AND HONORING BURKE
ON SENATE OR TRUST ALL OF THE
ISSUE. THERE'S READ WHY YOU
MIGHT AND CHECK THAT JUDICIAL
TIME FRAME THIS NOT USE THE
BALL SHE COOKIE TO THEIR- AND
HE IF NOT LATEST REQUEST OF A
PART. BUT IT. THE CASE THAT ONE
OR MORE WILL REQUIRE. MAKE IT
UNFEASIBLE. FINALLY A QUARTER
ANTICIPATING AND I THINK THE
LEGISLATURE AND MANY PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA ARE ANTICIPATING
SIGNIFICANT PANDEMIC RELATED
LITIGATION IN THE COMING YEAR
AND HERE'S- OKAY JUST TO THE
FRONT OF THE LINE AND CANNOT
OVER THE LIFE OF THE PROJECT
COULD HAVE AN ADVERSE IMPACT ON
OTHER CASES. THIS IS UNLAWFUL
IN FORECLOSURE ACTION AMONG
OTHERS FOR THESE REASONS WE ARE
AND. RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN THAT IN
RIGHT AT. FOUR FIFTEEN SO THANK
YOU WITNESSES FOR OBSERVING OUR
TIMELINES WE'RE NOW GOING TO GO
TO. THE HEARING ROOM TO SEE IF
THERE IS ANYONE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE WHO WISHES TO ADD
THEIR NAME OR AFFILIATION IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE WE WILL
MOVE TO ROOM ONE TWELVE TO SEE
IF THERE ARE ANY WITNESSES
THEY'RE SEEING NONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. WE WILL ASK OUR
MODERATOR TO BRING IN.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION BY
PHONE WITH THE REMINDER PLEASE
SHARE YOUR NAME. ORGANIZATION
AFFILIATION IF ANY AND YOU'RE
OPPOSITION NO FURTHER TESTIMONY
ON THE MERITS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
IN OPPOSITION OF AB THREE ZERO
ZERO FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION OF A. B. THREE ZERO
ZERO FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THE GIRL AT THIS TIME. AND ONE
MOMENT WHILE WE GATHER THE LINE
NUMBERS. NINE THIRTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU CAN STONE STONE
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF
ASSOCIATED BUILDERS AND
CONTRACTORS NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER WE HAVE A ARE VERY
RESPECTFUL OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED- CONDITION WE ARE ONLY
A FEW THAT PROVISION THAT
REQUIRES SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE REQUIREMENTS THAT
DON'T APPLY IF A PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENT IS IN EFFECT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MINE TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING CHRIS ANDERSON ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES I WAS
HAVING TROUBLE GETTING THROUGH
EARLIER JUST WANTED TO REGISTR
OUR ASSOCIATION SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
NOTED. NINE ONE SEVENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING SENATORS
FOR RICHARD MARCUSSEN
REPRESENTING THE WESTERN
ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION AND THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF
ASSOCIATED BUILDERS AND
CONTRACTORS OPPOSED TO THE
SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKFORCE
LOOPHOLE INCLUDED IN THE BILL
THANK YOU. ONE ONE NINETY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO I'M VINCENT YET
THOUGH- THE CALIFORNIA ANGLER
AND I WANT TO OPPOSE. SB THREE
THIRTY THANK YOU. MINE TOO
FIFTIES YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE I AM MAKE
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE AND
LOCALLY AND A WILDLIFE BUT-
MAN'S. OUTDOORSMAN I WHO.
OPPOSITION HE EIGHTY THIRTY
THIRTY SO I THINK WE'RE HAVING
A COUPLE WITH WHO WING IN ON A
THAT WE HAVE A YET HEARD AB
THIRTY ITEM FOR SO WE'RE TAKING
OPPOSITE COMMENT RIGHT NOW.
ON'T AB THREE Z. ZERO FIVE
REGARDING LEERING ANDERSON
DAMAGE INTERESTED. MODERATOR
ANY FURTHER- CALLERS IN
OPPOSITION TO AB. THREE ZERO
ZERO FIVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MR MINE TO FORTY. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NO
COMMENT. THANK YOU THAT MAYBE
SOMEONE IN THE QUEUE FOR LATER
BILL SO THANK YOU AND WE'RE
DOING OUR BEST HERE BUT WE'RE
ON ITEM ONE AB THREE ZERO ZERO
FIVE THAT'S NOT YOUR BILL
PLEASE. YOU CAN DIAL ONE ZERO
TO GET OUT OF THIS LINE AND
THEN COME BACK IN WHEN WE GET
TO YOUR BILL. THANK YOU.
MODERATOR ANY FURTHER COLLAR
SON AB. THREE ZERO ZERO FIVE.
YES. NINE ONE NINETY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU. ROBBIE ON BEHALF OF
SAN FRANCISCO BAY KEEPER AND
CITIZENS COMMITTEE TO COMPLETE
THE REFUGE IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO AB THREE ZERO ZERO FIVE. ONE
NINE NINE TWO SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE AHEAD. I WANT TO I
AM OPPOSED. TO THREE ZERO ZERO
FIVE. NINE ONE EIGHTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE ONE EIGHTY TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE NINE ONE EIGHTY TWO
DROPPED. JUST A MOMENT FOR A
LAST TWO LINES. NINE TO SIXTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS KATE'S AND I
AM AN AVID CALIFORNIA ANGLER
AND I OPPOSE A. B. THE THIRTY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY AGAIN
THAT'S NOT ON THE BILL WE'RE
HEARING RIGHT NOW WE ARE
HEARING AB. THREE ZERO ZERO
FIVE. YOUR OPPOSITION ANA LATER
BILL IS NOTED. MODERATOR ANY
FURTHER CALLERS IN OPPOSITION
TO AB THREE ZERO ZERO FIVE. WE
HAVE ONE LAST. NINE NINE TO
SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CALLER DROPPED
OUT OF. THANKS FOR THE COMMENTS
IN QUEUE FOR A. B. THREE ZERO
ZERO FIVE IN OPPOSITION. OKAY
THANK YOU MODERATOR THANK YOU
pBRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AND
LET ME JUST. EXERCISE THE
PREROGATIVE OF THE CHAIR TO
OFFER. A FEW COMMENTS I ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP. I'M A PROUD CO
AUTHOR ON THIS BILL AND I WANT
TO THANK- THE CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE SENATOR STERN IN HIS.
STAFF ANA LEAD CONSULTANT. FOR
THEIR EFFORTS IN WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO REACH. I THINK
A VERY STRONG RESOLUTION WITH
WITH ACCEPTED AMENDMENTS BY THE
AUTHOR. WE'VE HEARD FROM
SUPPORTERS AND OPPONENTS LET ME
JUST COMMENT ON THE CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE OF THE HANDER SIR
DAN ANDERSON DAM- TO HUMANS AND
TO HABITAT. WE SUFFERED A
TRAGIC- OVERFLOWED DURING THE
FLOODS STORMS THAT TOOK OUT
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF PROPERTY
DOWN CREATIVITY CREEK IN SAN
SAYING. IT MADE A LOT OF
RESIDENTS HOMELESS. IT LED TO-
A MERCHANT SEE RESPONSE. DURING
THE FLOODING OF THE REGION. THE
DAM STILL SERVED A PURPOSE
DESPITE ITS OVERFLOW THAT. THAT
TRAGEDY WASN'T AND AS WE'VE
HEARD FROM WITNESSES THE
SEISMIC SAFETY ISSUES THAT HAVE
LED TO BOTH STATE AND FEDERAL
INTERVENTION- RECOGNIZE THAT
THE SEISMIC RISK POSED TO
RESIDENTS OF MORGAN HILL IN
DOWN STREAM DOWN THE CODY
CREEK- THIS POSES A SIGNIFICANT
IMMEDIATE URGENT. PUBLIC SAFETY
RISK AND PARTIES HAVE PULLED
TOGETHER THEY'VE BEEN WORKING
ON THIS FOR YEARS- IN TRYING TO
COORDINATE AMONG DIFFERENT
FEDERAL AGENCIES DIFFERENT
STATE AGENCIES CHARGE WITH
WILDLIFE AND FISHERY PROTECTION
CHARGED WITH PUBLIC SAFETY AND
DAM SAFETY. AND I JUST WANT TO
APPLY TO ALL THE PARTIES THAT
HAVE COME TOGETHER TO TRY TO
MOVE THIS CRITCAL PUBLIC
SAFETY ISSUE FORWARD I THINK
THERE'S BEEN CONCERN RANGED
ABOUT THE USE OF EXPEDITED
REVIEW I JUST WANT TO REMIND
EVERYONE THERE IS NOTHING IN
THIS BILL. IT EXEMPTS THE
SEQUEL REQUIREMENTS THERE ARE
NO SEQUEL EXEMPTIONS THERE IS
EXPEDITED REVIEW BUT THERE WILL
STILL BE SEQUEL REVIEW AND
COMPLIANCE- REQUIRED COMPLIANCE
AS THE PROJECT MOVES FORWARD-
THIS IS OF CRITICAL IMPORTANCE.
NOT ONLY TO THE RESIDENTS OF
THE DISTRICT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RIVAS AND I REPRESENT THAT NAME
DURING DISTRICTS REPRESENTED BY
SENATOR CABALLERO REPRESENTED-
TO THE NORTH IN SAN JOSE SANTA
CLARA COUNTY. AND SO AS WE MOVE
FORWARD I WANT O THANK ALL
THOSE WHO HAVE PULLED TOGETHER
SPECIAL THANKS TO CONGRESSWOMAN
SO LOFGREN WHO'S MADE THIS A
PRIORITY AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
IS WELL. IN WITH THOSE COMMENTS
I WILL. TURN THE OTHER MEMBERS
FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS. PLEASE
AND WE DO HAVE A MOTION ON THE
BILL FROM VICE CHAIR JONES AND
I RECOGNIZE SENATOR JACKSON. S.
THANK YOU AND I APPRECIATE THE
URGENCY OF THIS- AND SO I'M I'M
KIND OF TORN. BECAUSE PUBLIC
SAFETY OF COURSE IS SO
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT MY CONCERN
AGAIN IS- AS WE REQUIRE THE
COURTS ARE TO DO EXPEDITED
REVIEW THERE ARE THERE ARE FEW
PROBLEMS ASSOCIATED WITH THAT
ONE IS I DON'T THINK WE REALLY
CAN FORCE THEM TO DO A REVIEW
IN TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
DAYS- IT'S KIND OF ASPIRATIONAL
ONE OF THE REASONS IS BECAUSE
WE DON'T REALLY HAVE CONTROL
OVER THE COURTS AND THE
PROCEDURAL- MANNER WITH WHICH
THEY- OPERATE. THIS A ARE NOW
WITH IN THE MIDST OF THIS
PANDEMIC- WE ARE FIGHTING TO
RETAIN THE ABEYANCE ON FICTIONS
OUR CRIMINAL COURTS ARE
BACKLOGGED BECAUSE OF THE-
MONTHS WHERE WE HAVE ALSO
WITHHELD THE PROCESS BY WHICH-
OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE PROCEEDS
AND OF COURSE THAT THE LAW THE
CONSTITUTION ALLOWS FOR SPEEDY
TRIALS- WE'VE SEEN A NUMBER OF
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS WORKING WITH
PUBLIC DEFENDERS TO KEEP. THE
COURTS FUNCTIONING EVEN THOUGH
THE REALLY NOT FUNCTIONING AND
NOW WE'RE GOING TO DO THIS-
EXPEDITED REVIEW. SO THE IN THE
IN ITS CURRENT CONTEXT I'M
CONCERNED IN THAT REGARD ALSO
THE MORE EXPEDITED REVIEWS THAT
WE DIRECT FOR THESE VARIOUS
KINDS OF PROJECTS THE QUESTION
THAT COMES TO ME IS. WHAT
WHAT'S THE NEXT URGENCY THAT
REQUIRES IMMEDIATE CARE BECAUSE
OUR- INFRASTRUCTURE IS IN
DISREPAIR AND- IT'S DANGEROUS
AND SO MANY DIFFERENT AREAS SO
I AM TORN BECAUSE I RECOGNIZE
AND I DON'T WANT TO SEE- THIS
LEVEL OF POTENTIAL DISASTER.
WHICH APPARENTLY DOES EXIST ON
THE OTHER HAND I'M A LITTLE
WORRIED ABOUT. NGUYEN IS AN
URGENT PROJECT ENERGY PROJECT I
MAYBE IT'S THE PROVERBIAL
CAMEL'S NOSE UNDER THE TENT- SO
I I'M GONNA STAY OFF THE BILL-
I DO. NOT SUPPORT THE EFFORT IT
IS A CONCERN I SIT ON THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL ARCHERS SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE I IT'S PART
MY JOB TO TRY TO DO WHAT I CAN
TERMS A POLICY TO KEEP THE
PROCESS AS- REALIST S. AS PART.
IF THE WERE MORE YOU'RE COULD
SET UP A SEEK TYPE EXPERT. TYPE
PRICE. WHICH WAS FUNDED- I KNOW
THAT TO THE EXTENT THAT. THERE
CAN BE EXPEDITED ROUTE OF
REVIEW- IF THEY'RE IN THERE ARE
PROCEDURES NOW IN PLACE- BUT I
JUST WORRY THAT IT COULD WITH
ALL THE POTENTIAL EXPEDITED
REVIEWS WE'RE GOING TO SEE. THE
COURTS MAY VERY WELL JUST
IGNORE THEM THEY HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO DO SO. I DON'T
THINK THAT'S WHAT THEY CHOOSE
TO DO BUT WHEN WERE NOW A
SITUATION WHERE WE JUST DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH RESOURCES ONCE THE
PROVERBIAL DAMAGE BROKEN IN
TERMS OF. THE COURTS HAVING
BILL AND DO THE WORK THAT WE
EXPECT IN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM THE PRIORITIES WE GIVE
TO CASES INVOLVING IN THE CIVIL
JUSTICE SYSTEM PEOPLE WHO ARE
SIXTY FIVE YEARS. AND OLDER THE
PRIORITIES WE GIVE PEOPLE
INSERT. OF K. SALAS IT SO
THAT'S MY DILEMMA IF THE WERE
MORE. PERHAPS I DON'T OPPOSE
THE EFFORT I APPRECIATE YOUR
DOING THIS I UNDERSTAND HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS. THAT ONE
ELEMENT IS JUST OF GREAT
CONCERN TO ME AND I REALLY FEEL
THAT THAT WE NEED TO HAVE A
BETTER LOOK AT THIS AND IF WE
ARE GOING TO MAKE THOSE KINDS
OF DEMANDS ON THE COURTS ARE
GOING TO. MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE ABLE TO COMPLY WITH
THEM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR JACKSON ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS. SCENE NINE WE DO HAVE
A MOTION FROM SENATOR JONES AND
I TURN TO AUTHOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIVAS IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE S. WALL YOU KNOW AGAIN
I'M MISTER CHAIR AND YOU KNOW
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY HERE AND AGAIN
CAN'T EMPHASIZE. THE WORK BY-
THE COMMITTEE STAFF BY SENATOR
STERN WE WOULD BE HERE THIS
MORNING WITHOUT ALL OF THEIR
WORK AND ENGAGEMENT ON THIS
BILL SO REALLY APPRECIATE ALL
OF THE WORK AND- CERTAINLY AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU IN
THE SYSTEM. PASSAN AZAM. TO
ASKS CONSULTANT TO PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. AB THREE ZERO ZERO
FIVE MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS MINING NINE
AWNING HI JONES JONES HI ALAN.
ALLEN HI BOB. LARGEST HI
CABALLERO CABALLERO HI. HUESO
JACKSON BOATING JACK NOT VOTER
STERN. NINE THIRTY FIVE. SIX IT
HAS ENOUGH THAT HAS SIX VOTES
ENOUGH TO GET OUT WE WILL KEEP
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ME ABSENT
MEMBERS. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIVAS WE'RE NOW GOING TO
MOVE TO OUR FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWO. ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
SEVENTY FOUR- SENATOR ALLEN I
BELIEVE YOU'RE PRESENTING THIS
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN. AND THE FLOOR IS
YOURS 2% THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH- MEMBERS. THIS IS AB TWO
TWENTY SIX. AS YOU AS WE ALL
KNOW BECAUSE WE SPEND A LOT OF
TIME HERE AND- SOME OF US HAVE
PROPERTY HERE- SACRAMENTO
REDUCE ME FOR INTERRUPTING BUT
WE HAVE ITEM TWO IS AB THIRTY
SEVENTY FOUR. BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN FIRE PREVENTION
WILDFIRE RISK DEFENSIBLE SPACE.
YES IF YOU WOULDN'T MIND MOVING
TO THE NEXT- BILL WILL COME
BACK TO IT BECAUSE I. OKAY
THANK YOU HOLD ON ONE SEC LET
ME JUST ASK OUR CONSULTANT
TECHNICAL TEAM ARE WE OK TO
MOVE ON TO ITEM THREE WE NEED
AN AUTHOR. THAT IS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I CAN. IF YOU WANT ME TO
JUST PRESENTED I CAN DO THAT
BUT YOU CAN YOU PRESENT ITEM TO.
S. A. B. THIRTY SEVENTY FOUR.
LET ME JUST GO AHEAD AND DO IT
I DON'T HAVE THE EXACT THAT I
WAS LOOKING FOR BUT- OKAY. YOU
CAN DO IT AS WE HAVE CONFIDENCE
OKAY. SO AB THIRTY SEVENTY FOUR
ITEM FILE ITEM TO PRESENTED BY
SENATOR ALAN THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
OKAY GIVE ME ONE SECOND MEMBERS
SORRY ABOUT THIS. THIRTY
SEVENTY FOUR. I THOUGHT I HAD A
DOCUMENT HERE. THIS ANALYSIS AT
LEAST. I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE I
WORK OFF OF I BY APOLOGIZE
MEMBERS AYE AYE. YEAH I WILL
REMIND TO PLEASE WEAR MASKS
COVERING NOSE AND MOUTH AS
REQUIRED BY SENATE RULES THANK
YOU. YEAH OKAY THE DISSONANCE
SO BE THIS HAS TO DO WITH- THEM
DEFENSE SPACE AROUND HOMES. AND
REQUIRES THAT THAT GIVES IS
ALREADY COMING OUT OF OUR OF
OUT OF FOR JOHN WITH. IN IT
REQUIRES THAT LASTED FOR FIVE
AROUND HOME. HOW EMBER RESIST
AND THEN WITHIN TO THIRTY FEET
THERE ARE NEWER BUT LESS
RESTRICTIVE LIMITS- THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF OTHER PROVISIONS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE BILL BUT
AND IT'S ABOUT DEFENSIBLE SPACE
AND TRYING TO RESPOND TO. THE
CHALLENGES AND CONCERNS THAT
WE'VE HAD OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS- THE BILL'S PULL TOGETHER.
A LONG LIST OF SUPPORTERS- AND
WE DON'T HAVE ANY OPPOSITION-
THEY'VE I KNOW THE AUTHORS
WORKED VERY CLOSELY WITH.
EVERYONE FROM- FROM INSURERS TO
PROPERTY OWNER ORGANIZATIONS
CITIES. AND ALSO FIRE PHí
BOTH FOR DISTRICT AND I'M HAPPY
TO- TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT I YOU ALSO
I BELIEVE THAT WE'VE GOT SOME
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
SENATOR ALAN- WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT CAN WE
HAVE- LISTED IN SUPPORT LIZ
FORSBERG THE NATURE CONSERVANCY
WILL BE TESTIFYING. ONLINE
FOLLOWED BY RON BREMER
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION ALSO ON THE PHONE
LINE UNLESS THE MODERATOR CAN
YOU BRING IN. MS FORSBERG AND
AGAIN FOUR MINUTES TOTAL IN
SUPPORT- YOU CAN DIVIDE THE
TIME HOWEVER YOU CHOOSE-
MODERATOR- FIRST WITNESS ON AB
THIRTY SEVENTY FOUR THANK YOU.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CLIFF
FOURTH BURKE AND I'M THE
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF POLICY
FOR THE NATURE CONSERVANCY. WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB THIRTY
SEVENTY FOUR. I THINK IS A
MEMBER OF THE FIRE ADOPTED
COMMUNITY LEARNING NETWORK A
NATIONAL GROUP WORKING TO BUILD
SUSTAINABLE WILDFIRE RESILIENCE
CAPACITY A FIRE PLAN COMMUNITY.
THE COALITION HELP PEOPLE A
WILD URBAN. THAT THAT. WHILE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE HIGHSPIRE
RISK AREA. WE MUST MAKE THE
MORBIDLY TO BUYERS BUILDING
STANDARDS. BASED PROGRAM.
DIRECTION PREVENTION OF HUMAN.
AB THIRTY SEVENTY WOULD MAKE
IMPOTANT TO A AND SPACE
REQUIREMENTS AND HELP. THE
MAJORITY OF WILDFIRE INVASION
OUR CALL BY DRIVEN EMBERS
ADDRESS NINETY THE HOME
ORGANIZING BUDGET NEAR THE HOME
HE BUILT BABEL IS THAT THERE
ARE. THE NUMBER IN DOWN STRUCK
I RECOMMEND BY FIRE SCIENCE
EXPERTS AND IMPORT PART OF
WILDFIRE ADMITTED. ON THE ISSUE
AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND WELL
KNOWN MOVED TO MISTER ROEMER
MODERATOR. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN SENATORSON BOB RAYMER
WITH THE BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION SPEAKING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY SEVENTY
FOUR I'M ALSO REPRESENTING AN
INDUSTRY COALITION SUPPORTING
THIS MEASURE THAT INCLUDES THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION THE BUSINESS
PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS AND THE BUILDING
OWNERS AND MANAGERS
ASSOCIATION. FOR THE PAST
DECADE NEW HOMES IN
CALIFORNIA'S FIRE PRONE REGIONS
HAVE BEEN REQUIRED TO MEET THE
FIRE MARSHAL'S FIRE HARDENING
BUILDING STANDARDS WE ALSO KNOW
THAT HOMES COMPLYING WITH THESE
BUILDING STANDARDS ARE IGNITION
RESISTANT ONLY IF THE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE REQUIREMENTS
ARE MAINTAINED BUT WHEN WE DO
HAVE THE COMBINATION OF THE
FIRE HARDENED HOME INDEFENSIBLE
SPACE. THE RESULTS ARE
INCREDIBLE. THE PARADISE FIRE
PUMP IT MET THE FARMERS IS
BUILDING STANDARDS AND HAVE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE HAVE A
SURVIVAL RATE THREE TO FOUR
TIMES GREATER THAN THOSE THAT
DID NOT. EIGHT INCIDENTS
SENSIBLE SPACE AROUND THE HOME
IS VITAL FOR PROTECTING HOMES
AND COMMUNITIES FROM WILDFIRE
AB THIRTY SEVENTY FOUR ENHANCES
ARE DEFENSIBLE SPACE
REQUIREMENTS BY ESTABLISHING A
CRITICAL FIVE PT AMBER
RESISTANCE ZONE. THAT WILL
FURTHER REDUCE AMBER IGNITIONS
THUS PROTECTING HOMES AND LIVES
LASTLY DECEMBER RESISTANCE ZONE
WILL SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE
SAFETY OR FIRE SERVICE MEMBERS
PROVIDING ON SITE FIRE
SUPPRESSION EFFORTS. ONCE AGAIN
THE INDUSTRY COALITION SECURE
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ONE NOW SEE
IF THERE ARE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IN ROOM FORTY TWO ZERO
THREE. PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF
BY NAME AND AFFILIATION IN YOUR
SUPPORT. YES MISTER MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CHRISTMAS
CEILIDH ON BEHALF OF HUMBLE AND
MENDOCINO REDWOOD COMPANY IS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. SIGNAL
OTHERS IN FORTY TWO OR THREE
ANY ONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE SEEN NONE. WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO OUR PHONE
LINES THIS IS FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE ZERO SEVEN
FOR. A MODERATOR. THANK YOU
MISTER IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE ZERO
SEVEN FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY SEVENTY
FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. OUR FIRST.
COMMENT COMES FROM MINE ONE
TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE KATHY LYNCH
REPRESENTING THE WESTERN WOOD
PRESERVERS INSTITUTE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MY AND ONE
SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS JULIAN
ALLEN ASKING FOLLOW ON BEHALF
OF THE FIRE DISTRICT
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION AND THE MEN PLANNED
FOR A REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT ALL IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY SEVENTY FOUR THANK YOU.
MY TO NINETY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
INTO THE ALLEY CAT BURKE BUT
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IMPORT THANK YOU. NINE
THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MORNING
MISTER CHAIR THIS IS MARK
FENSTER MAKER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIPHS CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF RESOURCE CONSERVATION
DISTRICTS IN SUPPORT. NINE
THREE HUNDRED AND TEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MEMBERS OF THE MATTHEW MARGO
BUT THE CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE ZERO SEVEN
FOUR THANK YOU. NINE THREE
TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NOT BRING IT UP WITH
YOUR BILL CALIFORNIANS CORK.
NINE TWO HUNDRED AND TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MISTER TURNER
NUMBER ERIN EVANS ON BEHALF OF
THE TREE CARE INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU ONE SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. CREEK
ROAD ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. NINE
ONE NINETY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. PATRICK
MARTIN CALIFORNIA ANGLER
UNOPPOSED AB THIRTY THIRTY
THANK YOU. THAT'S ON THE WRONG
BILL WE'RE NOT HEARING THAT
BILL AT THIS POINT YEAR
OPPOSITION TO THIRTY THIRTY IS
NOTED THAT WILL BE ITEM FOR IN
OUR AGENDA- MODERATOR PLEASE
WITNESSES. IN SUPPORT NOW OF AB.
THREE ZERO SEVEN FOUR. THANK
YOU AND LINE THREE ELEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE THREE AT ELEVEN YOU MAY BE
ON MUTE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND
MOVING ON TO LINE TWENTY NINE
LINE TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CAPTAIN FREEMAN ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
ACCOUNTED REPRESENTING STATE'S
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES IN THE
COURT OF AB THREE THOUSAND FOUR
THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
ZERO SEVEN FOUR. THANK YOU- WE
HAVE KNOWN LISTED OPPOSITION-
FOR WITNESSES IT PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. I WILL
TURN TO- ARE HEARING ROOM TO
SEE IF THERE ARE ANY WITNESSES
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION SEEN NONE. MOVING TO
ROOM ONE TWELFTH INNING
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO AB
THIRTY SEVENTY FORCING NONE.
MOVED TO THE MODERATOR TO SEE
IF THERE ARE ANY PHONE LINES
FOR OPPOSITION TO AB THREE ZERO
SEVEN FOUR. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF AB
THIRTY SEVENTY FOUR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION
OF AB. THREE ZERO SEVEN FOUR
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. IN ONE MOMENT PER
LINE NUMBERS.
JUST A BRIEF
MOMENT LONGER. IN MIND THREE
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE MOMENT. MY INCREASED
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
SEVENTY OWES THE MONEY I AM ME
CALIFORNIA ANGLER AND I. OPPOSE
THIS MEASURE I THINK YOU MAY BE
CALLING ON ANOTHER BILL THAT IS
NOT BEFORE SHE HAD WE ARE ON
FILE ITEM TO AB THIRTY SEVENTY
FOUR ON FIRE PREVENTION
WILDFIRE RISK MODERATOR ANY
OTHER CALLERS IN THE QUEUE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB. THIRTY
SEVENTY FOUR. WE HAVE NOBODY IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL NOW BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE-
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS I HAVE
SENATOR JACKSON. YES THANK YOU
AND- THE AUTHOR ISN'T HERE BUT
I WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATION- I KNOW LAST YEAR
SHE BROUGHT A- A BILL THAT
CONTAINED THIS PARTICULAR
DEFENSIBLE SPACE- ISSUE- IS.
SOMEONE REPRESENTING A DISTRICT
THAT WAS HAMMERED- JUST A
COUPLE YEARS AGO BY THE THOMAS
FIRE THE IMPORTANCE OF
DISPENSABLE SPACE CANNOT BE
OVERSTATED- THIS IS REALLY A
CRITICAL COMPONENT. AND I HOPE
THAT- THIS A COMBINED WITH SOME
MEASURES THAT I HAVE DONE AND
OTHERS HAVE DONE WILL REALLY
HELP US ADDRESS- WHAT FIRES
WHICH ARE PART OF THE
CALIFORNIA LANDSCAPE SO- I
DON'T KNOW IF IT'S TOO LATE TO
ADD AS A CO AUTHOR. FEW WOULD
INDICATE TO THE AUTHOR OF BOTH
APPRECIATION FOR THE L. AND
DESIRE TO BE INCLUDED. THE ARE
FUNDS THE PAGE PER MY WAS ABLE
TO OBTAIN A COUPLE YOU AGO THE
BE USED BY. TO DIFFER SPACE ON
THEIR PROPERTY SO THIS WILL
DOVETAIL. NICELY AND- IT'S A I
THINK AN IMPORTANT TO- TOOL IN
THIS TOOLBOX AND WITH THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO. COMMITTEE AUTHOR
BUT MOVE THE BILL THANK YOU WE
HAVE A MOTION ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. MOTION
FROM SENATOR JACKSON. SENATE
ALLEN WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
FOR YOUR COMMENTS SENATOR I
THINK YOU HIT THE NAIL ON THE
HEAD AS TO WHAT THIS BILL DOES-
IT'S ALL ABOUT. MAKING SURE WE
HAVE A- SANER APPROACH TO. TO
BUILDINGS AND WE AND WE DO WE
STOP YOU KNOW I NECESSARILY
PUTTINGFIREFIGHTERS AT RISK-
BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T TAKEN THE
STEPS NECESSARY TO PROTECT AMIT
MAKE HOMES. MORE DEFENSIBLE AND
HAVE THE SPACE AROUND THEM BE
MORE DEFENSIBLE SO- WE WILL I
WILL ABSOLUTELY PASSED HERE.
KIND REQUEST A CO AUTHOR OF THE
BILL. I WOULD THAT I VERY MUCH
RESPECT FOR ASPIRIN. THANK YOU
IN- WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR JACKSON AB THIRTY
SEVENTY FOUR TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS- CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB. THREE
ZERO SEVEN FOUR TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS MONNING NINE ON
IN ALL RIGHT JONES JONES HI
ALAN HI ALAN HI BURGESS.
BURGESS ALL RIGHT CABALLERO
HERTZBERG HUESO JACKSON ACTION
I ACTION BY STERN AND I. STERN
HI. SIX GOOD ENOUGH THE BILL
HAS SIX ENOUGH TO GET OUT WILL
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU SENATOR ALAN
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN WILL NOW MOVE TO ITEM
THREE. ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY TO
FOURTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE
MON- WELCOME ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS AT
FIRST I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL THE
WORK ON EIGHT THIRTY TWO
FOURTEEN I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. ON MAY
NINETEENTH TWENTY FIFTEEN SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY SAW THE LARGEST
OIL SPILL IN CALIFORNIA OVER
TWENTY FIVE YEARS THIS BILL
SEVERELY DAMAGED BUT STILL
EAGLE. AND IT'S SANTA BARBARA I
NEED YOUR FOUND HAYNES ALL
AMERICA PIE GUILTY OF A FOR
FEELING PROPERLY IT'S DANGEROUS
HIGHLY PRESSURED PIPELINE WHICH
DIRECTLY LED TO THE OIL SPILL
DESPITE THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
AND THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY
GENERAL ASKING FOR OVER A
BILLION DOLLAR IN CRIMINAL
PENALTIES THE COMPANY ESCAPED
WITH THE L. T. OF A LITTLE OVER
THREE MILLION WHICH IS A LITTLE
CRIMINAL PENALTY A. EIGHT EIGHT
BE MORE. TO HAVE. WE SUCH A
MORE AT TO HAVE. TO PAY FOR IT
SPILLED AND DO EXPENSIVE
MAINTENANCE CRIMINAL MEANT
PENALTIES FOR OIL SPILLS HAVE
NOT BEEN UPDATED SINCE THE
EARLY NINETEEN NINETIES AND
MAJOR OIL SPILLS CONTINUE TO
HAPPEN ACROSS CALIFORNIA. IT IS
ESSENTIAL TO HAVE MEANINGFUL
DETERRENCE FOR ESPECIALLY BAD
ACTORS THESE CRIMINAL PENALTIES
ARE ONLY AVAILABLE WHEN A
VIOLATOR KNOWN ONLY COPSES.
THESE AN ATHLETE I HAVE KNOWN
THAT THEIR ACTIONS WOULD LEAD
TO AN OIL SPILL IN STATE
WATERS. THIS BILL DOUBLES THE
CURRENT BASELINE PENALTIES
BRINGING THEM IN LINE WITH
INFLATION AND ALSO ALLOWS FOR
AN ADDITIONAL ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER GALLON PENALTY AT
THE DISCRETION OF THE COURT.
THIS WILL ADD SIGNIFICANTLY
MORE DETERRENTS I HAVE WITH ME
TODAY I'VE READ ABOUT IT ON THE
WITH THE SOON AND MELISSA METAL
WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION VOTERS TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMóN WE WILL
NOW GO TO THE- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY TWO FOURTEEN. IN WE WILL
ASK THE MODERATOR TO BRING IN
MR ARE A DANDO- FOLLOWED BY
MELISSA ROMERO. FOUR MINUTES TO
BE DIVIDED BETWEEN THE TWO
WITNESSES THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ON
FOREVER OF ON THEM AND I'M
PRESENTING TODAY ON BEHALF OF A
SOON IN ADDITION DEDICATED TO
DEVELOPING A IN A LEADERSHIP
AND PERSPECTIVE THE NOTION
CONSERVATION CULTURE PROTECTION
AND BECAUSE THE LACK THAT.
THAT'S VERY HAPPY TO PROVIDE
STRONG SUPPORT TO SOME NUMBER
OF THE MOANS AB THIRTY TWO
FOURTEEN THAT THE OTHER
REPRESENTS THE THREE MILLION
DOLLAR PENALTY IN THE PLAINS
CASE WAS WOEFULLY INADEQUATE.
AND THAT HAS BEEN MENTIONED BY
OUR COLLEAGUES AT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE CENTER
LOCATED IN SANTA BARBARA THE
JUDGE IN THAT CASE COMPLAINED%
THAT THE STATUTORY PENALTIES
WERE TOO LOW AND NEEDED TO BE
UPDATED. WE APPRECIATE
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCES PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON THE
OVERALL PENALTIES ASSOCIATED
WITH THE OIL SPILL- BUT IT'S
ALSO IMPORTANT BUT THERE ARE
OTHER COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THIS BILL. BEING BORNE BY THE
TAXPAYERS. ONE OF THE PLAN.
WOMEN THAT THE RECENT THAT LED
TO THE HAVING FOOT THE BILL OF
OVER A HUNDRED MILLION THE
COMMISSION PLATFORM HOLLY AND
THE WELL AT RINCON ISLAND IN
SANTA BARBARA VENTURA COUNTY.
FOR MORE THE PLANE THE AMERICAN
PIE PLAN WHICH DEPICTS OIL.
HUNDRED EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
COMES DIRECTLY FROM THE STATE'S
GENERAL FUND AND AS WE KNOW
MOVING FORWARD DURING THE
ECONOMIC RECESSION THE STATE
WILL NOT BE IN A POSITION TO BE
A LOT MORE ALL COMPANIES. FROM
THEIR OBLIGATIONS RELATED CALLS
RELATED CATASTROPHE FROM THE
TAXPAYERS AT THE TAXPAYERS
EXPENSE. AB THIRTY TWO FOURTEEN
WILL GO A VERY LONG WAY TO
ENSURING ADEQUATE PENALTIES ARE
IMPOSED- TO BE A DETERRENT AND
WHERE NECESSARY HELP DEFRAY THE
COST TO THE TAXPAYERS PLEASE BE
SINCE WE ASK WHERE I PUT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WELL NOW MOVES
TO- MISS ROMERO CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH TERRY MEMBERS
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MELISSA
ROMERO BUT THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION VOTERS. ASSEMBLY
MOUNT AB THIRTY TWO FOURTEEN AM
BUT LIKE A BANK NUMBER AND BOTH
LEADERSHIP HOLD POLLUTERS
ACCOUNTABLE AND MILLION SHORE
THAT CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS ARE
NOT LEFT BUT THE BILL I'VE BEEN
VERY POLLUTION THAT HARMS OUR
HEALTH. AND THE CLIMATE CRISIS
AND THIS BILL DOES EXACTLY THAT
HOLD POLLUTERS ACCOUNTABLE WHO
KNOWINGLY CALDWELL TOLD OR WHO
ACTUALLY DID NOT TAKE STEPS
THAT COULD HAVE AVOIDED AN OIL
SPILL BY BEING THE CRIMINAL
PENALTIES. FOR THAT ACT. COME
OUT HE- OUT WE CREATE THE
TARGET TURN. OUT BAD ACTORS
FAILING TO TAKE ACTION. TO
AVOID DEVON CALIFORNIA I KINDA
AND BIODIVERSE. BENEFITING
LOCAL. SHOWING BIRDS MARINE
WHILE. AND HUMAN HEALTH. THE
ORACLE CRIED MEAT ALL AMERICAN
PLANET TWENTY. KIND BARBARA
COUNTY NEAR REFUGIO STATE BEACH
SHOULD HAVE NEVER HAPPENED.
WHAT BECAME THE WORST OIL SPILL
IN CALIFORNIA IN TWENTY FIVE
YEARS AND IT HAPPENED AS MUCH
AS A HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILES OF
THE COAST SOUTH OIL NOW. WITH
BY PREVENTABLE MAINTENANCE
PROBLEM AND TO MAKE MATTERS
WORSE I FLOW RESPONSE REPORT
INJECTED. VOEPEL WITH THE
CURRENT HELP LEVEL WHICH IS NOT
BEEN UPDATED BACKING BUT MONTH
OLD AND A NEW THREE POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS FINE IF I THE
PROPERTY CAN REQUESTING. YOU
OVER ONE. I DON'T KNOW HOW TO
FIND WHATEVER I'M YOU KNOW WHY
LASTING DAMAGE TO IN THE THAT.
THE TEACHER AND WILDLIFE WHEN
WELL I'M NOT FIFTEEN WELL. WE
CAN'T TAKE THAT AVOID BIGGER
THAN. AND I COULDN'T HELP YOU
COULD TURNED BACK ACTORS THAT
FAIL. ACTION TO AVOID OIL FOR.
IN THE CREDIT FACTOR
ACCOUNTABLE. THE CLEAR THEIR
WORK FOR THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
THAT NOW CONTINUE AND THAT IS
LIKE THE BUT AT THE NUMBER OF
THE NON EIGHTY THIRTY YOU
FOURTEEN AND WHY URGENT AYE BUT
PAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NUMBER ONE NUMBER
TO THE OTHER WITNESS IN SO OF
AB THIRTY TWO. THIS WILL BE
AFFILIATION IN YOUR SUPPORT NO
FURTHER TESTIMONY WILL GO FIRST
TO THE HEARING ROOM HERE FORTY
TWO OH THREE SEEN NO WITNESSES
HERE IN SUPPORT MOVED TO ROOM
ONE TWELVE SEEN NO WITNESSES
THERE WILL MOVE TO OUR PHONE
LINES MODERATOR PLEASE BRING
IN. THE PAPERS ON AB SEVEN FOUR
I'M SORRY THIRTY TO FOURTEEN BY
LIMON- ITS NAME AN AFFILIATION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTY TWO FOURTEEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
TWO. YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. OUR FIRST
COMMENT COMES FROM LINE TWO
HUNDRED AND TWELVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CHARTER MEMBERS.
WARNING TRIMMERS TODD TRITON ON
BEHALF OF NEXT GEN CALIFORNIA
INTO PORT THANK YOU. AND MINE
ONE TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GARCIA FOR THE
WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION WE'RE ACTUALLY IN
OPPOSITION. DALY NOTED THAT WE
WILL TAKE OPPOSITION COMMENT IN
JUST A MOMENT THAT THAT YOUR
OPPOSITION IS NOTED THANK YOU.
MODERATOR BY TWO HUNDRED AND-
THANK YOU PLAN TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
KAREN MEMBERS THIS IS VICTORIA
ROME WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
NINE THREE HUNDRED AND FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WARNING CAME OUT ON
BEHALF OF AUDUBON CALIFORNIA AS
WELL AS JEFF AND THE COURT
THANK YOUNG. NINE THREE HUNDRED
AND TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS BRENNAN DAWSON HERE TO
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. NINE
THREE HUNDRED AND FORTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS JIM
WEINBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION- CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANKS. AND NINE SIXTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. L. A. RIVER ROAD
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE AND PARKS.
AND NINE NINETY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS MICHAEL TRUMP CINEMA
COUNTY IN SUPPORT. AND ONE
MOMENT LAST NIGHT. NINE ONE
TWENTY OKAY. SHE. WHEN ONE
TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU MAY BE A
MY NAME. CAN YOU HEAR M PUT
YES WE CAN NOW THANK YOU. THE
MORNING. TO THE BALCONY- IN
BEHALF OF THREE FIFTY SOUTH A
LOS ANGELES. INDIVISIBLE SOUTH
BAY LOS ANGELES. SOCAL THREE
FIFTY. IN STRONG SUPPORT. THERE
ARE NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN Q.
IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY TWO
FOURTEEN. THANK YOU MODERATOR
WE WILL NOW TURN TO LEAD
OPPOSITION ON AB THIRTY TWO
FOURTEEN I BELIEVE WE HAVE JOHN
BURKE WITH PACIFIC PACIFIC
MERCHANT SHIPPING ASSOCIATION
AND SHAUN ONE TIME CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION FOUR MINUTES TO BE
SHARED BETWEEN THE TWO OF YOU.
MODERATOR PLEASE SPRING IN- MR
BURKE THANK YOU. AND BERGER
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I'M JOHN
BERG VICE PRESIDENT WITH THE
PACIFIC MERCHANT SHIPPING
ASSOCIATION WE REPRESENT NON
TANK VESSELS SERVICING
CALIFORNIA SPORTS LIKE TO START
BY SAYING WE DO APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S EFFORTS TO ADDRESS
SOME OF OUR CONCERNS. THE
DOUBLING OF THE COBRA
REQUIREMENTS AND A REDUCTION IN
THE PER GALLON. PENALTY HOWEVER
WE MUST RESPECTFULLY CONTINUE
OPPOSITION THE BILL. FOR THE
FOLLOWING REASONS. FIRST THE
DOUBLING OF EXISTING PENALTY
PROVISIONS. WE DO UNDERSTAND
THE NEED TO UPDATE FINES AND
PENALTIES OVER TIME BUT THE
SENATE SIMPLE DOUBLING SEEMS
ARBITRARY AND UNSUPPORTED BY
EVIDENCE. THIS SEEMS ESPECIALLY
TRUE REGARDING THE DOUBLING OF
THE PENALTY MINIMUM. WHICH WILL
LIKELY BE COUNTERPRODUCTIVE IF
ANYTHING WE BELIEVE THE PENALTY
SHOULD HAVE KNOWN BETTER MOMS
LEAVING THAT TO THE DISCRETION
OF PROSECUTORS AND THE COURTS
TO DETERMINE. SECONDLY THE
AMENDED THOUSAND DOLLAR PER
GALLON PENALTY IS STILL FAR
BEYOND ANY EXISTING PENALTIES
THROUGHOUT STATE CODES WHICH
ARE IN THE TEN TO SIXTY DOLLAR
PER GALLON RANGE. THIS
EXCESSIVE PENALTY WOULD APPLY
PER NOWINGLY COSTS BILLS WHICH-
UNDER WHICH SIMPLE NEGLIGENCE
ACTUALLY QUALIFIES AND THAT'S
THIS COULD APPLY TO PURELY
ACCIDENTAL SPILLS WOULD DROP
REGARD TO FALL BEFORE
CULPABILITY. NOW THE AUTHORS
STATED THE AMENDMENT PROVIDES A
COURT FLEXIBILITY OUR IT DOES
PROVIDE NO GUIDANCE AS TO HOW
OR WHEN THIS HIGHER PENALTY
SHOULD BE IMPOSED OR WHAT
FACTORS SHOULD BE CONSIDERED.
WE THEREFORE REQUESTED A
FURTHER GUIDANCE LANGUAGE FOR
THIS PENALTY BE ADDED. TO
INCLUDE KNOWINGLY WILFULLY OR
RECKLESSLY AND THE CAUSATION OF
THIS BILL. THAT'S WHAT
APPROPRIATE FOLKS APPROPRIATELY
FOCUS A PENALTY ON THE MORE
GREGIS SPELLS AND POLLUTERS. WE
HAVE HAD DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
OFFICER'S OFFICE TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THESE CONCERNS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS. AND WE HOPE
THESE CAN BE RESOLVED HOWEVER
UNTIL THEN WE MUST RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THE BILL. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND NOW
ABOUT ONE MINUTE FORTY FIVE
SECONDS REMAINING FOR MR ONE
TIME. SHARE NUMBERS- JOHN ONE
TIME FOR THE CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION UP IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL WE BELIEVE- THE
PENALTY THE CURRENT LAW ARE AN
ADEQUATE DETERRENT. OIL
PRODUCERS ARE HIGHLY
INCENTIVIZED TO TAKE GREAT CARE
TO ENSURE A SAFE PRODUCTION
PROCESS. I D. W. EXISTING
PENALTIES- IS MUCH HIGHER THAN
INFLATION ARE UNDERSTANDING
THAT ADJUSTING CURRENT PENALTY
TO INFLATION SINCE THEY WERE
LAST ADJUSTED WOULD EQUAL AN
INCREASE ABOUT 49% NOT ONE
HUNDRED PERCENT- WHILE WE DO
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR REDUCING
THE NEW PENALTY IN THE BILL OF
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS PER GALLON
OF CRUDE OIL SPILL TO ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS. PER GALLON
HOWEVER- ALONG WITH DOUBLING OF
THE OTHER FIND IN THE BILL THIS
NEW PENALTY REMAINS EXCESSIVE
IN OUR OPINION. BUT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR NO
VOTE ON AB THIRTY TWO FOURTEEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERYMUCH
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO. SEE IF
THERE'S OTHER OPPOSITION FIRST
HEARING ROOM FORTY TWO ZERO
THREE. SEEING NONE MOVING TO
ROOM. ONE TWELVE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO IS BILL THREE TO
FOURTEEN WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
THE PHONE LINES ASK FOR YOUR
NAME. AFFILIATION AB THIRTY TWO
FOURTEEN MODERATOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION
OF AB THIRTY TWO FOURTEEN YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF AB
THIRTY TWO FOURTEEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. OUR FIRST COMMENT COMES
FROM MINE THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY NINE. NINE THREE FIFTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD R. E. S. I'M SORRY I
WAS IN THE QUEUE FOR SUPPORT
WOODY HASTINGS IN SUPPORT OF
THIRTY TWO FOURTEEN OF THE
CLIMATE CENTER. THANK YOU YOUR
SUPPORT IS DULY NOTED. BACK TO
THE MODERATOR FOR OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY. FINE THREE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
JOHN MCCAIN A CALIFORNIA
ANGULAR- ALSO. ON A COMMERCIAL
BUSINESS- FISHING BUSINESS AND-
I OPPOSE AB THIRTY THIRTY.
THANK YOU THAT'S NOT THE BILL
WE'RE HEARING NOW BUT WE HEAR
YOUR OPPOSITION WILL SAVE THAT
FOR LATER- ANY OTHER OPPOSITION
ON AB THIRTY TWO FOURTEEN. AND
ONCE AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTY TWO
FOURTEEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION
OF AB THIRTY TWO FOURTEEN YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. NINE ONE TWELVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE ONE HUNDRED AND TWELVE YOUR
THE CHAMBER MEMBER GARCIA ONCE
AGAIN FOR THE WESTERN STATES
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. WE HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT IN Q. THANK
YOU MADAM MODERATOR WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS I HAVE
SENATOR JACKSON YOU RECOGNIZED
YES THANK YOU- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THIS PREVENTED CURRENT IN OUR
DISTRICT. ON MY BIRTHDAY SO I
REMEMBER QUITE WELL- AND AS WE
DUG DEEPER INTO WHAT WAS THE
CAUSE OF THIS- THE FACT IS THAT
PLAINS ALL AMERICAN PIPELINE
HAD A CHOICE TO PUT IN A CUT
OFF VALVE WOULD HAVE COST ABOUT
A MILLION DOLLARS- IN THAT YEAR
THEY HAD MADE I THINK PROFITS
OF ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS. SO THEY MADE A
BUSINESS DECISION TO USE AN OLD.
INADEQUATE CUT OFF FAILED THAT
WOULD HAVE IMMEDIATELY
RECOGNIZE WHEN THE PRESSURE HAD
GOTTEN TO THE POINT THAT IT
HAD. AND WOULD HAVE CUT OFF OF
THAT OIL. SO INSTEAD WHAT
HAPPENED WAS IT WAS A WRITER ON
MEMORIAL DAY WEEKEND UP NEAR
SOME OF OUR BEAUTIFUL STATE
BEACHES AND OTHER FACILITIES.
SO PEOPLE FROM ALL OVER THE
STATE THE CENTRAL VALLEY IN.
THE SOUTHERN PART OF THE STATE
WHO HAD PLANNED PROBABLY CLOSE
TO A YEAR IN ADVANCE THAT'S
WHEN RESERVATIONS HAD TO BE
MADE AT THE STATE PARKS AND ALL
TO COME UP TO SPEND THAT TIME
WITH THEIR FAMILIES. THE PARKS
WERE CLOSED. SO THIS NOT ONLY
IMPACTED PEOPLE COMING TO WRECK
CREATE IN THE AREA BUT ALSO THE
BUSINESSES SMALL BUSINESSES SO
pKEEP EXPRESSING THEIR CONCERN
FOR SMALL BUSINESSES. WHAT
HAPPENED HERE WAS THAT SMALL
BUSINESSES FOR A PERIOD OF
SEVERAL WEEKS IF NOT MONTHS
WE'RE NOT ABLE TO FUNCTION AND
SO THEY WENT OUT OF BUSINESS.
SO THIS ONE MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT ENDED UP COSTING
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO THE LOCAL COMMUNITY
AND ALSO THE CLEANUP COSTS. AND
THEN THERE WAS A PROSECUTION OR
PROSECUTION OF CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION IN WHICH THEY WERE
FAR THE COMPANY WAS FOUND
LIABLE NOW UNFORTUNATELY. YOU
CAN'T PUT A CORPORATION IN JAIL.
SO WHAT YOU CAN DO THOUGH IS
THAT YOU CAN IMPOSE PENALTIES
AND THE PURPOSE IS TO PREVENT
THIS KIND OF BEHAVIOR FROM
OCCURRING IN THE FUTURE. THE
JUDGE VERY SPECIFICALLY GBOMO
ON THE FACT THAT THE AMOUNT OF
PENALTY HE WAS ABLE TO INFLICT
WAS SO MINIMAL BECAUSE THE- THE
CURRENT STATE OF A MAXIMUM
PENALTIES WAS SO LOW AND I
SUSPECT THAT'S THE REASON THAT
YOU BROUGHT THIS BILL. AND SO
IF WE'RE LOOKING TO TRY TO
DETER THEIR BEHAVIOR IN THE
FUTURE WHICH COST A NUMBER OF
OUR LOCAL SMALL BUSINESSES TO
GO UNDER. AND POLLUTED ARE-
OCEANS. POLLUTED TO OR AND
RUINED THE ABILITY OF PEOPLE
FROM ALL OVER THE STATE TO COME
AND ENJOY THE BEAUTIFUL COAST
THAT BELONGS TO US ALL IN
CALIFORNIA. THE AT THE ATTEMPT
HERE TO A DOUBLE THE FINES IS
REALLY. FRANKLY KIND OF
MINIMAL- THE FACT THAT THERE
WOULD BE OPPOSITION- IS ALSO.
NOT SURPRISING BUT
DISAPPOINTING WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT PUTTING THEM OUT OF
BUSINESS THE GOAL IS TO TRY TO
DISCOURAGE THIS BEHAVIOR GOING
FORWARD SO. I THINK THE I THINK
IT'S HELPFUL TO PUT THAT IN
THAT CONTEXT BECAUSE IT WAS THE
JUDGE WHO AGAIN WAS UNABLE TO
DO MORE EVEN AFTER A CRIMINAL
CONVICTION. OF THIS COMPANY A
TOOK PLACE SO- WITH THE ACT I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL- FANTA AS CERTAINLY.
RESHAPED OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
IT AND WOULD LIKE TO MOVE THE
BILL AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU SENATOR JACKSON WHO'S
MADE A MOTION. IN SUPPORT. OF
AB THIRTY TWO FOURTEEN. SKEWS
ME WHEN I TRIED IT DE ACTIVATED
TIMER. MY APOLOGIES AND WE'LL
TAKE IT BACK TO THE AUTHOR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK
YOU AND I JUST WANT TO ECHO
THAT THIS IS A ABOUT DETERRENCE
AND THIS IS ABOUT DETERRENCE
THAT WORK FOR EVERY COUNTY'S
DISTRICT ATTORNEY- AS WELL AS
THE COURTS- I ALSO WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS HAS NOT
THIS ISSUE HAD NOT COME UP. IN
TEN YEARS IN THE ENTIRE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THIS DOES NOT
APPLY TO EVERY SINGLE OIL SPILL
THIS HAS HAPPENED ONCE IN THE
LAST TEN YEARS SO WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT- OF A VERY VERY
VERY SMALL NUMBER OF TIMES THAT
THEY CAN THIS CAN EVEN BE USED
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
THAT'S WHY WE WANT THIS TO BE A
DETERRENT- I ALSO WANT TO IT
BASED ON SOME OF THE COMMENTS
WITH THE OPPOSITION. ALSO SEE
THAT YOU KNOW THAT THE U. S.
BUREAU OF LABOR STATISTICS
CONSUMER PRICE INDEX CALCULATOR
FOR ONE HUNDRED DOLLARS A
NINETEEN NINETIES APPROXIMATELY
A HUNDRED NINETY FIVE TWENTY
TWENTY. SO WE STILL THAT'S WHY
YOU SEE SUCH A LARGE INCREASE-
IT HAS BEEN THIRTY YEARS SINCE
THESE HAVE BEEN UPDATED AND SO
WE'VE WE'VE LOOKED AT THAT AS
WELL THE BILL HAS COME A LONG
WAY WE'VE IMMENSELY I'M TO THE
BILL BUT WE ABSOLUTELY FEEL
THAT IT IN. TO RECOGNIZE THAT
THIS IS A DETERRENT IT'S ONLY
HAPPENED ONCE IN THE LAST TEN
YEARS I'M BORED IT DOESN'T
APPLY TO EVERY SINGLE OIL SPILL
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ACOSTA.
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN FOR
THE RECORD YOU DID X. THE CAN
MEMON SAID THE BIG OF YOUR
PRESENTATION THIS TO PASS S.
AND IT. PATIENTS. CAN WITH HIS
CAR ON THE ROAD. PLEASE MIKE
SIR ON WHEN I CALL THE SO THE
IT'S EIGHT. THREE TWO FOUR
MOTIONS PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROACH. MONEY NINE MONNING HI
JOE. JON SNOW. HI ALLEN HI
BRIDGES NO REGIS NO CABALLERO.
HERTZBERG HUESO JACKSON XLRI
XLRI STERN NINE TURN OFF BY.
HAS FOR NEEDS ONE MORE THE BILL
HAS FOUR IN FAVOR TO IN
OPPOSITION WE WILL PLACE THAT
ON HOLD FOR MISSING MEMBERS
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER. SO
FRIENDS WERE NOW GOING TO MOVE
TO ITEM FOUR THIS IS AB THIRTY
THIRTY- BYE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA. JUST DOING A TIME CHECK
WE'RE STARTING HERE ABOUT TEN
THIRTY FIVE AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER DEPENDING ON. THOSE
WANTING TO TESTIFYING TO ASSURE
THAT WE CAN ACCOMMODATE ALL WHO
MAY WANT TO WEIGH IN ON THIS.
WE WILL DO A TIME CHECK AROUND
NOON WE MAY TAKE A HALF HOUR
LUNCH BREAK FOR. STAFF IN
MEMBERS SPENT I WILL. MONITOR
THE CLOCK AND WE WILL MONITOR
HOW MANY ARE N THE QUEUE. FOR
TESTIMONY ON THIS BILL- SO
WITHOUT FURTHER ADO WE WILL
TURN TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA
TO PRESENT AB THIRTY THIRTY THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE I WANT TO FIRST THANK
CHAIR STERN IN THE COMMITTEE
STAFF- FOR THE- FOR WORKING
WITH MY STAFF AND FOR HAVING
THIS BILL- TODAY. AS A FELLOW
POLICY CREATURE UNDERSTAND
SYMPATHIZE THE CHALLENGES
INVOLVED FACE AND WORKING
HERE'S MANY DOES POSSIBLE. WELL
BOUNCE IN THE PEOPLE'S WORK IN
PUBLIC HEALTH IS NOT AN EASY
PROCESS BUT I DO APPRECIATE
EXTEND MY GRATITUDE TO THE
CHAIR AND STAFF FOR THEIR
NGAGEMENT AND HARD WORK ON
THIS BILL. THESE LAST FIVE
MONTHS HAVEN'T G. BUT IT IS
ENCOURAGING TO SEE THAT WE ARE
HERE. DOING THE PEOPLE'S WORK
AND I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT AB
THIRTY THIRTY FOR YOU TODAY-
AND I WANT TO START BY TAX AT
ALL OF THE SUGGESTED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. THIRTY THIRTY
THIRTY IS A CRITICAL MEASURE.
IT WAS A NORTH STAR AN
IMPERATIVE YET CLEAR GOAL TO
HELP GUIDE THE STATE DURING THE
DIFFICULT TIMES AHEAD. WILL
HELP TO FOCUS OUR EXISTING
EFFORTS BY SETTING AN
ATTAINABLE STATEWIDE GOAL OF
PROTECTING AT LEAST 30% OF OUR
LANDS AND WATERS. OVER THE NEXT
DECADE. BY THIRTY PERCENT. AS
NOTED IN THE TWENTY ANALYSIS IT
IS THE BARE MINIMUM NEEDED TO
SAFEGUARD CLEAN AIR CLEAN
DRINKING WATER AND FOOD CHAINS
THAT SUPPORT ALL LIFE ON EARTH.
AND I QUOTE THE SCIENTIFIC
COMMUNITY HAS RECENTLY REACHED
BROAD CONSENSUS. THAT WE ARE IN
THE MIDST OF A SIXTH MASS
EXTINCTION EVENT THAT LIKE
CLIMATE CHANGES HUMAN BECAUSE-
OF THREATENS HUMANITY'S
SURVIVAL. IN THE STATE WE DO
BELIEVE IN SCIENCE AND THIS
BILL IS SCIENCE DRIVEN.
PRESERVING 30% IS NEEDED TO
HELP HOLD AND HOPEFULLY REVERSE
THIS CRISIS. SB THIRTY THIRTY
ALSO ESTABLISHES A STATE POLICY
TO IMPROVE BUT COULD WILL
PUBLIC ACCESS WITH THE PACIFIC
AND EMPHASIS ON CREATING ACCESS
FOR STARK MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES. BY ADOPTING AB
THIRTY THIRTY CALL FOR
CALIFORNIA NOT ONLY BECOME THE
FIRST DAY TO EMBRACE THIS COOL
LITTLE INVENTORS THE STATE AND
ACCESSING FEDERAL. AND NON
PUBLIC GRANT MONIES TO HELP
ACHIEVE THE GOALS SET FORTH IN
THIS BILL. THIS IS ESPECIALLY
NECESSARY TO TIME IN OUR HOSTEL
FEDERAL MINISTRATIONS ROLLING
BACK ENVIRONMENTAL REGULATIONS
OPENING WHILE PUBLIC PLANS TO
DRILLING AND MINING. AND
ABANDONING THE PARIS CLIMATE
AGREEMENT. FOR THE PAST FIVE
MONTHS MY STAFF TO CO SPONSORS
LINE VOTE COUNTLESS MEETINGS
AND WORK TIRELESSLY. TO WORKING
CLOSELY WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS
THAT IS REFLECTIVE OF THIS
MEASURES IMPORTANCE. ALTHOUGH
YOU'RE NOT BEEN ABLE TO SATISFY
EVERYONE THE MEMBERS WE HAVE
MADE ARE IN DIRECT RESPONSE TO
MANY. OF THE CONCERNS RAISED.
SPENT A LOT OF ATTENTION SHOWN
THIS BILL AS IT IS ONE OF THE
FEW. ENVIRONMENTAL BILLS. STILL
MOVING ALONG HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE. TESTS THAT WE HAVE
BEEN SUBJECT TO MANY IN CORRUPT
INCORRECT. ASSUMPTIONS AS I
SAID IT SETS A GOAL WHAT IS NOT
WHAT DOES IT WHAT IT DOES NOT
DO IS MANDATE. NEW STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS. DOES NOT REQUIRE
NEW REGULATIONS TO GRANT
ADDITIONAL REGULATORY THIRTY
FORTY TO ANY AGENCY OR
DEPARTMENT. SOME PUT THE THUMB
ON THE SCALE OF EXISTING
CONSERVATION PROGRAMS DOES NOT
BAN HUNTING OR FISHING. IN FACT
ESTABLISHING MEASURES MEASURES
AS APPLIES TO OUR LANDS AND
WATERS. TO PROTECT OUR
NATIONAL. CHARACTER AND
RESOURCES. YOU WOULD THINK THAT
ANYONE WHETHER THEY'RE
INTERESTED HUNTING FISHING
HIKING CAMPING. TECNOLOG ON THE
BEACH BUT THEY WILL BE
SUPPORTIVE OF HAVING MORE LANDS
THAT ARE PROTECTIVE. PROTECT
THE HABITAT AND ALLOW FOR MORE
RECREATIONAL ACCESS AND
OPPORTUNITY. SPILLED IS ALSO
NOT INCREASE COST PRESSURES.
RATHER WHAT DOES NOT DO DOES IS
ACT AS A NORTH STAR THE NORTH
STAR THEY GIVE US A CLEAR GOAL
TO CONSERVE BIODIVERSITY
INCREASE CLIMATE RESILIENCE
OUR FOOD SUPPLY HELP PROTECT US
FROM DISEASE AND IMPROVE MUCH
NEEDED ACCESS TO NATURE. FOR
ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES
INCLUDING ARE ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
OFTEN TIMES WHEN WE GET THESE
BONDS AND GRANTS THAT FOR OPEN
SPACES WE KNOW THAT THEIR APART
DESERT'S AND OPEN SPACE ACCESS
ISSUES FOR MANY COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE. WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT AS WE'RE
LOOKING AT. UP PROTECTING
PUBLIC LANDS THAT IS NOT JUST
IN THE FAR REACHES OF OUR STATE
BUT IT'S THROUGHOUT OUR STATE
MAKING SURE THAT. EVERYONE HAS
ACCESS TO OUR BEAUTIFUL
COASTLINE OUR WATERS AND OUR
LANDS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THIS IS A SIMPLE YET PROFOUND
MEASURE TOWARDS BUILDING A
HEALTHIER MORE ROBUST. MORE
AFFABLE FUTURE FOR CURRENT AND
FUTURE GENERATIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS. WITH THE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OR MARSEILLE
GOOD HERE IS GARDENS ADVISABLE
AND WE ALSO HAVE DR HUNT OF
NRDC. WHO'S AVAILABLE FOR
TECHNICAL SUPPORT. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA WE WILL
NOW GO TO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
THIS IS AB THIRTY THIRTY WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO THE TWO PRIMARY
LEAD SUPPORT WITNESSES WHO WILL
SHARE FOUR MINUTES- IN IS
INTRODUCED BY THE AUTHOR- WILL
GO FIRST TERM MARKS GOOD DID S.
GRODIN. FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF US SCHOOL.-MODERATOR. GOOD MORNING. YES MY
NAME IS ELLIOT. IT IS YOU ARE
HAVE YOU EVER TURNED ON HER
COMPUTER JUST ONLY THE PHONE
PLEASE TURN DOWN THE COMPUTER
VOLUME. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS MICHAEL BENNETT OUT
INTO THE FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF AN ORGANIZATION
WORKING IN THE TNC MEETING.
BEFORE THAT I WAS OPERATIONS
MANAGER FOR THE ANNUAL BASED
COMMERCIAL PEOPLE IN
AGRICULTURE COMPANY. THE
ALAMEDA JOIN THE CONSERVATION
MOVEMENT IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT.
THEY CHANGES I SAW FIRST HAND
THE GREEN OVERFISHING AND
POLLUTION LED ME TO THE
REALIZATION THAT USUALLY WILL
NOT BE DEMOCRATS BOARD FROM
EITHER AN INDUSTRY DURATION. I
DO STRONGLY SUPPORT AT THIRTY
THREE THIRTY AND THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA. FOR LEGISLATION.
I WANT TO FIGHT HEARING IT IS
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT WE
ARE ALSO IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
CRISIS IN NATURE WITH
BIODIVERSITY ROCK FIRING OUT OF
CONTROLLING CLIMATE CHANGE
DRIVING REQUIRES GROUND INTO
THE- WHERE BETTER TO SEE THE
COMPANY. BY LOSS CLIMATE CHANGE
THEM TO LOOK OCEAN. OTHER OF MY
MACHINE. OCEAN IS NOT. WARMER
MORRIS TODAY WITH MORE WEIGHT
LET'S TALK WE CAN LESS
PRODUCTIVE AND LESS PREDICTABLE
AND IN SOME WAYS OCEANS ARE
BEING IMPACTED BY CLIMATE
CHANGE FASTER THAN ORIGINALLY.
THE FUNDAMENTAL TO THE OF OUR
OCEAN THE BIGGEST RIGHT TO BUY.
AND THAT AND BY HAS THE PEACH
TREE THAT ARE LINED UP.
ASSEMBLY EXTENSION ARE CRITICAL
HUMAN HEALTH IN ECONOMY.
FURTHER SCIENTIST POINTED OUT
THAT THE MY PLAYS AN IMPORTANT
ROLE IN PREVENTING FUTURE
SOMATIC AND THEN. HIGHLIGHTED
JUST HOW MUCH SPENDING TIME IN
THE ASSEMBLY IMPACTS OUR HEALTH
AND WELL BEING AND THROUGHOUT
THROUGH NATURAL DURABLE
STRAIGHT IT IS EASIER TO SEE
HOW INEQUITABLE ARE ACTIVE. YOU
NEED NOT AN AMENITY IT IS A
NECESSITY. FOR TOO LONG THE
COST OF IMPACT OF NATURAL
RESOURCE EXTRACTIONAND
POLLUTION FALLING
DISPROPORTIONATELY ON LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND
YOUR- A REPORT RELEASED LAST
MONTH FROM THE HISPANIC HAVE
FOUNDATION FOUND THAT.
CALIFORNIA 62% OF PEOPLE OF
COLOR ARE MORE LIKELY TO RESIDE
IN THE COMMUNITY THAT IS THE
NATURE OF THE PROJECT. THE
PURSUIT OF A THIRTY THIRTY GOAL
MUST ADDRESS IS GOING TO BE IN
YOUR WAY MORE EQUITABLE
DISTRIBUTION THE MAJORS BENEFIT
TO ALL PEOPLE. ACCORDING LEAN
KIND. PROTECTING 30% OF ALL
LANDS WATER THE NOTION HABITAT
IS THE MINIMUM PROTECTION UNIT.
WHICH IS WHY HELP EITHER OUR
COUNTRIES ARE WORKING TOGETHER
TO SET INTERNATIONAL GOLD
PROJECT 30% OF THE PLANET. BY
TWENTY THIRTY. NOTED IN THE
LETTER A LETTER SIGNED BY MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRED FORTY
SCIENTISTS WHO LIVE OR WORK IN
CALIFORNIA. THE SAME GOAL OF
THE FEASIBLE AND WORKABLE FOR
STATE. EIGHTY THIRTY THIRTY ONE
NOT ONLY REINFORCED CALIFORNIA
STATUS AT THE BIG WILD WILD.
LEADER IMPROVISED AN IMPORTANT
EXAMPLE. IS A NEW ONE COMMAND
STREAM. IN ADVERSITY. RIGHT
RIGHT IT WOULD ALSO. DO BY
TOGETHER EFFORTS REVERSE THE
MATH THEY SHOULD BUY DIVERSITY.
AND IN SURE FOR THE LAST TO
EACH OF OUR COMMUNITY HAVE A
THE WORKING BACK. I AMYOU HOW
DO NOT FOR IT NINE EIGHT THIRTY
IN THE LADY YEAH AGAIN AND-
FIRST STEP IN DRAFTING A WRITER
PRICE IN GROWTH IN THE QUALITY
DIGNITY AFTER THE BEEP CARE.
FOR THESE REASONS I YOUR I HOPE
THANK YOU THANK YOU YOU VIEWS
AND A HALF MINUTES OF THE-
MINUTES ALLOCATE. ONE NOW TO DO
IT HI. SENIOR TURN WITH NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL YOU
HAVE THIRTY SECONDS. TO OFFER
YOUR COMMENTS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CHAIR AND COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE COMMENTS
THIS MORNING. AND TESTIMONY HOW
THE ORGANIZATION ORGANIZATIONS
CO SPONSORING THIS BILL
REPRESENTS NEARLY ONE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS AND I'M HERE TO
DAY TO VOICE OUR COLLECTIVE
SUPPORT FOR A BI. THIRTY THIRTY.
EIGHTY EIGHT WHAT MISTER KALRA
MUSKETEERS GOT IN THAT NOT ONLY
MUST WE ADDRESS THE POVERTY
CRISIS PATTERSON STATE POLICY
THE GOAL TO PROTECT 30% OF OUR
LANDS AND WATERS. WE MUST DO SO
WITH A CLEAR AN EQUAL
COMMITMENT TO ENSURE ACCESS TO
NATURE ALL CALIFORNIAN Q.
MANAGER OVER BEFORE I MINUTES
VIOLENT GRAVEL. UP TO ALL. I
JOIN IT IN THE CALL DEBATE
LEVINE TECH EXPERT. ON ON YOUR
QUESTION FROM THE COMMITTEE IF
YOU HAVE LONG ENTRY QUESTION I
BOUGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU ON
SO THAT WAS ABOUT FOUR MINUTES
TWENTY SECONDS WE WILL FORWARD
THE SAME. OVER TIME TO THE
OPPONENTS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME WE NOW WILL MOVE TO PEOPLE
IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY THIRTY.
WILL START FIRST BY SEEING IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO ZERO THREE. SEEING NONE
WILL MOVE TO ROOM ONE TWELVE
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT SEEN
NONE THERE WE WILL MOVE TO THE
PHONE LINES LET ME JUST REMIND
CALLERS. THE FIRST. SET OF
CALLERS WILL BE THOSE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY THIRTY
YOU'LL OFFER YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATIONAL AFFILIATION IF
ANY. AND THAT YOU SUPPORT NO
FURTHER TESTIMONY JUST NAME
AFFILIATION IN SUPPORT
MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE
BRING IN WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTY THIRTY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
THIRTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY THIRTY.
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. OUR FIRST MINE IS
MINE ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
TWO. MIND ONE SEVENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS QUALITY I MEAN I
KNOW SHOULD BE DIRECTED HOFFMAN
CALIFORNIA A LISTING ON NUMBER
OF ORGANIZATIONS WHO WENT TO
COURT MEASURE. STARTING WITH
THREE FIFTY SELL STOCK ON
VALLEY ONLINE CALIFORNIA CITY
CALIFORNIA ACOSTA PROTECTION
NETWORK CALIFORNIA NEEDS
CONSERVATION VOTERS CALIFORNIA.
INTERFAITH POWER AND LIGHT
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY
CALIFORNIA LEAVE CALIFORNIA
WILDERNESS COALITION CALIFORNIA
SHE RETIREMENT CYCLE INSTITUTE
CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY. GENTLE HEARING BY
MENTORING RESOURCE CENTER CLEAN
WATER ACTION CONSERVATION LANDS
FOUNDATION WIRY DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE. HE AC ON WEST MORAN
JUSTICE ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE CENTER.
WILL JUSTICE COALITION FOR
WATER ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING
GROUP COURSE FOREVER
TRANSACTION COMMITTEE OF
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA
FRIENDS APART WILL BEACHES AND
PARKS FRIENDS OF THE DESERT
MOUNTAINS FRIENDS OF THE EARTH
TREND ALL INYO. TRANSACTION AS
WELL THEIR NATION HEAL THE BAY
HEALTH FOR EVERYONE IT'S PANIC
ACT. ASSEMBLY SHOULD. LOS
POLLUTION MARINE CULTURE AND TO
MISSION. BOB DEADLINE SHOT
MAILLET COMMITTEE CENTER SIERRA
AND BY RESOURCE CENTER RENDON
LOS. ARMONK MIGHT SEEM LEARN
HELP STATE SYSTEM AND THREATENS
FRACKING THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR ARI AND I'LL TO
THANK THE ORGANISER FOR
COLLABORATING TO OFF. THEIR OR
SUPPORT COLLECTIVELY THROUGH
WAY. I URGE OTHERS TO TAKE
NOTE- AN EFFECTIVE WAY TO
ADVANCE ORGANIZATIONAL SUPPORT.
MODERATOR WILL GO TO THE NEXT
WITNESS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR NINE THREE NINETY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU HI MY NAME IS
WILLIAM HOPPER I AM A SUPPORT
SYSTEM HERE IN CALIFORNIA. AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB. THIRTY
THIRTY BECAUSE- WE HAVE VERY
LIMITED WATER SO WE CONSIDER
KNOWN TESTIMONY OR THIS OR NO
TESTIMONY AT THIS POINT YOU CAN
SAY YOUR NAME YOU'VE REGISTERED
YOUR OPPOSITION OR ACTUALLY
TAKING CALLS NOW FROM
SUPPORTERS OF AB THIRTY THIRTY.
BUT YOU'RE OPPOSITION HAS BEEN
DULY NOTED BUT NO FURTHER
TESTIMONY FRIENDS ON EITHER
SIDE NAME IN OPPOSITION YOUR
WITNESSES HAVEADVANCED YOUR
CONCERNS IN ADVANCE. THANK YOU
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER IN
SUPPORT. OF AB THIRTY THIRTY.
THANK YOU AND AS A REMINDER WE
WILL MOVE TO OPPOSITION IF YOU
ARE ACCIDENTALLY IN THE-
SUPPORT QUEUE AT THIS TIME
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO TO
REMOVE YOURSELF FROM THE
SUPPORT QUEUE. AND YOU CAN
QUEUE UP FOR THE OPPOSITION TO
ONCE WE GET TO THAT POINT. AND
WE ARE NOW GOING TO THE LINE OF
THIRTY EIGHT IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY THIRTY. GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MARK PENSION RECORD
DI<c.cyan> ON BEHALF OF THE</c>
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICT
AS WELL AS THE TRACK WHERE
VALLEY OPEN SPACE IT'S ALREADY
AND STRONG SUPPORT. NINE THREE
HUNDRED AND FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS JAMIE CAL ON BEHALF OF
THE PARK NOW COALITION
INCLUDING TREEPEOPLE ACTIVE AND
GABRIEL VALLEY FATHERS AND
FAMILY THE SAN JOAQUIN WHAT YOU
KNOW COALITION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA NATURE FOR ALL
OUTDOOR OUTREACH UNIT OUTSIDE
LATINO OUTDOORS FRESNO BUILDING
HEALTHY COMMUNITIES BROWN'S
OFFICER THE WILDERNESS SOCIETY.
AND POGO PARK. RIGHT THANK YOU-THANK YOU. MINE FOR THIRTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU FORTY EIGHT
THINGS WITH THE CLIMATE CENTER
IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY THIRTY.
ONE SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE SIXTY ONE
EIGHT ONLY YES HI MY NAME IS
ELLEN THROWN PROVISION CANNOT
RESPECT ME TIME. FOR ON BEHALF
OF FALLING ORGANIZATIONS ARE
MILLIONS OF COLLECTED
CALIFORNIA NUMBERS THE FAMILY
OF. BIG MORONGO CANYON
CONVERGING RANGE ALLIANCE
NATIONAL PARKS CONSERVATION
ASSOCIATION NATIONAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL NEXT JOHN
CALIFORNIA. OCEAN DEFENDERS
ALLIANCE OUTDOOR ALLIANCE
CALIFORNIA PLANNING
CONSERVATION LEAGUE THE CLASSIC
POLLUTION COALITION. OUR SHORES
SEVENTH GENERATIONAL BEISER THE
COURT OVER LAND TRUST CALL
CALIFORNIA YOU'RE A BUSINESS
COUNCIL BURKE WRITER CALIFORNIA
FIVE GYRES INSTITUTE. I'M SURE
THE FIRE BACK GROUPS
CONSERVANCY THE WILDERNESS. AND
THIS HAPPENED BERMAN HE TALKED
FOR PUBLIC LIFE THE VOICE.
WINTER WHILE ALLIANCE WESTERN
WATERSHEDS PROJECT COOLEY EACH
TO- OH. PRIVATE PLAN PROJECT
HALEY AND FINDING OUT FRONT
CALIPER CAPITAL REGION FRESNO.
CAN JUST GO. MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MICHAEL FROM INSTANT ON THE
COUNTY. STRONG SUPPORT IN FAVOR
OF AB THIRTY THIRTY THANK YOU.
NINE THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
NATALIE MX ON BEHALF OF THE
LOS ANGELES NEIGHBORHOODS LAND
TRUST AND THE CALIFORNIA
HABITAT CONSERVATION PLANNING
COALITION IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY THIRTY. AT NINE FORTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
GOOD MORNING SHARE THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
CANDY GORDAN AND THE
CONSTITUENTS LIVING IN SENATOR
BEN ALLEN DISTRICT AND I'M
CALLING TODAY TO EXPRESS MY
STRONG SUPPORT. FOR A BI THIRTY
THIRTY. NINE FIFTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH CAN A GALLIARD FOR THREE
FIFTY SACRAMENTO IN STRONG
SUPPORT. MY TO SEVENTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO DARYL GALE FROM LOS
ANGELES I BELONG CONSUMERS
ALREADY MENTIONED ORGANIZATION
SO I WON'T BORE YOU WITH THEM
STRONG SUPPORTER OF THE SENATE
NECESSARY MINIMUM SUPPORT CALL
THANK YOU. NINE FOUR HUNDRED
AND FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE ABOUT TWO HUNDRED STE ON
THE LINE SO MINE FOR FIFTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO RENEE
ROWLAND REPRESENTING POP PACK
OF CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTY THIRTY. WE HAVE A
FEW TAKE A BREAK FIND ONE
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD REALLY CLOSE THEN I
JUST. NINE ONE TWENTY NINE YOU
MAY BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LIVING ON TOP OF MINE. TWENTY
NINE NINE TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING FRIEDMAN ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES AND
ALSO TODAY REPRESENTATIVE WILL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVE THE
CALIFORNIA. BETWEEN SNYDER
SUPPORT OPPOSITION I'M ALWAYS
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S INTENT
IN OPERATIONAL GOALS WE HAVE
MET A LETTER CONTAINS THE
COMMITTEE OUTLINING CONCERNS.
ABOUT THE IMPACT OF THE FALL
COUNTY. SHAME ON TIME TO WORK
ON THE- OF THE TOPIC YOU. NINE
ONE HUNDRED AND FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
YEAH YOUR ON BEHALF OF THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA CALLING IN SUPPORT
THANK. PLAN FOUR HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CARLA GARIBAY
ON BEHALF OF TOAD AND CO TROUT
UNLIMITED CALIFORNIA TROUT AND
SONOMA LAND TRUST IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOUNG. NINE THREE
HUNDRED AND NINETY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ARE YOU NEED TO PUT ME IN THE
OPPOSE Q. PLEASE. THANK YOU
WILL CALL UPON. TESTIMONY IN A
FEW MINUTES THANK YOU. NINE
FOUR HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOU MAY BE ON MUTE NINE
FOUR FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE FOUR FORTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES ARENA FRANCO BUT I
AM PART OF THE OPPOSE. OKAY
THANK YOU WE WILL COME TO A
CLOSE WE REGISTER YOUR COMMENT
THOUGH THANK YOU. HELLO. HOW DO
I GET OUT THE VOTE OF A FOLLOWS.
THE. THANK YOU WERE TAKING
CALLS IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
THIRTY IF YOU'RE IN THE QUEUE
FOR OPPOSITION AND YOU'VE
ACTIVATED INTO THIS LINE YOU
CAN DIAL ONE ZERO TO MOVE OUT
OF THE SUPPORT LINE AND WHEN WE
START TAKING OPPOSITION CALLS
YOU COULD THEN AGAIN DIAL ONE
ZERO TO GET IN THE QUEUE FOR
OPPOSITION SO MODERATOR
ACCEPTING CALLS IN SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTY THIRTY. THANK YOU.
NINE FOUR HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BUT FEDERAL FELLOW
CALIFORNIA AFTER RECREATION
PARTNERSHIP IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTY THIRTY. ONE FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
WAS PUT IN THE WRONG LAW. OKAY
VERY BADLY OPPOSITION WILL BE
COMING UP SHORTLY. ONE FOUR
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MANY TENDER CARE LIVE IN
SANTA MONICA AND I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL AB
THIRTY. ONE FOUR HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE FOUR
THIRTY THREE FOUR HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MOVING ON TO LINE FOUR HUNDRED
AND SIXTY TWO NINE FOUR HUNDRED
AND SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. PLEASE CHECK
YOUR MUTE BUTTON MIND FOR SIXTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MOVING
ON TO LINE FOUR HUNDRED AND
SIXTY NINE NINE FOUR HUNDRED
AND SIXTY NINE. FOUR SIX NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS MARCUS AUTUMN
IN STRONG OPPOSITION OF THIRTY
THIRTY. OKAY THANK YOU WE ARE
TAKING CALLS RIGHT NOW IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY THIRTY IF
YOU'RE ON THE LINE IN YOUR
WAITING TO OPPOSE. PLEASE
ACTIVATE ONE ZERO THAT WILL
TAKE YOU OUT OF THIS LINE WHEN
WE START TAKING OPPOSITION YOU
CAN THEN AGAIN HIT ONE ZERO IN
BE BROUGHT INTO THE OPPOSITION
LINE. MODERATOR PLEASE PROCEED
WITH CALLS IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY THIRTY. LINE FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES I'M IN OPPOSITION.
MODERATOR I KNOW YOU PERHAPS
DON'T HAVE ANYWHERE TO
SURVEYING CREWS OUT THERE MOM
LET'S TRY ONE MORE FOR THOSE IN
SUPPORT IF WE DON'T HEAR
ANYMORE IN SUPPORT I MAY MOVE
THIS TO OPPOSITION AND ANYONE
STUCK IN LINE WHO DIDN'T GET TO
COMMENT SUPPORT COULD DO SO
DURING THAT CUBA. LET'S TRY A
COUPLE MORE LINES IN SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTY THIRTY THANK YOU.
FIND FOUR HUNDRED AND FORTY
FIVE FOUR FOUR FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
OPPOSITION ARTHUR TAYLOR ALL
POSED AB THIRTY THIRTY. THANK
YOU AGAIN WE'RE TAKING CALLS IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY THIRTY
WILL TRY ONE MORE LINE
MODERATOR IF NO MORE IN SUPPORT
I WILL MOVE THIS TO THE
OPPOSITION PRIMARY WITNESSES
THANK YOU. THANKS FOR IT EIGHTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SH GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS IT'S JENNIFER
FEARING CALLING IN SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF THE MOUNTAIN LION
FOUNDATION AND OCEANA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MODERATOR LET'S KEEP
TRYING THEM FOR THOSE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY THIRTY.
FINE FOR EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M IN
OPPOSITION PROTECT FISHING HI
ARE YOU YOU YOU'RE IN THE WRONG
QUEUE WILL GO MODERATOR ANY
OTHER CALLERS IN SUPPORT OF AB.
THIRTY THIRTY. ONE MOMENT NINE
FOUR TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE FOR
NINETY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT LOOKS LIKE
WE DO HAVE- THE REST ARE IN.
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU MODERATOR AND I WILL MOVE
TO THE PRIMARY LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES AT THIS TIME IF
SOMEBODY WAS CALLING IN TRYING
TO REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT. YOU
CAN DO SO ONLINE- WITH A LETTER
OR EMAIL TO THE COMMITTEE- AND
IF YOU STAND THE LINE WE WILL
CAPTURE YOU BUT WE ARE MOVING
TO OPPOSITION EITHER OPPOSITION
WITNESSES AT THIS MOMENT- I
HAVE MISTER TAYLOR RUSSIAN FROM
THE CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU. BY
MARK GIRL THANK WITH THE
COASTAL CONSERVATION
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
YOU'LL HAVE A TOTAL OF FOUR
MINUTES AND TWENTY SECONDS TO
SHARE BETWEEN THE TWO OF YOU.
AND DO WE HAVE IS THIS MISTER
ROSHEN IN IN ROOM FORTY TWO
THREE. MORE CHRONIC I WILL BE
THE FIRST SPEAKER OKAY THANK
YOU SO WE HAVE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE IF WE CAN HAVE THE
MICROPHONE PLEASE THIS IS MR
GRONIK WITH THE COASTAL
CONSERVATION ASSOCIATION THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MARK
CARRILLO LOOK. I'M SPEAKING
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA SUSTAINABLY MANAGED.
RECREATIONAL FISHING HUNTING
AND COMMERCIAL FISHING
COMMUNITIES. I CHAIR THE
PACIFIC FISHERY MANAGEMENT
COUNCIL. THE FEDERAL BODY THAT
MANAGES MOST FISHERIES OFF THE
COAST OF CALIFORNIA. AND
DESIGNATES AREAS PROTECTION BUT
I'M HERE TODAY. AS A CALIFORNIA
FISHERMEN. NO ONE DISPUTES THE
NEED FOR GLOBAL BIODIVERSITY
PROTECTION. HOWEVER CALIFORNIA
IS ALREADY AN INTERNATIONAL
LEADER IN THIS AREA WITH
BIODIVERSITY PROTECTION
EXCEEDING THE 30% GOAL IN THIS
BILL. PARTICULARLY IN MARINE
WATERS WE CANNOT SUPPORT THE
BILL IN ITS CURRENT FORM. WE DO
NOT BELIEVE THAT EXISTING
ACCESS FOR A WIDE WIDE ARRAY OF
RECREATIONAL PURSUITS. OR FOR
COMMERCIAL FISHING ACTIVITIES
SHOULD BE ELIMINATED UNLESS
THOSE ACTIVITIES PRESENT HARM
TO BIODIVERSITY THAT'S AN
AMENDMENT WHICH SOUGHT AND BEEN
REFUSED. FOR A BILL THE
SUPPOSEDLY SERVES TO INCREASE
ACCESS TO CALIFORNIANS IT'S
REFUSAL TO PROTECT EXISTING
ACCESS PUZZLES ME. AB THIRTY
THIRTY CALLS FOR PROTECTION BUT
THE TERMS MEETING IS OPAQUE. I
SPENT HOURS WITH THE SPONSORS
FUTILELY TRYING TO MAKE THE
LANGUAGE MEANINGFUL. WHAT WE
KNOW FROM THE SUPPORTERS PUBLIC
STATEMENTS IT'S A PAY EQUITY
PROTECTION. WITH AREAS THAT
SPECIFICALLY ELIMINATE FISHING
ACCESS. AND THEIR GOAL IS TO
DOUBLE THESE FISHING CLOSURES
THAT COMES FROM THE PROPONENTS
SUGGESTED THAT ONLY 16%
CALIFORNIA'S WATERS ARE
PROTECTED AND THOSE ARE THE
AREAS. THAT LIMIT OR ELIMINATE
FISHING. THAT DEFINITION OF
PROTECTION IS FAR NARROWER THAN
IS INTERNATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
IN FACT WELL MANAGED AND
SUSTAINABLE FISHING IS
COMPLETELY COMPATIBLE WITH
BIODIVERSITY PROTECTION IN AB
THIRTY THIRTY IT NOR IS THIS.
AND WHILE IT'S BEEN NOTED THAT
THIS BILL DOES NOT PROVIDE ANY
ADDITIONAL STATUTORY AUTHORITY.
AT NINE IS REALLY NEEDED
ALREADY EXISTS. THE LEGISLATURE
MUST PROVIDE THE ADMINISTRATION
WITH BETTER GUIDANCE ON THE
APPLICATION OF THE OPERATIONAL
GOALS IN SB THIRTY THIRD. THE
BILL'S LACK OF CLARITY
JEOPARDIZES CONTINUED ACCESS TO
COMMERCIAL AND SPORT FISHING
ACTIVITIES WHICH HAVE HUGE
EMPLOYMENT AND ECONOMIC IMPACTS
IN CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA
FISHING IS A TWENTY NINE
BILLION DOLLAR INDUSTRY
SUPPORTING A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
TWO THOUSAND JOBS. THE STATE'S
OWN WILDLIFE ACTION PLAN STATES
THAT SPORTFISHING AND HUNTING
PUMPS SIX POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY INTO
CALIFORNIA COPY KANEMI. AND
SUPPORTS FIFTY SIX THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA JOBS. THIS BILL IS
NOT READY TO BE IMPLEMENTED AS
LAW. ASK FOR YOUR NO VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR AND THAT WAS
ABOUT TWO AND A HALF MINUTES WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO. MR TAYLOR
ROSHEN. WHO WILL HAVE ABOUT ONE
MINUTE TWENTY SECONDS REMAINING.
GOOD MORNING MISTER TURNER
MEMBERS KILLED RUSSIAN WITH THE
FARM BUREAU AND MEMBERS OF OUR
COALITION REPRESENT MOST OF THE
PRIVATE LANDHOLDERS IN THE
STATE AND WE AGREED TO
PROTECTING. CALIFORNIANS
WORKING LANDSCAPE IS ABOUT MOST
MOST IMPORTANT THAT THEY SHOULD
BE SOMETHING WE BE SUPPORTIVE
OF BUT WHERE THE RUBBER MEETS
THE ROAD. WITHOUT THE DETAIL
THE BILL RESPECTFULLY HAS
ISSUES THIRTY THIRTY TESTIFIED
THE PROTECTED LANDS OTHER THAN
DURING DURING MEASURES MEANING
IN PERPETUITY THE FIFTEEN
MILLION ACRES UNDER THE STATE'S
LARGEST AND MOST POPULAR AND
MOST SUCCESSFUL IN PROTECTION
PROGRAM HE ONE BLACK WOULD NOT
QUALIFY AS PROTECTED UNDER THE
BILL. THIRTY THIRTY ALSO
REQUIRED LAND BE MANAGED FOR
BIODIVERSITY CLIMATE RESILIENCY
AND YOU GOT WE SERVICE THOSE
STATE FEDERAL AND PRIVATELY
FUNDED CONSERVATION
AGRICULTURAL EVENING DON'T
INCLUDE THESE CRITERIA. ANOTHER
ADDITIONAL MILLIONS OF ACRE
WOULDN'T MEET THAT STANDARD
IT'S ALREADY INCREDIBLY
DIFFICULT AFTER PRIVATE
LANDHOLDER TO FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT RIGHT IN UNDER AN
EASEMENT BUT I REMEMBER TO IT
BECUSE THEY BELIEVE IN EACH OF
THE LAND PROTECTIONS THE LANE
REDUCTION OF CONDITIONS ON THE
DECLINE- AFTER POSTING A BILL
WILL CALL THAT COMMITMENT.
THIRTY THIRTY ALSO SUFFERS FROM
PRACTICAL ISSUE AS WE NOW KNOW.
THAT LIKE I DIDN'T. IT GOT THE
CALL. THEM PROVIDE FOR
LEGISLATIVE UP OVER. DOESN'T
DISCUSS HOW DATA BE COLLECTED
ATTRACT PROGRESS IN A- CAN.
WORK LANDS NATURAL LAND. EACH
OF THOSE PLAN ARE UNIQUE AND-
TO THINK MAN. AND POLICY PER.
BUT A TIME THAT WE AGREE WITH
AS MANY. TO IN OUR TOOL. BUT
WORKING LAND THIRTY THIRTY. THE
RESOURCE. CREATING A SINGULAR
TO. INFLUX APPROACH THAT WON'T
BE EXACT TO MOST OF OUR WORKING
LANDHOLDERS THE STATE. THE
FOURTEENTH RECENTLY
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING ABOUT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THAT WAS
RIGHT ON THE MARKET ABOUT FOUR
MINUTES AND TWENTY FIVE SECONDS
SO. THANK YOU FOR SHARING THAT
TIME JUDICIOUSLY. AND MEMBERS
WERE NOW GOING TO MOVE TO-
CALLERS IN OPPOSITION AB THIRTY
THIRTY ACTUALLY ON A FIRST
CHECK WITH. I HAVE SOME
WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO ZERO THREE WILL START HERE-
PLEASE NAME AFFILIATION IN.
YOUR OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS BILL
BILLER ON BEHALF OF PACIFIC
COAST FEDERATION OF FISHERMEN'S
ASSOCIATIONS. THE FOLLOWING
COMMERCIAL FISHING COMMUNITY
MEMBERS WHO COLLECTIVELY
HARVEST PROCESS VAST MAJORITY
OF CALIFORNIANS SEAFOOD.
PROPOSED TO THIS MATTER. THREE
BEGIN THE SAN DIEGO FISHERMAN'S
WORKING GROUP. THE TUNA HARBOR
DOCKSIDE MARKET. DEL MAR
SEAFOOD CALIFORNIA WHAT FISH
PRODUCERS ASSOCIATION WEST
COAST SEAFOOD PROCESSORS
AMERICAN ALBACORE FISHING
ASSOCIATION WESTERN FISH BOAT
OWNERS ASSOCIATION ALLIANCE OF
COMMUNITIES FOR SUSTAINABLE
FISHERIES CAL MARINE FISH
COMPANY. CALIFORNIA FISHERIES
AND SEAFOOD INSTITUTE THE OC
WILD SEAFOOD VENTURA COUNTY
COMMERCIAL FISHERMEN'S
ASSOCIATION. KEY WORDS FISH
CALIFORNIA SEA URCHIN
COMMISSION GET HOOKED SEAFOOD
OF SANTA BARBARA AND A MODERATE
FISH COMPANY ALL IN OPPOSITION
TO SB THIRTY THREE THANK YOU
AND I APPRECIATE. YOUAS WELL
FOR COMBINING SOME OF THE
ORGANIZATIONAL OPPOSITION
THROUGH A SINGLE WITNESS MUCH
APPRECIATED THE NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE REMEMBERS JERRY DOES MEN
ON BEHALF OF RECREATIONAL
BOATERS OF CALIFORNIA AGES
NONPROFIT ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
WITH FIFTY YEARS OF TRADITION
REPRESENTING TENS OF THOUSANDS
OFBOATING CLUBS FAMILIES AND
VOTING THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS ACROSS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA FISHERIES AND
SEAFOOD INSTITUTE. MILLIONS OF
CUSTOMERS EVERY DAY IN
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL THANK YOU. MISTER KERR
WENT OVER WITH ALSO
CONSERVATIONISTS CALIFORNIA
OCEANSIDE SENIOR ANGLER SAN
DIEGO COUNTY WILDLIFE
FEDERATION AND I COULD NOT
STAND HER NAME ABA HUNDREDS OF
FISHING CLUBS TACKLE
MANUFACTURER SPORT BOAT
LANDINGS RADIO SHOWS AND
RETAILERS BUT I WILL. HELLO
WITH FILES OF PETITIONERS WE
ALL OPPOSE THANK YOU THANK YOU
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR SHARING
ON BEHALF OF SO MANY. THANK YOU
NEXT RESEARCHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS BILL
GAINES TODAY PROUDLY
REPRESENTING THE BALLOT.
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
OF THE WILD SHEEP FOUNDATION
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA GUIDES AND
SPORTSMEN'S ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA WATER
FILE THE CALIFORNIA STATE
CHAPTER OF THE NATIONAL WILD
TURKEY FEDERATION SAN DIEGO
COUNTY WILDLIFE FEDERATION THE
SYSTEM RESOURCE CONSERVATION
DISTRICT. SPARKLES
INTERNATIONAL SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA CHAPTER CALIFORNIA BONE
HARVESTING ARCHERY ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA CONFRONTS SURVATION.
THE CALIFORNIA HAWKING CLUB.
THE BRENT THE CAL WELL IN ONE
COUNCIL THE AMERICAN SUPPORT
FOR ASSOCIATION THE ROCKY
MOUNTAIN ELK FOUNDATION THE
DALLAS SAFARI CLUB. CALIFORNIA
USED ADVENTURES ESCONDIDO
FISHING GAME ASSOCIATION THE
WOMEN GROVE ROD AND GUN CLUB.
NATIONAL SHOOTING SPORTS
FOUNDATION PHEASANTS FOREVER.
THE SAN DIEGO SPORTING DOG CLUB
RIVERSIDE COUNTY GUN OWNERS SAN
DIEGO QUAIL FOREVER. GUY
FALCONRY THE NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION INSTITUTE FOR
LEGISLATIVE ACTION SOUTH BAY
ROD AND GUN CLUB SENO COUNTY
FARMER CALLERS. THE SUPPORT OF
INTERNATIONAL SAN DIEGO CHAPTER
TWENTY BASIN WETLANDS
ASSOCIATION TRIPLE B.
ADVENTURES THE SPORTS FISHING
TO THE CONSERVANCY. AND START
FAR CLUB INTERNATIONAL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ALL IN OPPOSITION
TO SB THIRTY THIRTY THANK YOU
SIR AND I ALSO APPRECIATE YOUR
COMBINING- THOSE TOGETHER
INSTANTLY NOTED YES NEXT PLEASE
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AVING KLEIN ON
BEHALF OF THE CONGRESSIONAL
SPORTSMEN'S FOUNDATION- AND DUE
TO. THE ISSUES WHAT THE
STATUTORY LANGUAGE WE ON EARTH
WE REGRETTABLY REMAIN OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARK SMITH ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL MARINE
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION
SIMILAR TO THE COMMENTS
PREVIOUSLY MADE IN OPPOSITION
UNLESS AMENDMENTS ARE TAKEN TO
THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
OH THREE SEEING NONE LET'S LOOK
TO ROOM ONE TWELVE I SEE NO WAY
THIS IS WAITING THERE. IN JUST
BEFORE WE MOVED TO OUR PHONES.
I WANT TO REMIND. HE SUPPORTER
OR OPPONENTS YOU MAY SUBMIT.
TESTIMONY SUPPORT OPPOSITION.
DIRECTLY TO THE COMMITTEE- BUT
WE WILL NOW GO TO OUR PHONES
AND WE HAVE- THE NUMBER IN THE
QUEUE- LAST TELLING ME LET ME
JUST GIVE PEOPLE A HEADS UP.
ABOUT FIFTY IN THE CUBAN THAT
CAN BE ADDED TO BUT I WILL ASK
THE MODERATOR WILL START.
TAKING THOSE IN OPPOSITION TO
SHARE YOUR NAME. ORGANIZATIONAL
AFFILIATION IF ANY INTO SIMPLY
COMMENT. ABOUT THAT YOU OPPOSE
NO FURTHER SUBSTANTIVE
TESTIMONY PLEASE. OUT OF
RESPECT FOR THOSE BEHIND YOU
PLEASE SHARE YOUR NAME AND
OPPOSITION AND MODERATOR LET'S
START. TAKING THOSE CALLS AT
THIS POINT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND AT THIS TIME
WE HAVE A HUNDRED AND TEN. IN
Q. THANK YOU NINE HUNDRED AND
TEN IN THE QUEUE. WERE ASSUMING
THESE ARE IN OPPOSITION- BUT
LET'S GET GOING IN NAME AND
AFFILIATION. AND WE KNOW THAT
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
FIRST COMMENT COMES FROM NINE
FOUR SEVENTY NINE NINE FOUR
SEVEN NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIS
I THINK THE MODERATORS
SEARCHING FOR CALLERS RIGHT NOW
AND I'LL JUST REMIND PEOPLE
WE'RE WE'RE INFORMED WE HAVE
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND TEN IN LINE
I'M GONNA DO A TIME CHECK
AROUND TEN OF TWELVE AND WE MAY
TAKE A SHORT LUNCH BREAK OUT OF
SUPPORT OF OUR STAFF AND
MEMBERS BUT I WILL KEEP YOU
POSTED IN AND WE'LL SEE HOW
MUCH WE HAVE REMAINING- IN WE
ME. PRESS THROUGH IF THERE'S
NOT TOO MANY WAITING ON THE
LINE BUT WE WILL AFFORD
EVERYONE AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HEARD WHO WANTS TO BE HEARD.
MODERATOR THOSE IN OPPOSITION
TO AB THIRTY THIRTY THANK YOU.
NINE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
LINE FOR SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
DONNA BROCK BUT BABIES LOCKER
SPORTFISHING NEWPORT BEACH
OPPOSE. PLAN THREE TWENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PATRICK
BRENNAN CALIFORNIA ANGLER
STRONGLY OPPOSE. ONE FOR FORTY
NINE. BUT OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FOUR FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. DAVID
KENNEDY WITH BOAT OWNERS
ASSOCIATION OF THE UNITED
STATES HAS SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND MEMBERS NATIONWIDE
SEVENTY THOUSAND IN CALIFORNIA
WE OPPOSE. NINE FIVE THREE FIVE
ZERO THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BOB REED WITH
THREE BUT GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
ON BEHALF OF THE VALLEY AG
WATER COALITION AND MOUNTAIN
COUNTIES WATER RESOURCES
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION. NINE
FOUR EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT YOU'RE A
MEMBERS JASON BRYANT ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CATTLEMEN'S
ASSOCIATION WERE OPPOSED THANK
YOU. NINE FIVE OH FIVE NINE
FIVE OH FIVE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS GAIL WITH WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. NINE
ZERO ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE TWO
HUNDRED AND ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SO I WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION AB RIGHT
BETWEEN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
APPRECIATE CONVERSATIONS WE'VE
BEEN HAVING WITH OTHER ARTISTS.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY STILL I'M
OPPOSED TO ADD A PROVISION THAT
IT THANK YOU. NINE NINETY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE RUDY COASTAL
CONSERVATION ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE THANK YOU.
NINE TWO FIVE THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN NINE TO FIFTY THREE GO
AHEAD. YOU MAY BE ON MUTE NINE
TWO FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MOVING ON TO LINE FIVE
ZERO SIX FIVE HUNDRED AND SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M NOT FORMING PRIVATE
CITIZEN NOW DOORS WHEN OPPOSED
AS WRITTEN. NINE TWENTY EIGHT.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE COMMENTS OF THE GATE
YACHT CLUB SAN DIEGO WE ARE
STRONGLY OPPOSED. NINE FOUR
TWENTY NINE NINE FOUR TWENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN I HAD.
IF YOU'RE CARE MEMBERS MAPPED
OUT ON THE AFTER THE
SPORTFISHING CONSERVANCY AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
NINE THREE NINETY FOUR. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RICHARD COLLECTIBLE SAN DIEGO
ON THE RECREATIONAL FISHERMEN
I'M OPPOSED. THANK YOU EIGHTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GLENN EVANS
CALIFORNIA ANGLER FOR FIFTY
FIVE YEARS ON BEHALF OF LOS
ROPE IS FISHING CHARTERS THIS
YEAR'S STICKS SNAP REALLY
OPPOSITION CHARTERS WELLSTAR
SPORTFISHING PACIFIC VOYAGER
AND OUTER LIMITS WE ALL OPPOSE.
I'M FOR SEVENTY TWO. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIRMAN I'M GARY BRENNAN THE
PRESIDENT IS SENDING A COUNTY
WILDLIFE FEDERATION
REPRESENTING THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS ALABAMA ST
ATHLETIC CLUB DUCKS UNLIMITED
SAN DIEGO CHAPTER CALIFORNIA
YOUTH ADVENTURES IMPERIAL
COUNTY ESCONDIDO FISHING GAME
ASSOCIATION. SAN DIEGO GERMAN
SHORTHAIR POINTERS CLUB LEMON
GROVE BROADEN GUN CLUB NATIONAL
WILD TURKEY FEDERATION CHAPTER
IN SAN DIEGO HELLO MORE
SPORTSMAN'S CLUB PROJECT TWO
THOUSAND SAN DIEGO FISHING GAME
ASSOCIATION. QUAIL FOREVER SAN
DIEGO CHAPTER DOESN'T FOREVER
IMPERIAL COUNTY RAMONA
SPORTSMEN'S ASSOCIATION
SPARKLED INTERNATIONAL SAN
DIEGO CHAPTER SAN DIEGO COUNTY
BACK COUNTRY HORSEMEN. SAN
DIEGO COUNTY GUN OWNERS ORANGE
COUNTY GUN OWNERS SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY GUN OWNERS
RIVERSIDE COUNTY GUN OWNERS SAN
DIEGO COUNTY VARMINT CALLERS.
SAN DIEGO SUPPORTING DAHLE CLUB
SAN DIEGO RETRIEVER IN FIELD
TRIAL CLUB SAN DIEGO SPORTS
DAHLE TRACKERS GUY FALCONRY.
SOUTH BAY ROD AND GUN CLUB.
SPORTS FISHING CONSERVANCY
ENTER BILLION TRIPLE B.
ADVENTURES WE'RE ALL IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO AB
THIRTY THIRTY THANK YOU THANK
YOU SIR DULY NOTED WE
APPRECIATE COMBINING. THOSE
REFERENCE THANK YOU NEXT MONDAY.
ONE FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE FORTY
FOUR YOU MAY BE ON MUTE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES DAVID LOPEZ
CHARTER CAPTAIN SANTA BARBARA
CALIFORNIA STRONG OPPOSITION.
NINE FOUR EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MATTHEW
HARPER OVER THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
NINE TWO FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
FRANKLIN MURPHY CONSTITUENT OF
HANNAH BETH JACKSON AND LEE
MONIQUE LIMON ASSOCIATED WITH
THE ALSO CONTRIBUTION OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE VENTURA
COUNTY COMMERCIAL FISHING
ASSOCIATION AND RECREATIONAL
BOATING ASSOCIATION AND
CALIFORNIA HANDLER FOR FORTY
YEARS IN VERY STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. NINE THREE EIGHTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU CHARLES
CRITCHLOW GPA- CALIFORNIA-
COASTAL CONSERVATION
ASSOCIATION MEMBER AND I AM
OPPOSED. NINE TO ELEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES MR CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS LUKE PERSON
I'M A SIXTY NINE YEAR OLD
CALIFORNIA NATIVE LIFELONG
ANGLER AND REPRESENTING THE
FIFTY FIVE MEMBER DANA WHARF
ROTTEN REAL CLUB WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE VERY VAGUE AND
LOOSELY DEFINED A. B. THIRTY
THIRTY. THANK YOU. NINE SIXTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. CHRIS ROBERT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FORESTRY ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION. NINE FOUR FORTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD I'LL BE ON A BEHALF OF
SANTA CLARITA VALLEY WATER
AGENCY WE OPPOSE. NINE FOUR
EIGHTY ONE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD DAVID ON THE
CALIFORNIA ANGLER I URGE YOU TO
VOTE NO ON AB THIRTY THIRTY.
NINE TO FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. S. B.
PUBLIC SAFETY SERVANT FAMILY
MEMBER FAMILY MAN AND A
SPORTSMAN I STRONGLY OPPOSE IT.
NINE THREE SIXTY SEVEN. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE. RANDY AND
ROBIN CARLSON A LONGTIME
CALIFORNIA'S WORST MEMBERS OF
CAL AT CCA CALIFORNIA WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE. NINE FOUR
THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CHAMB BRISCOE
WITH THE TAHOE LAKEFRONT OWNERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION TO AB
THIRTY THIRTY. ONE FIFTY SEVEN.
ONE FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ROBERT
EDWARDS CALIFORNIA ANGLER
STRONGLY OPPOSE. NINE ONE FIFTY
FOUR. YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GREG SMITH DB ROD AND
GUN CLUB LOS ANGELES AREA.
MEMBERS WE WANT TO PROTECT
SHRINK WE URGE YOU TO VOTE
DAHLE HONEYBEE. THIRTY THIRTY.
TWENTY THREE FIFTY SIX. ONE
THREE FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MICHAEL
SEEWALD- AND REPRESENTING MY
LOVELY BRIDE IS AT WORK VALERI
SEWALD IN SENEGAL FISH ONLINE.
A GROUP OF HUNDREDS OF WOMEN IN
SAN DIEGO WE ALL STRONGLY
OPPOSE WHERE ALL FOR POSITIVE
THINGS BUT THIS IS A NEGATIVE
THANK CHAO. NINE TWO SEVENTY
FIVE NINE TWO SEVENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JOHN ABOUT WITH BONDO BEACH
WORK REGIONAL FISHERMEN I
BELIEVE AB THIRTY THIRTY WALL
UNDOING LOOK AT ACCESS THE
RECREATIONAL SPORT BUT
COMMUNITIES ALONG WITH THAT AB
THIRTY THIRTY LACKS ANY SORT OF
SPECIFICITY. OF HOW THIS WILL
BE HANDLED IN HOUSE OVERSIGHT
WILL BE HANDLED BECAUSE OF
THOSE REASONS I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
MY TWENTY FOUR NINE THREE TWO
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLAY GO
AHEAD. YEAH OKAY IT'S FROM NINE
HUNDRED CAN HARBOR RUN REAL
CLUB AND THE SO CAL
SPORTFISHING CLUB IGFA MEMBER
AND IF YOU SEE A MEMBER WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU. NINE
THREE SEVENTY NINE. I'M SORRY
NINE TO SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD NINE TO
SEVENTY NINE. HI PHIL SELO A
SENIOR CITIZEN- I HAVEN'T
OUTDOORSMAN STRONGLY OPPOSES
ARBITRARY AND CAPRICIOUS BILL
THANK YOU. NINE THREE EIGHTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD OKAY HELLO MY NAME IS
LARRY COURTNEY HOW WITH THE SAN
DIEGO ANGLERS AND THE COASTAL
CONSERVATION ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND. I OPPOSE AB
THIRTY THIRTY. MY FOUR FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
MOMENT NINE FOUR FIFTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. JAMES GARDNER OCEANSIDE-BIG COMPANIES OPPOSE. NINE
THREE TWENTY. TWENTY THREE
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
NINE THREE TWENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YOU MCDONALD THANKS FOR
STAYING STRONG. TWENTY FIFTEEN
MIND FIFTEEN ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
TWENTY FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT
PETER CALIFORNIA RECREATIONAL
ANGER ANGLER- I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. NINE ONE EIGHTY
THREE POINT ONE EIGHTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN FOR
DISCUSSION. GLENN HUGHES
PRESIDENT OF THE AMERICAN
SPORTFISHING ASSOCIATION AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE. NINE ONE
SEVENTY NINE SEVENTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
HI MY NAME IS KHAN REPRESENTING
DIAL CORPORATION AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE. ONE FIFTY SIX
ONE FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAPTAIN DAVID
BACON CCA CALIFORNIA CHARTER
BOAT CAPTAINS BAIT AND TACKLE
STORE OWNER I REPRESENT
RECREATIONAL ANGLERS ON THE
CHANNEL ISLANDS NATIONAL MARINE
SANCTUARY ADVISORY COUNCIL MY
CONSTITUENCY AND I OPPOSE AB
THIRTY THIRTY. I AM THREE FORTY
NINE THREE FORTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS SHRUTI CO GUARDIAN AND
I'M A CALIFORNIA ANGLER AND I
OPPOSE. NINE THREE FORTY FIVE.
NINE THREE FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS CARLENE ELLIS I'M A
CALIFORNIA ANGLER. AND I BELONG
TO THE SOUTH SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION THE NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION INTERNATIONAL
DEFENSIVE PISTOL ASSOCIATION.
SACRAMENTO DEFENSIVE PISTOL
SHOOTERS ON THE PHONE FROM
SHOOTING CLUB AND I OPPOSE AB.
THIRTY THIRTY UNLESS AMENDED
THANK YOU. PLAN THIRTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BARBARO. DON ARMSTRONG
STRONGLY OPPOSED. THANK YOU
DULY NOTED THANK YOU MODERATOR
NEXT CALLING THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MR NINE THIRTY YOUR- PLEASE.
THE BILL ARNEY AKHIR CALIFORNIA
ANGLER COASTAL CONSERVATION
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
MEMBERS I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB
THIRTY THIRTY. NINE FIVE TWENTY
FIVE NINE FIVE TWENTY FIVE YEAH
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT WAS THE
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATED
GENERAL CONTRACTORS OF
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION. NINE
TWO OH SEVEN NINE TWO OF SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SERGIO BASKET HERE AM THE OWNER
OF BUSINESSES AND THE STITCHING
AND BOATING INDUSTRY EXPERT
MARINE ELECTRONICS AND
SWORDFISH HERE. I'M ALSO
REPRESENTING TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF ANGLERS HOME WILL BE CORRECT.
HI THIS BILL. CHAU CALIFORNIA'S
CLUB LOCALES LAYERS. UNION SO
CAL GROUP KCM FISHING CLUB WEST
COAST AND- WEST YEAH. SALTY
PAYER LACK SITE REAL YOU SO CAL
THOUGHT MIGHT CAL ANGERS GROUP
AND MANY OTHERS. WE ALSO
OPPOSED AB THIRTY THIRTY DUE TO
THEIR SUFFICIENT CONSERVATION
MEASURES ALREADY BEING IN PLACE
THANK YOU SIR WE APPRECIATE
YOUR WEIGHING IN ON BEHALF OF
THOSE ORGANIZATIONS- TAKING
IDENTIFICATIONS AT THIS POINT
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER. NINE
FIVE ZERO SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
MORNING MY IS TO THEM I WAS NOT
ABLE TO BE CALLED BEFORE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL FOR THREE
FIFTY SOUTH BAY LOS ANGELES
INDIVISIBLE SOUTH BAY LOS
ANGELES TO SO CAL THREE FIFTY
ALL IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU THANK YOU YOUR SUPPORT IS
DULY NOTED MODERATOR WE WILL GO
BACK TO CALLERS IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CARE LINE FOR
FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE FOUR FORTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BRING
ON THE LINE FOR. FOUR NINE FOUR
FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I THANK YOU
THAT MY NAME IS DARREN.
SACRAMENTO CHAPTER IN
OPPOSITION THANKS. ONE SEVENTY
NINE. NINE SEVENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN ONE ONE MOMENT
NINE SEVEN ELEVEN. NINE SEVENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN AND
COMMISSIONERS ROBERT GRABER
NATIVE CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORTS
THEM FOR NEARLY SIXTY YEARS. HE
HE A MEMBER SINCE THEY CAME TO
CALIFORNIA AND IGFA MEMBER AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB THIRTY
THIRTY THANK YOU FOR TAKING
PUBLIC COMMENT. NINE EIGHTY
FOUR LINE EIGHTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN COMMISSIONERS
THIS IS STEVE CARSON ON THE
FORMER CHAIRMAN OF THE BUTTE
COUNTY FISHING GAME
ASSOCIATION. AND CURRENTLY A
MEMBER OF SAN DIEGO ANGLERS
OCEANSIDE ANGLERS AND THE
COASTAL CONSERVATION
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB THIRTY
THIRTY. NINE FOUR FORTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
COMMISSIONERS THIS IS GREG
GLEISER- REPRESENTING-
CALIFORNIA VOTERS AND RESIDENTS
HOPEFULLY THAT YOUR AND IF HE
CAN FIND ITS WAY TO HEAR THESE
VOICES AND FIND A WAY TO SEE
THE CHALLENGE OF COMPROMISE
HERE AND I AND I SHOULD
CURRENTLY IN OPPOSED. TO THIS
PROPOSAL AS IS THIS AB AS AS
PROPOSED WITHOUT AMENDMENT
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
ONE FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
SHOULD BE OVER IN BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION WE ARE OPPOSED.
NINE THREE ZERO NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
BILL ME ON- LIFEGUARD AND- ALSO
IN THERE ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED.
NINE THIRTY TO NINE THIRTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN IT'S GOT
ABOUT ONE HUNDRED. ONE CHAMBERS
DAVID CHAVEZ BECAUSE OF
CONSERVATION ASSOCIATION A
CALIFORNIA AND THEY KEPT THE
PRESIDENT BUSH FOR THE
IMPENDING LANGUAGE FOUNDATION
AND THE SAME CHEMICAL AND THEIR
FAMILIES FISHING CLUB AND
OUTDOORS. AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. NINE TWO TWENTY ONE NINE
TWO TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS CARRIE CHARLOTTE COSTA I
MAKE HER A CALIFORNIA ANGLER
AND NUMBER OF THE CEO OF
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE. NINE
TWO ZERO FOUR. NINE TWO ZERO
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS DR RICHARD
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF THIS YEAR
CALIFORNIA. AND HE
INTERNATIONAL GAME FISH
ASSOCIATION FORMERLY A MEMBER.
OF THE EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE OF
THE MAKE A WISH TO THE
CHALLENGE I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THAT BURKE THANK. MIND FOR
TWENTY. NINE FOUR TWENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M A MEMBER OF THE PGA
CALIFORNIA SHOWER FISHING CLUB
WHAT'S CLOSEST IN POOLS.
SPEARFISHING IN THE DATA OR
CLOUD REAL CLUB AND THE NRA AND
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE NUKES BOB
THIS. FIND THREE TWENTY EIGHT
POINT THREE TWENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JOSH THIS DEAL. ABBOTT
CALIFORNIA ANGLER STRONGLY
OPPOSE. NINE TWO ZERO THREE.
NINE TWO ZERO THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
TWO HUNDRED AND THREE YOU MAY
BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MOVING UN MINE ONE FIFTEEN.
NINE ONE FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING AND- ALMOND CALIFORNIA
ANGLER I STRONGLY OPPOSE. MY B.
FIFTY FIVE. NINE THREE FIFTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TWENTY CAN CLOSE THE
ACCOUNT. THIRTY JAN OPPOSE AB
THIRTY THIRTY. I'M SORRY COULD
YOU REPEAT YOUR AFFILIATION.
I'M SORRY SHE DROPPED A LINE TO
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JIM HENDRIX
REPRESENTING SOLAR SPORTSMAN
MAGAZINE SPORT FISHING MAGAZINE
AND RECORDING MAGAZINE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION AB THIRTY
THIRTY. ONE TO THIRTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GO AHEAD.
YES JASON DONE STRONGLY OPPOSE
AB THIRTY THIRTY. NINE FOUR
ZERO SIX ONE FOUR ZERO SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI BLOOD LEGAL COSTA-
CALIFORNIA ANGLER AND I'M
OPPOSED TO SB THIRTY THIRTY.
NINE FOUR FIFTY FIVE NINE FOUR
FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CHAU BERYL
REPRESENTING SAN DIEGO ANGLERS
FAMILY FISHING IS WHOSE CLUB
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE OPPOSE.
ONE FOUR THIRTY. ONE FOUR
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES. MY NAME IS JAMIE DIMON I'M
THE OWNER OF THE START OF
SPORTFISHING AND CORAL REEF
COURT ISSUING OUT LOCATED AND
MONIQUE LIMON AND SENATOR
JACKSON DISTRICT I'M ALSO ON
THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS FOR THE
SPORTFISHING ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE AVERAGE
FEMALE ANGLER AND DIFFUSER AYE
OPPOSED. EIGHTY THIRTY THIRTY.
NINE FOUR SEVENTY SIX NINE FOUR
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI JASON
DIAMOND OWNER STARDUST COURT
FISHING AND CORAL SEA SPORT
FISHING SANTA BARBARA IT
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB THIRTY
THIRTY. NINE FOUR SEVENTY NINE
FOUR SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL I MATTHEW
DIAMOND DECK AND- I'M FOURTEEN
AND DECADE OF THE ARTICLE
REPORTER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
SB. THIRTY THIRTY. NINE TO
THIRTY FOUR NINE TO THIRTY
FOUR. GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME'S
JOHN SUMMERS ARE REPRESENTING
IBEW LOCAL NINE FIVE TWO AND
FOUR THIRTEEN OVER A HUNDRED
ANGER STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
ONE ONE SIXTY ONE MY ONE SIXTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD KERN CHRIS BENTLEY NATIVE
CALIFORNIAN LIFELONG HUNTER AND
ANGLER MEMBERS CCA CALIFORNIA
IN OCEANSIDE SENIOR ANGLERS
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB THIRTY
THIRTY. THANK. NINE ONE TEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CANBERRA WHITE HOUSE. IT
YEAH WHITE HOUSE CALIFORNIA
NORCECA CAL MEMBER OPPOSE AB
THIRTY THIRD AND- NINE FOUR
TWELVE. POINT FOUR TWELVE IN
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH YOU'RE ME THIS IS MIKE
THOMPSON OWNER NEWPORT LANDING
SPORTFISHING. OR BEACH
CALIFORNIA I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF
THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF THE
SPORTFISHING ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND I'M ON AN
ADVISORY PANEL TO THE PACIFIC
FISHERY MANAGEMENT COUNCIL AND
I AM OPPOSE. NINE FOUR SEVENTY
SEVEN MIND FOR SEVENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS CLIFF FRIEND-
FROM KNIGHTS OF COLUMBUS SAYING
THERE'S NO DOWNEY AND JEAN
PRETTY SEVEN STRONGLY OPPOSE.
NINE EIGHTY SEVEN. NINE EIGHTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MACKRELL AMERICAN
FISHING TACKLE COMPANY
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSE.
NINE THREE TWENTY NINE POINT
THREE TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GERALD
RICHARDSON READING TO LEARN
VETERANS STRONGLY OPPOSED. NINE
NINETY SEVEN. MY NINETY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LAUREN OUTDOORS MAN
MEMBER OF CTA. STRONGLY OPPOSE.
NINE FIVE FOUR. ONE FIVE TWENTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE FIVE TWENTY FOUR
YOU MAY BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AND MOVING ON TO LINE TO
FORTY SIX. NINE TO FORTY SIX.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD BACK CALIFORNIA OPPOSED
COULD YOU REPEAT YOUR NAME IT
WAS CUT OFF. YES SHAUN ROONEY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NINE FIVE
TWENTY TWO. ONE FIVE TWENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I WAS THERE B. HA AND
THEN WTF MEMBER STRONGLY
OPPOSED. ONE FOUR TWENTY FIVE.
NINE FOUR TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
THIS IS WILLIAM PENNER REMEMBER
THE SOUND OF OUR FLY FISHING
CLUB AND PRESIDENT OF LOS
PADRES COUNCIL BOY SCOUTS OF
AMERICA IN STRONG OPPOSITION.
NINE SEVENTY TWO POINT SEVENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY IS JOSEPH BAILEY
ABOUT LIFELONG ANGLERS CCAP
WIFE HAS A LICENSE PLATE SON
LIKES TO FISH IT WE ALL
APPROACH A. B. THIRTY THIRTY.
THANK YOU. MY IN THREE THIRTY
FIVE. NINE THREE THIRTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOU MAY BE ON MUTE NINE
THREE THREE FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS DANIELLE
GRAF AND I OPPOSE. NINE TWO
TWENTY FIVE AND TWO TWENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ARMENIANS CHASING S.
DEVELOPMENT CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB THIRTY
THIRTY. NINE FIVE TWENTY SIX
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS KEVIN DE CADA I'M
A LIFETIME MEMBER OF CTA
CALIFORNIA AND SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER AND FISHING GUIDE AND I
AM IN STRONG OPPOSITION OF AB
THREE THIRTY. ONE SIXTY EIGHT.
POINT SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS MATT EVERINGHAM OF
EVERY MEMBER OTHERS BIG COMPANY
IN OPPOSITION TO AB THIRTY
THIRTY THANK YOU. NINE THREE
NINETY SEVEN NINE THREE NINETY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI SEAN SIR LONG TIME
CALIFORNIA YOUNGER ANGLER A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOIATION- CCA HAND ON BEHALF
OF OUR SPORTS FISHING CLUB
RECREATIONAL FISHING CLUB IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. NINE
FORTY NINE FORTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS CAPTAIN SICKENING BAG ON THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CPA CALIFORNIA
SANTA BARBARA CHAPTER ALSO
MANAGER OF A BAIT AND TACKLE
STORE- ALSO PROJECT DIRECTOR
FOR STOP IN AND WE ALL STRONGLY
OPPOSED AB THIRTY THIRTY. THANK
YOU. NINE FOUR ZERO EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S KIM
EXTRA REPRESENTING FISHERMAN'S
LANDING ROLL STARS FIFTEEN
FISHERMEN PROCESSES COLE OWNER
ALSO REPRESENT TEAM
SPORTFISHING ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA'S BOARD MEMBER
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB THIRTY
THIRTY. MIND ZERO TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. JOHN
WALL REPRESENT ISLAND JACK
SPORTFISHING CEDAR SPORTFISHING
AND CHANNEL ISLANDS
SPORTFISHING WILL STRONGLY
OPPOSE. NINE FIVE THIRTY TWO.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. SB DISAGREE
FONG. NINE FIVE THIRTY TWO.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS MICHAEL
COMING WITH THE NATIONAL
SHOOTING SPORTS FOUNDATION OF
CLOSING AT THE BILL I'M ALSO
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF DAN READ.
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS DIRECTOR OF
LOS LOBOS EDUCATION AND GET
YOUR TODAY THANK YOU. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE MIND. ONE NINETY
THREE NINE ONE NINETY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOU MAKE IT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN ONE NINETY THREE. MOVING
ON. NINE TO FORTY SEVEN. JUST A
MOMENT. TWENTY FORTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THAT BANNER AND AVID
OUTDOORSMAN STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NINE ONE
TWENTY TWO YOUR MIND PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS WENDY KOJI
HARA ON THE FISHING INDUSTRY
MANUFACTURES REPRESENTATIVE I'M
A MEMBER OF THE BOARD FOR COPA
CONSERVATION CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA USED ADVENTURES I'M
A RECREATIONAL ANGLER AND
HUNTER AND PAST REGIONAL
STAKEHOLDER FOR THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA MARINE NOT
PROTECTION ACT INITIATIVE I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB THIRTY
THIRTY. THANK YOU. NINE ONE
FIFTY TWO. ONE ONE FIFTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S BARBARA
MORTON- CALIFORNIA RECREATIONAL
ANGLER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU. MINE FOR
TEN. NINE FOUR TENURE LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
SCHERING CALOTTERY PRESIDENT OF
THE SAN DIEGO PORT JANET THE
PROCREATION REPRESENTING EIGHT
HUNDRED UPPER PORT JANET IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. NINE TWO
FIFTY ONE. NINE TWO FIFTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO YES YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YEAH NEED LEGIONS WITH
THE DATA WAR LADY ANGLERS WE'VE
BEEN AND- IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR WE ALL AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU. NINE FIVE FIFTY
ONE NINE FIVE FIFTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI AM GARY TURNER- PRESIDENT OF
THE EAST SIDE BROAD REAL CLUB
LIFETIME AGER AND HUNTER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK. NINE ONE SIXTEEN
ONE ONE SIX NINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. OUR SYSTEMIC MAN- THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE SOUTH
SACRAMENTAL CHAPTER OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION AND AN NRA MEMBER
IN STRONG OPPOSITION. NINE ONE
EIGHTY FIVE MIND ONE EIGHTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS BILL
SHOULD I AM CHAIRMAN OF THE CCA
CALIFORNIA AND EITHER CURRENT
OR PAST BOARD MEMBER OF THE
AMERICAN SPORTFISHING
ASSOCIATION. AND THE IGFA THE
INTERNATIONAL GAME FISH
ASSOCIATION AND A BEHALF OF ALL
THREE ORGANISATIONS IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO AB THIRTY THIRTY.
NINE ONE TWENTY FOUR. ONE
TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MINE ONE FIFTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
MAGGIE BEAUCHAMP AND I AM A
MEMBER OF THE BOARD
REPRESENTING OCEANSIDE ENGLISH
CLUB I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
COASTAL COME. TO BEIJING
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA.
RECREATIONAL ANGLER AND MEMBER
OF THE VIDEO STORES I'M ALSO A
PASSED DUE BALANCE THEY'RE
MAKING IT MORE. AND THEIR
FISHING. BROWN STRNGLY OPPOSE
AB. 391-407-1140 SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS SURE WOULD PROVE
SO I'M A RECREATIONAL ENGLAND
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE. MY IN.
ONE EIGHTEEN NINE ONE EIGHTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S CHRIS
THROUGHOUT EUROPE FROM THE
COASTAL CONSERVATION
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB THIRTY
THIRTY THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT MY
NAME. FORTY NINE NINE FORTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH HI SHARON
PERKINS PRESIDENT B. S. B.
ELECTRICAL CONTRACTOR CCA
MEMBER IN BEHALF OF JENNY LAKE
BASS MASTERS AND KOBE LOWERS WE
ALL STRONGLY OPPOSE SB THIRTY
THIRTY. ONE SEVENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE SEVENTY FOUR YOU MAY BE ON
MUTE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MOVING ON TO LINE.
THREE FORTY SEVEN NINE THREE
FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT MONACO I AM
ALSO A VOTING CONSTITUENTS OF
SENATOR STERN'S DISTRICT I'M A
BUSINESS OWNER AN EMPLOYEE YOUR
EMPLOYER OF TWENTY EMPLOYEES A
MEMBER OF COASTAL CONSERVATION
AMERICAN SPORTFISHING
ASSOCIATION AND WE PROVIDE RISK
MANAGEMENT SERVICES IN THE
OUTDOOR INDUSTRY AND WE ARE
STRONGLY OPPOSE IT IS CURRENTLY
WRITTEN. THANK YOU. NINE FIVE
FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
NORMAN OR RITA MEMBER OF THE
GOLDEN STATE PODCASTERS ISSUED
A CALIFORNIA AND IDFA STRONGLY.
OPPOSED AB THIRTY THIRTY. ONE
FOUR ZERO THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GEN JAMES
ROBERT LONG BEACH SPORTFISHING
STRONGLY OPPOSE. NINE FIVE
FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD I'M SORRY NINE
FIVE FORTY SEVEN DROPPED. I'M
SORRY NINE FIVE FORTY SEVEN.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD OKAY MARTIN LEVY WITH THE
INLAND SALTWATER ANGLERS CLUB
IN ABOUT EIGHTY MEMBERS ACTIVE
FISHERMEN ALSO A MEMBER OF C.
C. A. AND- STRONGLY OPPOSE SB
THIRTY THIRTY HAS WRITTEN. NINE
FOUR ZERO SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS JOHN DEERE OF AN
AVERAGE CALIFORNIA FISHERMEN
STRONGLY OPPOSED MAYBE THIRTY
THIRTY. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. NINE
THREE NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
PRIMARILY RECURRING. SANTA
BARBARA COLLEGES AND A
CONSERVATIONIST. I'M ALSO OF
SANTA BARBARA HARBOR COMMISSION
VICE CHAIR. NUMBER OF THE
CHANNEL ISLANDS THANKS VERY BY
THREE COUNCIL. THE CIVIC
FISHERIES MANAGEMENT COUNCIL
BROWN FISH ADVISORY SUB PANEL.
I'M A CCA CALIFORNIA STATE
BOARD MEMBER. COMMERCIAL
FISHERMEN OF SANTA BARBARA
NUMBER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU. NINE TO THIRTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE TO THIRTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WELL YES YES
YOU'RE A MUCH COMMERCIAL
FISHERMEN COMMERCIAL PASSENGER
FISHING VESSEL OWNER IN SELLING
CALIFORNIA I'D PROBABLY BE
THIRTY THIRTY. NINE THREE
EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
TO MAKE. THAT TO ME WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB THREE THIRTY THANK
YOU FOR. ON LINE TO NINETY SIX.
NINE THREE SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU
MY NAME IS BILL HOPPER I AM A
PORT FISHERMAN AND A MEMBER OF
THE CCA AND I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF MY FELLOW FISHERMEN
HERE IN CALIFORNIA IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY TWELVE WE WERE
SURE THAT MARINE PROTECTED
AREAS WERE TO BE SHORT TERM
STUDIES AFTER EIGHT YEARS IT IS
NOW CLEAR THE CALIFORNIA NEVER
INTENDED TO REOPEN THOSE WATERS
BACK UP TO FISHMAN IN THE
FUTURE. SB THIRTY THIRTY WOULD
ONLY ADD INSULT TO INJURY AND
FURTHER REDUCE THE OCEAN WATERS
THAT WE ARE ALLOWED TO FISHING
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE ALL
STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B. THIRTY
THIRTY. AND ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
TWENTY FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CHRIS ANDERSON ON THE
HAVE THE CERTIFICATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES WE
HAVE A POSITION OF I WAS NOT
AMENDED WE HAVE SUBMITTED
AMENDMENTS TO THE OFTEN
SPONSORS THAT WOULD ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS THEY HAVE NOT ACCEPT
THOSE AMENDMENTS BUT WE DO
APPRECIATE THEIR WILLINGNESS TO
HAVE CONVERSATIONS AND PLANNED
DISCUSSIONS. IF THE BILL IS TO
DANCE FROM THIS COMMITTEE TODAY
THANK YOU. AN NINE ONE NINETY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI LESLIE- AWASSI
COKE COCA CONSERVATIONIST OKAY
CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE TO ASSEMBLY
BILL THANK YOU. NINE TO FIFTY
SIX TWENTY FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY
YES YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH
WITH ONE LINERS MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA EIGHT FORMER
COLORFUL FUTURE AND I OPPOSE.
AB THIRTY THIRD. NINE FIVE
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS CAMERON X.
A MEMBER OF CALIFORNIA COASTAL
CONSERVATION ASSOCIATION AND I
OPPOSE AB THIRTY THIRTY. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. NINE FIVE TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES THIS IS JAMES
WATSON WITH THE SELF OF GOING
TO BE DRAWN GUN CLUB VEHEMENTLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. NINE ONE
THIRTY EIGHT. MY ONE THIRTY
EIGHT. JUST A MOMENT. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
ONE THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN YOU MAY BE ON MUTE. AND
MOVING ON ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
NINE THREE THIRTY SIX NINE
THREE THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS-OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD YES BUT IT.
MY NAME IS DOUG LASKO ON
PRESIDENT OF THE COMMISSION
TACKLE I'M A BOARD MEMBER OF
THE COSTA CONSERVATIONISTS WILL
SOLICITATION AND A MEMBER OF
THE AMERICAN SPORTFISHING
ASSOCIATION AND HAS WRITTEN
WITHOUT CLARIFICATION ON.
RECREATIONAL FISHING
OPPORTUNITIESWE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE- NINE ONE TWENTY
SEVEN ONE ONE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS ERIN
PETERS WITH THE SANTA BARBARA
FREE DIVERS CLUB WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE A. B. THIRTY THIRTY.
THANK YOU. NINE EIGHTY EIGHT
NINE EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
EIGHTY EIGHT YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE MOMENT FOR
THE NEXT NINE. NINE FIVE
FOURTEEN POINT FIVE FOURTEEN.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S MATT HOW
ARE MANY FACTOR REPRESENTING
OPPOSITION TO AB THIRTY THIRTY.
NINE FIVE SIXTY ONE NINE FIVE
SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD ARCHFORD MEMBER
OF LONG BEACH NEPTUNE STRONGLY
OPPOSE. NINE FIVE SIXTY THREE.
NINE FIVE SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. AT
JOHN GONZALEZ PACIFIC SEAFOOD
OPPOSED THANK YOU. ONE FOUR
SEVENTEEN HE JUST A MOMENT NINE
FOUR SEVENTEEN POINT FOUR
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS IS
JEFF BELL ON A MEMBER OF THE
COASTAL CONSERVATION
ASSOCIATION A MEMBER OF THE
ROCKY MOUNTAIN ELK FOUNDATION A
MEMBER OF THE FUNERALS ALL
CONSERVATION PARTNERSHIP.
MEMBER THE BACKCOUNTRY HUNTERS
AND ANGLERS AND A MEMBER OF TE
LONG BEACH THE CONSCRIPTION
CLUB IN A STRONGLY AB THIRTY
THIRTY. NINE FIVE FORTY ONE
NINE FIVE FORTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HILLS
CERTAIN VENTURA RECREATIONAL
ANGLER MEMBER OF CCA HELLO.
WRONG OPPOSITION. NINE TO
NINETY FOUR NINE TO NINETY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE PLEASE
GO AHEAD ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. THANK
YOU JOHN JOHNSTON LONG BEACH
NEPHEWS STRONGLY OPPOSE. NINE
THREE FIFTY EIGHT NINE THREE
FIFTY EIGHT OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS CODY SAID
I'M DHARMENDRA APCO AND THE CCA
CALIFORNIA LIFE NUMBER. I'M
OPPOSED TO AB THIRTY THIRTY.
MINE FIVE FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWO
BOARD MEMBER OF CALIFORNIA
STATE FARM COLORS ASSOCIATION
ALSO CALIFORNIA BY TEN LICENSE
ANGLER UNDER VOTER AN
OUTDOORSMAN STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
THIRTY THIRTY. NINE TO NINETY
ONE NINETEEN NINETY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH MY NAME IS MY NAME IS
GERRY WHITE. I AM A C. C. A. R.
CALIFORNIA MEMBERS. I'M A VOTER
I AM A FRIEND OF THE FRED HALL
SHOWS AND ALLEGE KAKO
COATBRIDGE YOUR SHOW AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE ALONG WITH
EVERYBODY ELSE WHO'S CALLED IN.
STRONGLY OPPOSE IT. THIRTY
THREE. MIND TWENTY FIVE POINT
THREE TWENTY FIVE PM LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
THREE TWENTY NINE. GO AHEAD
PLEASE. MARK MATCH CAL ANGLER
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB THIRTY
THIRTY. NINE THREE THIRTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI JULIAN LEE LOS
ANGELES CALIFORNIA RECREATIONAL
ANGLER AND DIVERT FORTY YEARS
STRONGLY OPPOSE. EIGHT THIRTY
THIRTY. NINE THREE FORTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO YES YOU'RE ON
YEAH- MY NAME IS MAX FLORES I'M
CALIFORNIA ANGLER AND I OPPOSE
SB THIRTY THIRTY. NINE TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY TO THIRTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOU MAY BE ON MUTE MINE
TOO THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MOVING ON. TO NINETY THREE
FIFTY TWO ONE THREE FIFTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS MICHAEL
B. DOES THE- COASTAL
CONSERVATION ASSOCIATION AND I
OPPOSE IT. NINE SIX TWENTY
EIGHT POINT SIX TWENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI I AM AND YOUR KELLOGG
AGREED CALIFORNIA ANGLER HUNTER
AND OUTDOORSMAN STRONGLY
OPPOSED. NINE SIX TWENTY NINE
SIX TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU ONE MOMENT
PEASE NINE SIX TWENTY. AND IS
NOW OPEN. YES MY NAME IS DONNA
CABLE AND THE OWNER OF DANA
WHARF SPORTFISHING IN DANA
POINT CALIFORNIA I'M ALSO A
MEMBER AT THE STATE CAPITOL.
ALSO A MEMBER OF SPORTFISHING
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AS
WELL THE GAME TO WORK LADY IN
WORDS I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
THIRTY THIRTY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MINE FOR FIFTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MARCUM LOOK AT HIM WITH A
CALIFORNIA SPORTS FISHING LAKE
OUR ORGANIZATION URGES YOU TO
CONSIDER TE VIEW OF CALIFORNIA
ANGLERS AND WE OPPOSE AB THIRTY
THIRTY AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED. MY
ONE THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING I AM CHARLES SHOEMAKER
I AM A MEMBER OF CTA CAL I AM A
PAST PRESIDENT OF THE LOS
ANGELES RUN REAL CLUB WHICH IS
ONE OF THE OLDEST FISHING CLUBS
IN THE COUNTRY WE OPPOSE SB
THIRTY THIRTY. THANK YOU. NINE
FOUR SEVENTY ONE LINE FOR
SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
GO AHEAD. THIS IS GEORGE
OSBORNE REPRESENTING THE COAST
SIDE DISHING CLUB CLOSE IS
OPPOSED AND LESS AMENDED THANK
YOU. NINE SIX THIRTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GRAMMOND RECREATIONAL
FISHERMEN- CALIFORNIA STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB THIRTY THIRTY. NINE
SIX EIGHTEEN POINT SIX EIGHTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS BILL THE PREVIOUS
REPRESENTING PACIFIC COAST
SPORTFISHING MAGAZINE STRONGLY
OPPOSE. NINE ONE SEVENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BY ONE SEVENTY SEVEN YOU
MAY BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LIVING ON TO
LINE. SIX SEVENTEEN NINE SIX
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BOB ZERO CCA
CAL MEMBER FORMER BOARD MEMBERS
HERE P. A. WESTERN REGIONAL
ORGANIZER FOR APPLE C. PROJECT
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
THIRTY THIRTY. THANK YOU
MODERATOR I JUST WANT TO DO A
QUICK TIME CHECK HERE IT'S A
LITTLE AFTER NOON. WE HAVE
ABOUT THIRTY SIX IN THE QUEUE
WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO IS GET
THROUGH OUR REMAINING CALLERS
IN OPPOSITION- AND THEN MINE
PLAN WOULD BE TO TAKE A SHORT
RECESS FOR STAFF. IN MEMBERS
COME BACK THEN FOR COMMITTEE
DISCUSSION AND A VOTE. BUT WE
WILL MAKE IT THROUGH THE
OPPOSITION CALLERS THANK YOU
MODERATOR YOU'RE DOING A GREAT
JOB THANK YOU CALLERS FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. IN I THINK WE'RE ON
THE STRETCH SO LET'S CONTINUE
THANK IN. THANK YOU CARE AND
LINE FIVE THIRTY THREE NINE
FIVE THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS CAN
FRANKIE REPRESENTING THE
SPORTFISHING ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS TWENTY
SECOND STREET SPORTFISHING
LANDING CHANNEL ISLANDS
SPORTFISHING DANA WHARF
SPORTFISHING DAVID WALKER
SPORTFISHING. FISHERMAN'S
LANDING HELP BRING SPORTFISHING
HMM LANDING HOAX LANDING WE
PALM SPORT FISHERS LONG BEACH
SPORTFISHING MARINA DEL REY
SPORTFISHING NEWPORT LANDING
OCEANSIDE SEA CENTER
SPORTFISHING. SPORTFISHING
POINT ALMOST. REDONDO BEACH
SPORTFISHING C. FOR
SPORTFISHING AND VENTURA-
HARBOR SPORTFISHING AS WAS
START A SPORTFISHING AND WE'RE
OPPOSED UNLESS DEMANDED THANK
YOU. NINE FIVE SIXTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE FIVE SIX FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHAT
HAPPENED CHEN MEMBERS PLANNING
A TRIP FOR A CHRISTIAN MCCAULEY
LEFT AND GENERAL MANAGER OF THE
STATE WATER CONTRACTORS ON
BEHALF OF THE TWENTY THOUSAND
PUBLIC WATER AGENCIES. A POST
SB. THIRTY THIRTY UNTIL AMENDED.
NINE FIVE FORTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
REAL FRANKA CALIFORNIA ANGLER
LIFETIME CCA CALIFORNIA MEMBER
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE. NINE SIX
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MICHAEL NAME.
THANK YOU FOR SUPPORTING
SOCIETY MY PHONE NUMBER BUT YOU
MOUNT OAK FOUNDATION SOCIAIS
ASIAN STRONGLY OPPOSE THIRTY
THIRTY. AT BY FIFTY SIX POINT
FIVE FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. JEFF
BENEDICT CALIFORNIA NATIVE
MEMBER OF THE COASTAL
CONSERVATION ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIAAND PRESIDENT OF THE
LONG BEACH NEPTUNE'S. WE
REGULAR SPRING UNIVERSALLY
OPPOSED EIGHTY THIRTY THIRTY IN
ITS CURRENT STATE. ONE SEVENTY
THREE LINE SEVENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MY NAME IS DAN FOUTS I AM A
LICENSED SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
ANGLER WHOSE BUSINESS SEVEN
MONICA BANNED FROM REDONDO TO
MALIBU FOR THE LAST FIFTY
YEARS. AND A FORMER COMMERCIAL
ALBACORE FISHERMEN I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB THIRTY THIRTY THANK
YOU. TWENTY SIX ZERO SEVEN NINE
SIX ZERO SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ZERO
PETERSON LIFETIME FISHERMEN OUT
OUTDOOR VILLAGESSTRONGLY
OPPOSE BILL THIRTY THIRTY. NINE
FOR THIRTY SEVEN MINE FOR
THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS JOE
MARKET I'M A MEMBER OF THE
COASTAL CONSERVATION
ASSOCIATION ALSO A MEMBER OF
THE LOS ANGELES TRIED IN REAL
CLOSE. AMONG THE FOUNDATION OF
THE LOS ANGELES FROM A REAL
CLUB FOUNDATION IMPOSE THIS
THIRTY EIGHTY. CAR. ONE SEVENTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS CHARLES
GOING SOON I AM A CONSERVATION
MINDED AND RECREATIONAL
FISHERMEN AND- A MEMBER OF
TEACHING LEARNERS AND IMPOSED.
MISINFORM HAVE MAYBE THIRTY
THIRTY. NINE SIX THIRTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS KATHY
SALICIN AND I'M A MEMBER OF THE
CCA AND I OPPOSE AB THIRTY
THIRTY THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. NINE THREE SIXTY SIX
POINT THREE SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
MA'AM MY NAME IS DAN KIRBY. I'M
A LIFE MEMBER OF TGA CALIFORNIA
AS PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
GOLDEN STATE TRACTOR DO SO
SUFFICIENT. LIFE MEMBER- THE
AMATEUR TOUCHING SUFFICIENT AND
THAT WE ALL OPPOSE IT SB THIRTY
THIRTY WE'VE HAD ENOUGH OF OUR
RIGHTS TAKEN AWAY FROM US.
THANK YOU. NINE FIVE FIFTY FOUR
NINE FIVE FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU
MAY BE ON MUTE MINE FIVE FIFTY
FOR YOUR- YOUR LINE IS ALIVE.
HI MY NAME IS VALERIE HANSEN
I'M AN AVID ANGLER I'M A MEMBER
OF G. C. A. AND CALIFORNIA A
MEMBER OF FAVORS FIGURES
CHRISTIAN FISHING CLUB FISHING
DIRECTOR OF OPERA BOASTS OCEAN
SPORTS CLUB AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB THIRTY THIRTY THANK
YOU. TWENTY FIVE FORTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOU MAY BE ON MUTE LINE
FIVE FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
MYNAME IS JEFF RANGERS ON THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CENTER FOR
SPORTFISHING POLICY WHEN WE ARE
OPPOSED TO SB THIRTY THIRTY AND
I WANT TO REITERATE THE
OPPOSITION. FROM OUR PILLAR
PARTNERS AT THE AMERICAN
SPORTFISHING ASSOCIATION THE
COASTAL CONSERVATION
ASSOCIATION THE NATIONAL MARINE
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION THE
INTERNATIONAL GAME FISH
ASSOCIATION AND VOTE U. S.
THANKS VERY MUCH. MINE FOR
FIFTY FOUR MIND FIFTY FOUR.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ALEX PLAN BACK WITH DIO
CORPORATION AND CCA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB THIRTY
THIRTY. NINE THREE EIGHTY FOUR
NINE THREE EIGHTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS A FIVE MONTH GO AHEAD.
THE NEEDS TO CALL BY AND THE
OWNER OF THIS IS LANDING IN
MARIN BANKS ALSO REPRESENTING
GIOVANNI'S FISH MARKET. IF
YOU'RE A MEMBER I REQUEST
FISHERMEN STRONGLY OPPOSE SB
THIRTY THREE. NINE FORTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI AM LORI STEELE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE WEST
COAST SEAFOOD PROCESSORS
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING
TODAY'S SEVERAL CALIFORNIA
BASED. COMPANIES INCLUDING KATO
FISCHER IN CALIFORNIA SHELLFISH
COMPANY SPECIFIC GROUP
MORNINGSTAR FISHERY ALIENTO
LAZIO FISH COMPANY AND SEVERAL
OTHERS SPEAKERS COMPANIES.
INCLUDING BORNSTEIN THE FOOD.
THE IS SHARKS. I'M WONDERING
WHY IN STRONG OPPOSITION IN
EIGHTY THIRTY THANK. MY FIVE
NINETY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DESPITE WAY
STAKEHOLDER ORANGE COUNTY.
ANYBODY CAN BE TRACKING
INFORMATION CALL WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIRTY. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE NINE SIX FORTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS DANIELLE
COULD BE A AT THE AMERICAN
MARKETING ASSOCIATION I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF OVER A
HUNDRED BUSINESS OWNERS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED.
NINE SIX FORTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BRADLEY MATTSON OF THE YEAH
WE'RE GONNA BE JOBS CLUB AND
BEACH CITIES BASS CLUB WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB KERN BIRD
THANK YOU. AND ONE MOMENT FOR
THE NEXT NINE. NINE FIVE NINETY
FIVE MY NAME'S NOT FIVE NINETY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS%
PETER PHILLIPS I'M A DIRECTOR
WITH THE RECREATIONAL BOATERS
OF CALIFORNIA A DIRECTOR WITH
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
YACHTING ASSOCIATION AND I
OPPOSE. SB THIRTY THIRTY IN ITS
CURRENT FORM. NINE SIX HUNDRED
NINE SIX HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE SIX
HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
LIVING ON ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
NINE SIX ZERO SIX NINE SIX ZERO
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
SERGIO FEINSTEIN I AM THE HOST
OF BANGOR CHRONICLES TELEVISION
SHOW ON FOX SPORTS WEST I'M
ALSO A HOST OF ANGER CHRONICLES
RADIO TALK SHOW ON ANGEL'S
RADIO AND THE THIRTY QUE LA HEY
I'M A MEMBER OF COASTAL
CONSERVATION ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA. AND MEMBER OF
DOZENS OF FISHING CLUBS. THIS
ASSOCIATIONS CALIFORNIA ON
BEHALF OF ALL OUR VIEWERS AND
LISTENERS ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION CALIFORNIA LICENSE
ANGLERS AND ALMOST SIX HUNDRED
NINETY THOUSAND HUNTING
LICENSES AT SEVEN WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB. THIRTY THIRTY AS
WRITTEN. THANK YOU. NINE SIX
TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI BRIAN PERSONAL
PROVISIONAL ANGLER IGFA NUMBERS
MEMBER ON LIFETIME CALIFORNIA
VISUALIZE OLD HOLDER IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL IS
WRITTEN THANK. NINE SIX THIRTY
NINE MY SIX THIRTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
THANKS FOR. NINE SIX THIRTY
NINE YEAR LINE IS OPEN. THE
BILL EIGHTEEN THIRTY THIRTY.
PHOTO AP THIRTY THIRTY TOUCH
THAT NATIONAL LAND DOG THE
WATER TO KEEP THE WATERS AND
THAT JOB IN THE END. WHAT ARE
YOU SURE OVER DRAFTING CLINCH.
HE ISSUE AND- NINE FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT NINE FIVE THIRTY EIGHT.
JUST A MOMENT. FIVE EIGHTY ONE
NINE FIVE EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS DANNY JACKSON
PRODUCER OF ANGLER CHRONICLES
ON FOX SPORTS WEST TELEVISION
REPRESENTING TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF VIEWERS WE ALL STRONGLY
OPPOSE A. B THIRTY THIRTY
THANK YOU. NINE SIX FIFTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE SHAME- SIR
CALIFORNIA WRANGLER I OPPOSE SB
THIRTY THIRTY. NINE SIX NINE
ONLINE SIX NINETEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD THIS IS
CHRIS BAILEY PRESIDENT DAN
ANGLING CLUB CALIFORNIA
RECREATIONAL FISHERMEN
CALIFORNIA COMMERCIAL FISHERMEN
MEMBER-IGFA I STRONGLY OPPOSE
AB THIRTY THIRTY. INSTRUMENT.
NINE THREE NINETY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE THREE NINE FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU
MAY BE ON MUTE. NINE THREE
NINETY FIVE UNITS OPEN. MOVING
ON. NINE SIX THIRTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON JANICE
RUTHERFORD SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
NATIVE WITH A FAMILY LINE THAT
GOES IN CALIFORNIA BACK YOU
WILL CALIFORNIA IS A STATE OF
CILIATED WITH A LOT OF THE SNAP
TUNES ARE. COOL OPPOSE THE BILL
AS WRITTEN. TWENTY SIX TWENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MARKET TWENTY SECOND
STREET LANDING POINT LOMA
SPORTFISHING INDEPENDENT
SPORTFISHING CHAMPION HERE IN
NEWPORT BAY COMPANIES WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB THIRTY
THIRTY. YEAH THANK YOU. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. NINE SIX ZERO
EIGHT. NINE SIX ZERO EIGHT.
JUST A BRIEF MOMENT. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. ONE SIX ZERO EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU WITH THE KATHY LYNCH-
REPRESENTING THE OFF ROAD LET
VEHICLE COALITION STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATION HEADQUARTERED IN
SAN DIEGO SAFARI CLUB
INTERNATIONAL OUTDOOR SPORTS
COALITION OF CALIFORNIA AND
CALIFORNIA COURT BY THE ON
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU. MY
ZERO THREE NINE TWO THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
PLEASE CHECK YOUR MUTEBUTTON
NINE TWO ZERO THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO IRAN. GOOD
AFTERNOON ARE GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS THIS TIME THE
STARS THE BOOK A GROUP CALLING
ON BEHALF OF KERN COUNTY WATER
AGENCY SAN BERNARDINO VALLEY
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC
BALANCE PUBLISHING OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU. NINE FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT AND FIVE THIRTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FRANK HELLO YES YOU'RE
ON. HI MY NAME'S FRANK GRETA
I'M A THIRD GENERATION SANTA
TUNA FISHERMEN. FORMER
COMMERCIAL SPORT FISHERMAN AND
OWNER OF SPORTFISHING BOAT
PRODUCER OUT OF H. M. LANDING
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE. NINE SIX
FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
GREGORY ON ITS ON THE ROAD IN
THE FRESNO COUNTY AND FOR THE
HUNDREDS OF THIS GRANT
COMMUNITIES THAT SUFFER FROM
LACK OF ACCESS AN ADVERSE
EFFECTS FROM THE IMPACT OF
DECLINING BIODIVERSITY I. URGE
YOU ALL TO SUPPORT AB. EIGHT
THIRTY THIRTY. THANK YOU LETTER
THAT EXCEED FIVE DULY NOTED WE
ARE TAKING CALLS IN OPPOSITION
NOW BUT IF ANYONE DIDN'T GET TO
VOICE. WE WILL HEAR YEAR.
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT THANKS.
SIX SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON
JIM HOUSER REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA MARINE AFFAIRS AND
NAVIGATION CONFERENCE IN
ASSOCIATION OF ALL COASTAL
HARBORS IN CALIFORNIA. THE ONLY
WAY TO HAVE FULL PROTECTION OF
THEIR I'M SORRY WE'RE NOT TOO
MANY TESTIMONY RIGHT NOW YEAR
OPPOSITION IS DULY NOTED THANK
YOU MODERATOR NEXT YEAR LARGER.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. ONE SIX
SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD WE'LL JUST KEEP
GOING I THANK YOU MY NAME IS
STEVEN CHILDS PRESIDENT
CALIFORNIA STATE FARM CALLERS
ASSOCIATION MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY
AND THE SIERRA CLUB AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB THIRTY
THIRTY. AND NINE SIX SIXTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I TERMINATE
COMMISSIONERS CHRISTOPHER
MCCLELLAN HERE- RESIDENT OF
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA ANGLER
ALSO A FREQUENT CUSTOMER OF
DENTAL WORK SPORTFISHING IN
STRONG OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTY
THIRTY THANK YOU. NINE SIX. SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WE'RE FORMER RESIDENT OF
THE MIDDLE NAME IS SIMON IN
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB. THIRTY
THIRTY. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAME MODERATOR WE
APPRECIATE YOUR SERVICE THIS
MORNING YOU'VE DONE A GREAT JOB
I WANT TO THANK ALL THOSE WHO
WAIT IN BOTH WAS SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. WE ARE GOING TO
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
NOW- AND BEFORE WE START I WANT
TO URGE COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO
MAKE THEIR WAY BACK. TO THE
COMMITTE ROOM WE WILL CLOSE
OUT THIS BILL FIRST WITH
CONVERSATION AND THEN A VOTE
AND THEN WE WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
OPEN SADDAM. I WANT TO THANK
THOSE HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE FOR YOUR PATIENCE-
BRINGING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE I'M GOING TO GO FIRST
TO. SENATOR STERN. WHOSE FIRST
IN THE QUEUE AND THEN I
RECOGNIZE SENATOR HUESO
FOLLOWING SENATOR STERN.
SENATOR STERN THE FLOOR'S YOURS.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- AND
THANKS FOR DOING SUCH AN
EXCELLENT JOB OF PRESIDING IN
MY ABSENCE HERE TODAY- DO TO.
KOBE RELATED CIRCUMSTANCES I
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO MAKE IT UP
THERE BUT I DO WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE FOR THEIR PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY- AND FOR THEIR
ENGAGEMENT THROUGHOUT THIS
PROCESS. THAT WE ARE IN A VERY
SPECIAL STATE WITH TREMENDOUS
BIODIVERSITY IN OUR RESOURCES.
AND WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE ALSO
OF A MASS EXTINCTION EVENT BOTH
IN CALIFORNIA AND ABROAD SO-
THE BILL TODAY BEFORE US I FIND
TO BE INCREDIBLY TIMELY AND
IMPORTANT- BUT I ALSO THINK
THERE'S A MISUNDERSTANDINGS
HERE THAT. I WISH COULDHAVE
BEEN RESOLVED BEFORE THIS
HEARING- I MYSELF GREW UP AS A
AS AN ANGLER- FREE DIET BEING
AND SPEAR FISHING AS WELL. OF
THE SEVEN. COAST AND IN AREA
WHERE THERE WAS A MARINE
PROTECTED AREA WITH NO TAKE
ALLOWANCES AND THEN RIGHT NEXT
DOOR- SOME LIMITED TAKE
OPPORTUNITIES AND- I SAW. FROM
MY FRIENDS AND- WELL I GREW UP
WITH AND STILL STILL STAY CLOSE
TO A TREMENDOUS STEWARDSHIP OF
OUR LAND AND I THINK THE SAME
COULD BE SAID FOR. MANY OF THE
WILD SHEEP FOLKS IN THE DEAR
FOLKS IN A LOT OF OTHERS WHO
CONSIDER THEMSELVES GOOD
STEWARDS OF OUR LAND- I DON'T
CONSIDER THIS BILL IN ANY WAY
AN INDICTMENT OR RESTRICTION ON
THOSE KINDS OF ACTIVITIES AND
WE REALLY TRIED THROUGH THE
COMMITTEE TEN MINS- I DON'T
KNOW HOW MUCH ALL THE CALLERS
WERE IN FACT BRIEFED ON. THE
WORK WE DID HE OR ZACHARY YOU
WERE TOLD THIS BILL DOES. THERE
WAS. IT DEPENDS MAY BE ADDED I
WANT TO SORT OF SET THE
WHATEVER PER STAY HAVE BEEN
MADE ASIDE WEEK WEEK WE GOVERN
IN LAW HERE AND THE LANGUAGE IN
THE BILL MATTERS- THE
AMENDMENTS MADE MAKE CLEAR THAT
THIS BILL DOES NOT CONTRAVENE
ANY OTHER EXISTING LAWS OR
REGULATIONS SO WHETHER THAT'S-
A MARINE PROTECTED AREAS-
THERE'S NOTHING IN HERE TO AND
AROUND THAT PROCESS AND FORCE-
SOME. ON CALIFORNIA FISHING
INDUSTRY. LIKEWISE DIDN'T THE
MEASURE THE AMENDMENTS MAKE
CLEAR THAT BOTH RECREATIONAL
AND COMMERCIAL STAKEHOLDERS ARE
NOW GOING TO BE DIRECTLY
ENGAGED IN THE IMPLEMENTATION
PROCESS YOU ARE NOT GOING TO
BE. CUT OUT FROM THE
CONVERSATION GOING FORWARD WE
WANT YOU TO HAVE A SEAT AT THE
TABLE IN FACT IF WE'RE GONNA
SOLVE THIS GLOBAL CRISIS WE
NEED. THEIR OPPOSITION AND THE
SUPPORT ON THIS BILL TO BOTH BE
STANDING SIDE BY SIDE TO
PROTECT OUR LANDS- FROM LOSING
ALL LIVING SPECIES IN THE NEXT
SEVERAL DECADES- SO. THE BILL
IN ADDITION ALLOWING COMMERCIAL
AND RECREATIONAL STAKEHOLDERS
TO THE TABLE AND MAKING CLEAR
THAT WE DON'T UNDERMINE ANY
OTHER EXISTING LAWS THE ONE
OTHER PIECE I WANTED TO TOUCH
ON THAT MAY PROVIDE A LITTLE
MORE CLARITY. THAN THAN SOME OF
THE PAST YOU'RE GOING ON AROUND
THE BILL- IS THAT IT ALSO WON'T
A DISINCENTIVE EYES OR UNDERCUT
THE ABILITY FOR FOLKS TO ENTER
SAY CONSERVATION EASEMENT IN
FACT THE BILL EXPLICITLY MAKES
REFERENCE TO WORKING WITH
WILLING. PRIVATE LANDOWNERS- WE
THINK THAT ON OUR FARMLANDS. OR
OUR- OUR DUCK CLUBS THAT WORK
WITH OUR RICE FARMERS OR OTHER
KINDS OF RESERVES OUT THERE THE
DOCTOR IN FACT EXCELLENT AN
INCREDIBLY PRODUCTIVE USES OF
CALIFORNIA LANDED BOTH SURVIVE
DIVERSITY AND- AND ALLOW US TO-
CONTINUE TO- GO THROUGH EITHER
RECREATIONAL COMMERCIAL
OPPORTUNITY SO. I'M A BIT DAY.
OF PROTECT DOES. PUT
CONSERVATION BUT DOESN'T MEAN
THAT YOUR INTERESTS ARE OF THE
WHO ARE OPPOSED TO OUT THERE
ARE GOING TO BE LAST IN A I
THINK THAT. THE OVERSIGHT
FUNCTION THAT. IN TWO SUPPORT
SHARE THIS SENATE NATURAL IN
WATER TO ANISSA YOU A JUROR
EQUITY STE IN SEEING HEALTHY
GOES THE DOES KALAU HERE IN WE
DON'T WANT TO SEE THE END OF
SAY ARE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
MOUNTAIN LION OR GARIBALDI- THE
DO YOU KNOW THE GIANT WHITE SEA
BASS- YOU KNOW OR OR SOME OF
OUR OTHER THREATEN TRES REAL
SPECIES. WE CAN DO BOTH HERE I
THINK THIS BILL IS READY- I
THINK THAT THE AMENDMENTS
PROVIDE SOME IMPORTANT
CLARIFICATION. AND I REALLY
HOPE THAT I DIDN'T HEAR MUCH IN
ENGAGEMENT- FROM THE OPPONENTS
ABOUT THE MEANINGFUL AMENDMENTS
MADE TO THE MEASURE OR HOW HOW
FAR WE TRIED TO PUSH HERE. BUT
I HOPE AT LEAST THOSE WHO HAVE
BEEN MAY BE TOLD THAT THIS BILL
WILL SHUT OFF YOUR ABILITY TO
BE AN ANGLER HUNTER IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA RECOGNIZE
THAT. THAT'S SIMPLY NOT TRUE I
RECOGNIZE THE- THAT PEOPLE
MAYBE WANT A LITTLE MORE
GRANULARITY IN THE DEFINITION
BUT I THINK THE FLEXIBILITY IS
ACTUALLY CRITICAL TO ALLOWING
SOME OF THESE OTHER USES BEING
ENGAGED SO. I'M GONNA BE
SUPPORT THE MEASURE TODAY AND I
DO APPRECIATE. EVERYONE'S
EFFORTS HERE. THANK YOU SENATOR
STERN IN ORDER I RECOGNIZE
CENTER REQUEST SO FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR BORCHERS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND GIVEN THAT WE'VE
ALL BEEN GIVEN GUIDELINES BY
WHICH WE MUST CONFORM AN ASSET
TO REMOVE BILLS THAT WERE NOT
RELATED TO COVERT AND EVEN I
HAD BILLS THAT WERE REMOVED
THAT WERE COVERED RELATED I
WANNA SEE AUTHORED TERMS OF
WHAT IS THIS BILLS CONNECTIONS
CO THE CRISIS CURRENTLY THAT
WAS MY CONCERN AS WELL. THANK
YOU CENTER WAS. THANK YOU- FOR
THAT QUESTION ANYA THE CUT THE
PUT THE COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC
UNDERSCORES. THE PROTECTION OF
FRAGILE INTACT ECOSYSTEMS
CRITICAL TO PUBLIC HEALTH WELL
BEING- NOT ONLY. IS THE
PROTECTION OF OUR BIODIVERSITY
AND- OUR OUR ECOSYSTEMS
CRITICAL BUT WE CAN SEE RIGHT
NOW IN THE PAST FEW MONTHS
WE'VE BEEN ASKED TO SHELTER AT
HOME. THAT ACCESS TO AN EVENT
AND AVAILABILITY- AND THE
PRESENCE OF OUR OPEN SPACES AND
PROTECTED SPACES- HAS BEEN ONE
OF THE FEW RESPITE THREE BEEN
ALLOWED. TO AN AGENT. AS TO THE
PROTECTIONS OF THE ECOSYSTEMS
DO NOT DISEASES LIKE OVER
NINETEEN RESULT FROM HUMAN
WILDLIFE INTERACTIONS LIKE
THOSE THAT OCCURRED- IT THROUGH
INCLUSION ON WILDLIFE HABITAT
PROTECTING MORE OPEN SPACE WILL
DECREASE HUMAN CONTACT WILDLIFE
TO TRAVEL DECREASES BUT AS
OXY'S IS HUMANS- I CAN
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
I'M SORRY YOU'RE YOU'RE RACING
THROUGH SOMETHING FOR- IT THE-
A COUPLE DIFFERENT THINGS AND
SO ONE IS A PROTECT PROTECT
MORE OPEN DECREASES HUMAN
CONTACT WITH WILDLIFE WHICH IN
TURN WILL DO THIS FOR. HUMAN
SIGN UP FOR JUST GOT I'M TRYING
TO GET SOME BREAD FROM BUT YOU
EXT THAT THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
FIGHTING COVETED TWENTY THIRTY.
IF IT'S NOT OPEN TO BE OTHER.
RESULTS OF US NOT- NOT BEING
CONSCIOUS OF PROTECTING
BIODIVERSITY THERE'S NO DOUBT
ABOUT THAT AND WE'VE SEEN
INCREASE OF DISEASE IS BASED
UPON OUR DESTRUCTION ABOUT
DIVERSITY. ABOUT SEPARATE FROM
THAT IS THE IDEA OF HAVING
ENSURING I THINK THE LAST FEW
MONTHS OF SHOWN ACCESS TO
MEANINGFUL RECREATION. OUTDOOR
SPACES WATER. OCEAN RIVER WAYS
PARKS OPEN SPACES HAS BEEN
CRITICAL FOR OUR MENTAL HEALTH
IN REVIEWING YOUR BILL IT HAS
NO MENTION OF ACCESS AND I'LL
I'LL EXPLAIN THAT BECAUSE- I'M
VERY FAMILIAR WITH CALIFORNIA'S
COAST AND OPEN SPACES AND A LOT
OF THOSE ARE PROTECTED AND
DON'T ALLOW ACCESS. AND YOUR
BILL HAS NO MENTION RELATED TO
ACCESS AND I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THAT WERE ALLOWED TO
ACCESS OPEN SPACE AND HIS. ARE
BOTH LOCKED. SO I WILL LIKE TO
SEE IS LEVEL OF MENTION THAT AS
THIS MOVES FORWARD. THAT WE
MAKE REFERENCE TO ACCESS
BECAUSE YOU'RE MAKING THAT
ARGUMENT FROM THE PODIUM BUT
IT'S NOT IN THE BILL. OF THAT
THE OTHER THING I'D LIKE TO
ADDRESS HIS- THE 30% NUMBER
WHAT'S THAT I MEAN I MEAN. I'M%
I'M OK IF IT'S NOT BUT I JUST
WANT UNDERSTAND WHAT WHAT
AMOUNT OF LAND. AND HAS SINCE
BEEN ABLE HAVE WE BEEN ABLE TO
BECAUSE WE HAVE. FEDERAL BLM
LANDS WE HAVE STATE LANDS WE
HAVE FEDERAL. PARK LANDS WE
HAVE. BOB PROTECTED LANDS THAT
WE'VE ENTERED INTO AGREEMENTS
WITH PRIVATE OWNERS WE YOU KNOW
FRANKLY THERE ARE SOME REALLY
REACH BRIDGE PEOPLE ON THE
COAST OF CALIFORNIA AND THEY
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO RAISE A LOT
OF MONEY TO PURCHASE LAND
AROUND THEIR PROPERTY SO THAT
THEY'RE NEVER DEVELOPED. WELL
IT IT SERVES FOR TWO PURPOSES
TO PROTECT OUR COASTAL VIEWS I
GET IT AND THAT NOBODY EVER BUT
IT ALSO HAS. A OF UP TO PROTECT
THAT LAND FOR MARINE DIVERSITY
AND THEY GET A BIG TAX BREAK IN
DOING THAT. THEY THEY THEY
RAISE MONEY TO A NON TO ACCESS
A SLOW AND THEN. THEY GET TO
BASICALLY USE IT FOR THEIR OWN
PURPOSE BUT THERE'S NO PUBLIC
ACCESS AND THAT I HOPE THAT
WE'RE NOT ENGAGING IN THAT KIND
OF ACTIVITY TO THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T REALLY. HELP
US WITH WITH ACCESS AND FROM
MUCH MORE LIMITED BENEFITS AND
I. AND YOU KNOW WE CAN'T DO
THAT IN POOR AREAS WE CAN ONLY
DO THAT IN AND RICH AREAS IN
CALIFORNIA WHERE POOR PEOPLE
LIVE. THEY DON'T GET ACCESS TO
OPEN SPACE AND PROTECTED LANDS
AND FAXES TO REVIEW SPECIES AND
INTERACT WITH THEM AND
HOPEFULLY LEARN ABOUT THEIR
THEIR OBLIGATIONS TO PROTECTING
THEMSELVES THAT'S THE STORY OF
CALIFORNIA AND I'M NOT
INTERESTED N FURTHERING A
POLICY THAT WILL DO THAT AND-
SO THAT'S WHY I ACCESS IS
IMPORTANT STRATEGIC. LOCATION
OF THESE IS ALSO IMPORTANT I.
AND THAT'S NOT MENTIONED IN THE
BILL AS WELL. AND I'D LIKE TO
SEE IF YOU COULD WORK IN GOOD
FAITH TO ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES.
HOW DID YOU COME UP WITH A 30%
NUMBER AND HOW MUCH DO WE
CURRENTLY HAVE. UNDER
PROTECTION INSTEAD OF
CALIFORNIA. FIRST OF ALL IF I
COULD- SUNDER- THE BILL DOES
SPECIFICALLY STATE THAT IS THE
GOAL OF THE STATE EVEN THIS
BILL. REPRESENTING THAT TO
IMPROVE ACCESS TO NATURE FOR
ALL PEOPLE BUT THERE'S A REASON
WHY I WAS RULES ONE OF THE KEYS
GROUP OF CO SPONSORS. OF THIS
BILL AND HOW DO YOU FIND ALL
PEOPLE THOUGH I MEAN WHEN YOU
GO INTO THE CENTRAL VALLEY PRO
COUNTY THAT. AREAS IN MY
COMMUNITY SAN DIEGO IT SOME
PEOPLE HAVE A HARD TIME AYE WE
HAVE TO PUT MONEY IN THE
BUDGET. TO GET PEOPLE FROM
ENGLAND TO THE COAST. UNLESS
SOMETHING THROUGH A DIRECT.
GOVERNMENT SUPPORT AND IF I
MEAN OF THE BILL IS MORE
SPECIFIC ON THAT I'D LOVE TO
SEE THAT BECAUSE THAT IS
IMPORTANT YES NO THANK YOU- THE
BUILD ACTUALLY THAT'S PART OF.
ONE OF THE MAIN PURPOSE OF THE
BILL PAYS FOR IT TOO AS WE-
PROTECT LANDS A PRACTICAL.
PRECIPITATING WAS NEVER NOT
PRESCRIPTIVE AND HOW WE DO IT.
BECAUSE AGAIN THIS IS A THE GO.
HOWEVER IT DOES VERY SPUR.
STATE PARTICULARLY FOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE THERE IS A RECOGNITION
AS I MENTIONED IN MY OPENING.
THAT ALTHOUGH WE GET A LOT OF
PARKS BONDS AND MONEY TO.
PRESERVE COULD CONSERVE OUR
PROTECT LANDS. THAT IT'S OFTEN
TIMES IN DIFFERENT CORNERS THE
STATE FAR AWAY FROM URBAN
COMMUNITIES FAR AWAY FROM
POPULATION CENTERS- AND SO WE
WANT AND I COMPLETELY AGREE
WITH. ALSO ACCESS AS WELL- THAT
TO IT DOESN'T DO MUCH GOOD TO
COMMUNITIES I DON'T HAVE ACCESS
OF COURSE LATTICES. HUNTER
PERCENT PRIDED AND BLOCKED OFF.
TO THE REST OF THE COMMUNITY
OUT THIS. BILL WITH A WILL WITH
BILLING. PRIVATE LANDOWNERS
COULD ALLOW. FOR A- OF THE
CONSERVATION EASEMENTS TO ALLOW
PUBLIC ACCESS. TO THE BEACH IS
THAT A LOT AND- THE POSTAL
REGION AS WELL. BUT BILL VERY
SPECIFICALLY DOES- EVER DOES
SPEAK TO THAT AND IF YOU KNOW
IF I KNOW MARSEILLE FROM AS
LITTLE AS ONE OF THE- IT. WAS
ONE OF MY PRESENTED TODAY. THE
M. BLOUSE CAN SPEAK THE ACT ASP
BECAUSE THAT'S PRIMARY REASON
WHY I ABLE. SIGNED ON AS
OPPOSED. A CENTER. FROM THE ALL.
YES SHE'S ON THE RIGHT NOW. I
WOULD ASK THEM ON TO WIN THIS
YEAH. THANK YOU CAN USE IF THE-
WITNESS IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL- IS STILL AVAILABLE- FROM
US TO MARS I AM. PLEASE DO YOU
WANT TO ADDRESS THE QUESTION
FROM SENATOR HUESO ABOUT ACCESS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY- GOOD AFTERNOON
THANK YOU CAN I WANT THE
ACTUALLY THE MONTHS INSTEAD OF
THE OTHER I'M NOT DECISION IN
YOUR DISTRICT I GREW UP IN YOUR
DISTRICT- WHEN WE SAY ALL
CALIFORNIANS WE NEED ALL
CALIFORNIANS THAT IS OUR STRONG
BELIEF. THAT THE CULT OF
CALIFORNIANS BELONG JUST AS
MUCH AS THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
LUCKY ENOUGH TO LIVE IN THE
COASTAL THE CODE AS THE FOLKS
THAT DRIVE TWO THREE HOURS FOUR
HOURS AWAY. HIS TO ENJOY
THEMSELVES- THAT IS THE
EXTREMELY- IMPORTANT TO THE
INTENT OF THE SPELL IN THE
SPIRIT OF THIS FOOTBALL CLUB.
pPROTECTION THEY'RE CURRENTLY
NOT ACCESSIBLE IN. THERE IN THE
CLOSE ARE GOING TO BE OPEN
TAXES. DID YOU HEAR THAT. I
DON'T I I'M I'M SORRY I DON'T
THINK I CAN ANSWER THAT
QUESTION OKAY I THINK THAT IF
IT'S IF IT'S PRIVATELY ONLINE
YOU CAN'T FORCE APRIVATE NO
I'M NOT ASKING APPROACH ONLY
LANDED PROTECTION YES AS I'VE
DRIVEN SWATS I'VE BEEN GIVEN
THE ENTIRE CALIFORNIA COASTLINE
FROM THE OREGON BORDER TO SAN
DIEGO ON. THEIR ENORMOUS ARE
ENORMOUS WHAT'S THAT ARE NOT A
CIVIL. AND THEY'RE NOT PRIVATE
OWNED AND SO THANK YOU. WATCH
CONFLICT 30% NUMBER HOW MUCH DO
WE HAVE CURRENTLY UNDER
PROTECTION. THERE ARE DIFFERENT
S. VINCE THAT INDICATE THAT AT
LEAST 22% OF OUR LAND IT. IS
CONSIDERED A PROTECTED. AND THE
LEAST AROUND 16% OF THE STATE'S
OCEAN WATERS I DO WANT TO MAKE
IT VERYCLEAR- THAT WITH
AMENDMENTS THAT- 30% OF THE
EIGHT OCEAN ASPECT OF THE BILL
IS IT VAST POTENTIAL 30% THE
NATION'S OCEANS BY TWENTY
THIRTY IS NOT A CALIFORNIA
SPECIFIC. GOAL SO THE CONCERN
OF 30% WOULD ALSO INCLUDE 30%
CALIFORNIA'S BECAUSE OF ME 30%
OF THE ENTIRE NATION IT'S A
IT'S A NATIONAL GOAL IS TO
ENCOURAGE AND TO HAVE
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT. TROUBLED
CENTER OF THE NATION'S OCEANS
SO THAT WOULD BE- UP POLICY
MAKING PROCESS SOME QUESTION
TEN. GIVE ME GIVE ME WORKING
WITH STATES AS BE DONE MANY
TIMES BE WORKING WITH OUR
FEDERAL AND- HAS. BEEN WRITTEN
LOOKING AT ARGUMENTS HERE I SAW
THAT. OTHER WAS A CLARIFICATION
RELATED TO THE MARINE PROTECTED
AREAS THE REPORT ON THE SAYS.
AMENDMENTS ALL DELETED ALL
REFERENCES TO MARINE PROTECTED
AREAS DOES THAT MEAN. THAT
WE'RE GONNA LIMONITE FROM
PROTECTED AREAS OR INCLUDE THEM
IN THE 30% OR IN ADDITION TO
THE 30% OF A RIGHT NOW. IF
YOU'D PREFER TO STOP ANALYSIS
THE MPA ARE INCLUDED AS PART OF
WATERS CONSERVE INTO A HUNDRED
IN NINETEEN OF. PEARSON THAT
16% YES THAT'S ALREADY IS SO
WHAT BUT- THIS WAS THE DIRECTOR
OSCAR THE RECREATIONAL. FISHING
GROUP I DO LIVE ANYWHERE. TWEET.
TO GO TO. TATIAN A LIFE
PROTECTION ACT WE LIKE PENSION
ACT WE COMPLIED WITH THEIR ASK
AND AMENDED DELETE A REFERENCE
OKAY AND IT COULD BE. THE
PROTECT IN THE 4% PAPA FOR I'M
IF WE CALIFORNIANS MORE OF THE
WATERWAYS OF THE- OF THE NATION.
I MEAN IT WORK I MEAN IF WE
TECH A PROPORTIONATE WE SHOULD
BE THIRTY BUT IF WE DO
DISPROPORTION WOULD BE ABOUT
THIRTY IN THE OCEAN POSSIBLY.
IS DONE THE RIGHT WAY I MEAN I
THINK THE BEST THAT THE KEY IS
PROTECTING OUR BIODIVERSITY
KEYS PROTECTING. AND CAN YOU
KNOW THE PROTECTION OF THE OUR
WATERS AND OUR LAND ACTUALLY.
ALLOWS FOR MORE FISHING AND
HUNTING BECAUSE ACTUALLY IF
YOU'RE PROTECTING FROM- THE
DESTRUCTION OF THE OKAY
DIVERSITY. AND YOU THAT COULD
BE STATE. NOT MISTAKEN ANOTHER
14% OF THE- CALIFORNIA
COASTLINE PROTECT POSSIBLY.
BECAUSE YOU SAID WE'RE AT 60%
OF US MARINE PROTECTED AREAS OF
16% YES THAT'S A THAT'S
ACCORDING TO THE ESTIMATES AS
INDICATED IN THE AND THE STAFF
ANALYSIS- SO THIS FIFTY TO THE
STATE OPTIONS WHAT IS
CONSERVING A HUNDRED OKAY FOR
MARINE MANAGED AREAS. AND AGAIN
BE WE- TOOK OUT NPA'S AT THE
REQUEST AND YOU KNOW HOW THAT
WE DO WE DEFINE THAT BECAUSE
SINCE AND WE HAVE AREAS THAT
ARE NOT PROTECT MARINE
PROTECTED AREAS BUT ARE ALSO
PROTECTED AREAS. ALONG SAN
DIEGO BAY ALONG SENEGAL COAST
AND- THOSE BE ADDED TO THE
CUMULATIVE NUMBER ABSOLUTELY
THE OF IT I THINK THAT THIS IS
NOT A COMPREHENSIVE PERCENTAGE
IS PROBABLY MUCH HIGHER THAN A
16% THAT WAS THE MOST. EASILY
ACCESSIBLE DATA POINT BECAUSE
IT'S EASY TO FIND THOSE THE
MARINE MANAGER UP TO THAT
PROVIDE SOME CLARIFICATION
HOPEFULLY THE THAT IS THE CASE
WILL INTO THAT ALSO. YOU THE
BILL ADDRESS DOES. RUMOR%
CULTURAL SO ACCESS TO NATIVE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY. THERE ARE
ALSO SOME UNTREATED I MEAN
WE'VE DECIMATED. THE IN THE
POPULATION CALIFORNIA AND
THEY'RE STILL TRYING TO
PRESERVE THE CULTURE AND MERRY
MANY AREAS PART OF THEIR
CULTURE- POSSESSES HUNDING
CERTAIN HUNTING TRADITIONS. AND
THEY THEY HUNT IN CERTAIN WAYS
THAT- SHOULD BE ALLOWED THAT
CURRENTLY ARE VERY RESTRICTED
AND I JUST WAS WONDERING IF YOU
COULD WOULD BE WILLING TO ADD
THAT TO THE BILL. TO ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE FOR THE NATIVE
AMERICAN COMMUNITIES WHERE
WHERE APPLICABLE. YEAH BUT
WORKING VERY CLOSELY. WITH THE
TRIBES TRIBAL NON TRIBAL
JUSTICE ISSUES AND CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THEM TO MAKE SURE
THAT THANK YOU ARE NOT IMPEDING
ON THEIR CULTURAL HERITAGE OR-
THEIR WAY OF LIFE THAT WOULD
THAT WAS IMPORTANT ARE
IMPORTANT TOO I GUESS AT TO THE
BILL. ALSO A BILL IN LIKE A
MEDICARE. DRUG PLAN WITH AN
ARTY YES WONDER IF I COULD
OFFER JUST A COUPLE POINTS I'M
JUST A MOMENT THIS. IS FREAKING
ICE I APPRECIATE KNOWING YOU'RE
THERE AND ALSO GONNA WRECK NICE
MOMENT THERE'S ANOTHER. PERSON
PRESS ONE TO DRESS THAT
SPECIFIC QUESTION WHICH I WILL
NOW I WANNA THIS FINISH. FIRST
UNLESS SENATORS WILLING TO HEAR
FROM IN OUR DC. IN RESPONSE TO
YOUR QUESTION THANK YOU. I
THINK BE IF A LOT I HAVE WOULD
LIKE TO HEAR THE RESPONSE BUT-
REGARDING. YOUR POLICY THIRTY
NINE YEAR AND THAT WOULD GAUGE
FEDERAL MEN AT WORK IN A
NATIONWIDE POLICY WOULD BE.
ALSO WORK WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO. MAKE SOME OF
THAT LAND AVAILABLE FOR
CONSERVATION ABSOLUTELY I MEAN
LOOK THIS THE IDEA BEHIND THE
BILL DOESN'T MENTION BE
ELEMENTS. OF THE- THE IDEA OF
THIS BILL IS TO. WORK WITH ALL
OF OUR PARTNERS FEDERAL. STATE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS COUNTIES
AND PRIVATE LANDOWNERS. TO
ACHIEVE THESE GOALS THAT'S WHY
IT'S NOT OVERLY PRESCRIPTIVE SO
I SAID YOU HAVE TO DO IT THIS
WAY THAT THAT WAY IT'LL BE
UNDERSTOOD CRITICISM THAT WERE
BEING TOO PRESCRIPTIVE AS TO
HOW TO DO IT. IT SAYS THE GOAL
AND ALLOWS US THE OPPORTUNITY
NOT ONLY TO WORK WITH OTHER
PARTNERS BUT TO ACCESS
POTENTIAL FUNDING FOR FEDERAL
GRANTS. IN IN PARTNER WITH
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PRIVATE
GRANTS WHAT HAD YOU LOOKING
PRIVATE LANDOWNERS WILLINGLY-
BUT YOU KNOW AS AS THEY AS THEY
CHOOSE- AND SO THERE IS A
VARIETY OF WAYS WE CAN ACHIEVE
THESE GOALS. AND THAT INCLUDES
WERE FEDERAL MEANT. THANK YOU
EN. YOU KNOW THE LAST ISSUE.
THE SENEGAL. I NEED TO SUPPORT
MY DOES AND HE'S MY MOTHER JOBS
IN MY DISTRICT AND OF COURSE
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
INDUSTRY THAT BRINGS A LOT OF
TOURISTS TO SAN DIEGO BUT ALSO-
YOU KNOW SUPPORTS- YOU KNOW IN
AN INDUSTRY THAT IS REALLY
DEPENDS ON THE SAN DIEGO
COASTLINE. THE EXORCIST AND
IT'S ONE THAT BRINGS UP LOTS OF
A SPIN. SUPPORT TO OUR ECONOMY
AND PROVIDE JOBS TO FOR A LOT
OF FAMILIES BUT IS ALSO WAY TO
SOURCE FOOD. FOR A LOT OF THE
PEOPLE THAT USE THIS METHOD TO
ALSO SEARCH PUT FOOD ON THE
TABLE. AND IT'S AN- METHOD OF-
YOU KNOW FEEDING YOUR FAMILY.
AND RECREATING THAT SAME TIME
SO IT IT CHECKS A LOT OF BOXES
AND I WANT TO DO EVERYTHING IN
MY POWER TO PROTECT THAT
INDUSTRY. MAKE THAT THEY THAT
THE STATE. WELL YOU KNOW WE'RE
COMPETING WITH WITH. OTHER
OUTSIDE. YOU KNOW COUNTRIES
LIKE YOU KNOW JAPAN IF YOU GO
TO JAPAN THE FIRST LARGEST.
FISH FISH MARKET IN THE WORLD.
NUMBER ONE IS IN JAPAN THE
SECOND LARGEST IS IN JAPAN THE
THIRD LARGEST IN JAPAN. THEY IN
THE CONSTRUCT CONSUME ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF FISSION. WELL TIMES
ARE FISHING OFF OF OUR
COASTLINE. TO MATT THAT PUTS
ARC FISHERMEN IN DIRECT
COMPETITION. WITH THAT INDUSTRY
AND OF COURSE A LOT OF THESE-
INDIVIDUAL SUPPLY TO OUR LOCAL
MARKETS INCLUDING OUR MARKET IN
SAN DIEGO WHICH IS IN
OPPOSITION TO THE SAN. AND THE
CURRENT THREE SO. I WOULD LIKE
TO ENCOURAGE YOU. TO WORK WITH
THAT INDUSTRY PROVIDE SOME
ASSURANCES THAT THEIR INDUSTRY
WILL BE PROTECTED IN THIS I
THINK THERE IS A WAY TO PROTECT
OUR COASTLINE AND THE INDUSTRY
AT THE SAME TIME I THINK
THERE'S A WAY I THINK WE SHOULD
ENDEAVOR TO GET THIS RIGHT. AND
I HOPE THAT- YOU'RE WILLING TO
PUT ME THROUGH THIS PROCESS TO
SEE WHAT WE CAN DO TO. ASSUAGE
THE FEARS GET THEM ON BOARD TO
UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW. WHAT WHEN
I SEE WHAT'S HAPPENING OUR
COASTLINE. AND HOW THE
MANAGEMENT OF THE FISHERIES IS
TAKING PLACE I THINK FOR DOING
A FANTASTIC JOB OF THE COAST OF
CALIFORNIA. AND THE THEY ARE.
OF THAT ENDEAVOR IN A LOT OF
THEM ARE HELPING TO FUND.
MANAGEMENT LIMON TOP. WE'RE
GONNA BE PRETTY MUCH SERVING UP
FOR FISH TO JAPAN. AND
ELIMINATING THOSE ABSENT A MILK
MILK LEMONADE IN OUR ABILITY TO
ACCESS. A SUPER FOOD LOCALLY.
OFFER ON COASTLIES AND JUST
ADDING TO THE WHOLE PUBLICATION
OF THE SEAFOOD INDUSTRY. I
DON'T SUPPORT. SO I'VE- THIS IS
A- THIS BILL BUT I THINK IT'S
SOME THAT WE CAN ACHIEVE BY
TWENTY THIRTY. OF UP YOU KNOW
SPUR SUPPORTED NON HOPE THAT WE
CAN REVEAL HE'LL ADDRESS THOSE
POINTS ARE BROUGHT UP IN. HI. I
THOUGHT I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU
TO. I WORK FOR ME ON THIS AND
HOPEFULLY WE COULD- A SUITE OF
FEATURES OF FISHING INDUSTRY
MAKE SURE THEY FEEL REPRESENTED
BY THIS LEGISLATURE THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR HUESO AND
WHEN I WOULD LIKE TO DO THIS IS
THE TIME FOR COMMITTEE
DISCUSSION. WE DO HAVE THE
ENERGY SEEING EXPERT ON THE
LINE TO ANSWER ONE OF CENTER
PLACES QUESTIONS. THERE IS
SOMEBODY. HERE IN THE ROOM I'M
GOING TO FORWARD YOU A MOMENT
TO IT I THINK YOU WANT TO
RESPOND TO ONE OF THE ISSUES
RAISED BY SENATOR HUESO. PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF AGAIN AND IF
YOU PROVIDE A BRIEF. COMMENT
THIS WILL NOT BE FOR EXCHANGE
WITH MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
OR THE AUTHOR PLEASE. AND THEN
WE'LL GO TO ENERGY C. WITNESS
MISTER CHAIR MEMBER MARC SMITH
I'M SPEAKING ABOUT THE
RECREATIONAL ANGLING COMMUNITY
I THINK YOUR CALL SINCE. PART
THE BILL. CONCERT BILLS WHAT
DID. YOU PER. IF YOU GO TO THE
NET RESOURCES. WEBPAGE IN THEIR-
THEY SAY 47% OF LANDS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ARE
PROTECTED. IF YOU TAKE THE
MARINE PROTECTED AREAS WHICH
ARE 60% ESSENTIAL FISH HABITAT.
NATIONAL MARINE SANCTUARIES AND
ALL THE OTHER THINGS THAT EXIST
OFF OUR COASTLINE WE ARE WELL
ABOVE 30% BUT WHEN THE SPONSORS
TALK ABOUT THE BILL THEY SAY
ONLY 22% OF ANDS ARE PROTECTED
IN ONLY 60% OF THE OCEAN WHICH
MEANS THEY'RE EXCLUSIVELY
FOCUSING ON EITHER MPAS. OR
SOME SUBSET OF THE LAND
PROTECTION. WE DON'T HAVE
CLARITY ON WHAT THE BILL MEANS
THE BILL DOES NOT DEFINE THESE
TERMS THAT IS CONSISTENTLY WHAT
WE HAD ASKED FOR. WAS
COMMITTEES CENTER WE SAW
THROUGH THE CHAIR THIS IS NOT
FOR DIALOGUE WE'RE TRYING TO
GET SOME CLARIFICATION PLEASE
PLEASE FINISH YOUR COMMENT AND
THEN I AM GOING TO GO TO THE
WITNESS FROM ENERGY CEO I THINK
ARE POOR. REMAIN THAT. HAVE
WORK HOURS WITH THE SPONSORS
HAVE NEGOTIATED AMENDMENTS BACK
AND FORTH AND WERE UNABLE TO
REACH A CONCLUSION ABOUT
DEFINING THE TERM PROTECTION IN
WAY THAT I. NOTICED THIS IS A
SERVER SENATE DOCTOR. COMBINED
YEAH. ARE GREATER THAN 30%
WHERE IS THE FISH. THAT BONDS
ARE. EMPLOYED EXIST BUT NOT A-
AND THEN THE LEADS US THINK.
YOU KNOW FOR ONLY TWO ABOUT
SIXTY PER. BUT FROM THEIR PURSE.
THEY'RE GOING TO ANOTHER FOR.
PER OF AND- WHICH IS. FISHING
RISK. WE NEED TO COME TO
CONSENSUS AND UNDERSTANDING ON
THIS. AND I DON'T THINK WE CAN
DO IT IN THE REMAINING THREE
WEEKS THIS IS BEEN AN EXTREMELY
CHALLENGING. WE HAVE PUT OUR
BEST FOOT FORWARD I. AT THE
SPONSORED TELL YOU THE SAME
THING. THIS IS A BILL THAT WE
WANT TO IMPLEMENT OVER THE NEXT
DECADE AND WE'RE TRYING TO RUSH
IT THROUGH IN THE NEXT THREE
WEEKS IN AN ERA AND IN A TIME
IN WHICH WE CANNOT HAVE
MEANINGFUL CONVERSATION. EACH
OTHER LET ALONE WHAT DO YOU.
THINK THE SOLUTION MAKER I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENT- WILL
LET THE AUTHOR ADDRESSED THAT
IN HIS CLOTHES. I'M GONNA GO TO
THE WITNESS FROM IN OUR DC. HAS
RELIED UPON BY THE AUTHOR. TO
ADDRESS SPECIFICALLY THE
QUESTIONS RAISED BY SENATOR
HUESO. YOU HAVE THE FLOOR-
MISTER HUNT. THANK YOU CHAIR-
FIRST REGARDING THE 30% FIGURE
AND ITS ORIGIN. 30% FIGURE
COMES FROM- WHAT SCIENTIFIC
GLOBALLY AND TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY FIVE- WORK. ON ISSUE IN
CALIFORNIA OR LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA HAS WRITTEN TO THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE LEGISLATURE
IS REQUIRED. IN ORDER TO
PROTECT BIODIVERSITY AND
ADDRESS ISSUES AROUND CLIMATE
RESILIENCE THAT WE ARE
CURRENTLY FACING. WE DIDN'T
THAT NOW. IN CAL IF YOU LOOK AT
THE TYPES OF PROTECTION THAT
ARE CALLED FOR BY THE
DEFINITION OF PROTECT.
ESTABLISHES THAT ON LAND
PERHAPS I WOULD ABOUT TWENTY
TWO PERCENT. OF AREAS ARE
PROTECTED- AND AGAIN THE
DEFINITION OF PROTECT RELIED ON
TERMS AND WE'VE WE'VE AMENDED
IT COULD DEAL WITH THIS ISSUE
SPECIFICALLY THAT MR SAID JUST
READ. IT RELIES ON TERMS THAT
THE PUBLIC RESOURCE CODE USES
THAT THE AGENCIES RESPONSIBLE
FOR IMPLEMENTING CONSERVATION
PROGRAMS PROTECTION PROGRAMS
MIGLIOR. WITH AND UNDERSTAND. I
IT'S NOT A MESS. IT DOES
ADDRESS- BIG CONCERN THAT WE'VE
BEEN THAT WE'VE BEEN FACING
DROUGHT AND WITH RESPECT TO THE
OCEAN. IT'S AN INTERESTING IT'S
INTERESTING- POSITION THAT THAT
THE INDUSTRIES ARE TAKING CARE.
IF THE PRACTICES THAT THEY
ENGAGE IN UNPROTECTED. IN THAT
IT PAYS TO PROVIDE CONTRIVING
BIODIVERSITY AND THERE'S NO
PROBLEM BECAUSE THAT DEFINITION
ALLOWS FOR THOSE ACTIVITIES
THAT SUPPORT ABOUT DIVERSITY.
IT'S NOT CLEAR WHAT IT MEANS IS
RESULT IN REDUCED ACCESS TO
SPECIALLY CONSIDERING THE FACT.
THAT IT DOESN'T CALLS FOR
EXPANSION OF AT GREAT PROTECTED
AREAS IN CALIFORNIA AND THE
DEFINITION COULD NOT LIMIT THE
TYPES OF PROTECTIONS ONLY TO
THOSE. FOUND IN PARTICULARLY.
LONG BIODIVERSITY IS AND ON THE
ON THE REASON FOR PROTECTING AN
AREA MANY OTHER USES COULD BE.
ALLOWED IN THOSE AREAS I ALSO
WANTED TO JUST POINT OUT TO.
MISTER HUESO AND I'M GLAD YOU
BROUGHT THIS PROPERTY CUTTING
TRADITIONAL USES BY MAJOR
MERICAN TRIED OTHER INDIGENOUS
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- SPECIFICALLY
ADDRESS THE ISSUE. AND IF YOU
LOOK ON PAGE FOURTEEN THIRTEEN
OF FOURTEEN OF THE COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCED THAT YOU CAN SEE AN
INTENSE SECTION OF THE BILL
SPECIFIC RECOGNITION OF THE
ISSUES AND THE IMPORTANCE. OF
READING TRADITIONALLY CLOSE
ECOLOGICAL KNOWLEDGE AS- EQUAL
TO OUR- KNOWLEDGE THAT WE
DEPEND ON THAT TREE AND IN OUR
IN OUR SOCIETY AND OUR CULTURE.
AND IT'S THE TYPICALLY CALLED
ON THE STATE. SOMETHING IT
SHOULD DO NOT MANDATORY BUT
SHOULD. BOB CAN SOLVE WITH MADE
IN AMERICAN TRIBES WHEN
CONSERVATION AFRICAN BACK
TRAVEL AND SOCIAL THANK YOU
MISTER HUNT WE APPRECIATE OUR
GRATIFICATIONS I AM NOW GOING
TO GO TO SENATOR BRANDIS. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- I THINK. MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO HAD
STARTED OFF WITH A QUESTION
THAT I THINK IS IMPORTANT TO
ASK BECAUSEIT ALSO BEARS
DIRECTLY ON. THE URGENCY OF
THIS MATTER AND WHETHER NOT
THAT EXISTS WE'VE BEEN ASKED.
THAT WE DEAL. WITH RELATED
MATTERS WILDFIRE IN HOUSING
THAT WAS THE ORIGINAL- A
RECOMMENDATION BY THE PRO TEM I
THINK IT'S CLEAR THAT THERE ARE
SO MANY EXAMPLES THE FAT THAT
WE'VE GONE ABOVE AND BEYOND
THOSE- PARAMETERS. AND I LOVE
THE VERBAL GYMNASTICS OF TRYING
TO CREATE A NEXUS THE CODE. IT
GETS JUST MORE INNER ALL THE
TIME- THAT IS A MAIN. I FIND
I'M HARD PRESSED TO THINK IF
THIS IS COVERED RELATED BUT
MOVING BEYOND THAT BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S HERE NOW THE
CHAIRMAN DECIDED TO ALLOW THE
ROSTER BILLS. TO MOVE FORWARD
IN THE WAY THAT HE DID. BUT I'M
LOOKING AT THIS. IT'S ALMOST AS
IF THIS SEEMS. LIKE WE'RE
JUMPING AHEAD OF A PROCESS I
THINK- YOU'D APPRECIATE THIS AS
AN ATTORNEY IN FACT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT PROVIDE
WANTED SAME LAW SCHOOL- SO I
THINK- THE- IS THAT. IS THAT.
THIS IS AN ASPIRATIONAL
DOCUMENT. IT DOESN'T HAVE SET
POLICIES IT DOES NOT HAVE
METRICS IT DOES NOT HAVE CLEAR
DIRECTION. EXCEPT FOR THE
NOTION THAT WE WANT TO MAKE
CERTAIN THAT 30% IS ACHIEVED
ART WHETHER IT BE THE NATIONAL
LEVEL OR A COMBINATION OF
STATES IN COMPLIANCE WITH THE
OVERALL INTERNATIONAL SET OF
OBLIGATIONS. BUT THE ISSUE IS.
BASED ON THE CONVERSATIONS THAT
I'VE HAD IN THE COMMENTS THAT
I'VE HEARD FROM FOLKS THAT RELY
ON THESE RELATED INDUSTRIES
THAT BELIEVE THAT THEY WILL BE
IMPACTED. WOULD IT NOT BE
APPROPRIATE. FOR US INSTEAD OF
A MAN DAY A LEGISLATIVE MANDATE
IN AN ASPIRATIONAL FORM OF
THIRTY PERCENT. TO INSTEAD
DIRECT THE STATE INSTRUMENTS
THE STATE AGENCY AND IN THEIR
IN THE RELEVANT DEPARTMENT. TO
DEVISE WAYS THAT WOULD BE
BROUGHT BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE
ON WHAT THINGS THEY WOULD DO TO
BE ABLE TO ACHIEVE. THE NUMBERS
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT BECAUSE I
THINK WITH THE FEAR THAT WE'RE
HEARING. FOLKS IN THE FISHERIES
FOLKS IN WILDLIFE FOLKS IN
AGRICULTURE. THE FEAR THAT
WE'RE HEARING IN THEIR
OPPOSITION. IS ONE OF. DISTRUST
WE'RE WE'RE IS GOING TO GO IN
COULD THIS ULTIMATELY IMPACT
THEIR LIVELIHOOD. AND I THINK
THERE'S MERIT TO THAT IT'S
THOSE SETS OF CONCERNS. SO
WOULD IT MAY BE MORE
APPROPRIATE TO USE THIS
LEGISLATIVE VEHICLE TO DIRECT
THE STATE AGENTS. TO SAY THIS
IS WHAT WE'D LIKE TO SEE HAPPEN
PLEASE REPORT BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE. ON HOW IT COULD BE
ACCOMPLISHED IN WHAT FASHION.
SECOND PART OF THAT WOULD BE
SINCE WE'RE IN COORDINATION. ON
THE ROAD WITH OTHER STATES AND
FEDERAL AUTHORITIES. HOW
EXACTLY THEY WOULD BE DOING THE
SAME THING. BECAUSE I THINK ONE
OF THE CONCERNS IS THAT IF
WE'RE PUSHING THIS FROM A
NATIONAL THE INTERNATIONAL
STANDPOINT. AND WE AT WE I
THINK WE'VE HEARD FROM FOLKS
THAT WASHINGTON HAS DIFFERENT
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICIES THAN
CALIFORNIA. WILL CALIFORNIA
ENDEAVOR TO MAKE UP THE SLACK.
MEETING THAT WE COULD EXCEED
THAT 30% IF THE MAJORITY OF
AMERICA DOES NOT IN EFFORT TO
MEET THE 30% INTERNATIONALLY OR
NATIONALLY. SO YOU CAN SEE WHY
THERE ARE A LOT OF FOLKS ARE
TERRIBLY CONCERNED ABOUT THAT.
AND THEN LASTLY IS THAT IF WE
REACHED. IT CONTEXT
UNDERSTANDING OF WHERE WE FIT
IN TO THIS LARGER AGENDA THAT'D
BE MEMORIALIZED IN LEGISLATION
AND BROUGHT BACK TO US SO MY
ULTIMATE POINT IN ALL THIS IS
THAT. THIS VEHICLE IT DOESN'T
HAVE SUBSTANCE IT IT IS
ASPIRATIONAL MANDATE. BUT THE
CONSEQUENCES COULD BE SO SEVERE
THAT WE ARE ABDICATING OR
LEGISLATIVE RESPONSIBILITIES IN
ALLOWING REGULATORY AGENCIES
THE WEIGHT OF THE LAW IN
AUTHORITY TO DEVISE POLICIES TO
ACHIEVE WHAT THIS LEGISLATION
ENDEAVORS. AND THAT I THINK IS
TERRIBLY DANGEROUS FOR THE
TRADITION OF THE LEGISLATIVE
BODY AS A CO EQUAL BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT WE'VE HEARD OVER AND
OVER AGAIN. SO MY POINT ALLEN
ALLEN TO HEAR. IS THAT NOT ONLY
IS NOT CODED RELATED AT ALL. WE
ARE CREATING MORE UNCERTAINTY
IN THE MARKET PLACE. AT A TIME
WHEN WE ARE DESPERATE FOR JOBS
IN CERTAINTY IN THE MARKETPLACE.
AND LASTLY WE ARE NOT ACTING IN
A LEGISLATIVE CAPACITY THAT
GOES INTO SPECIFICITY ON WHAT
THIS WOULD MEAN FOR RELATED
AREAS OR INDUSTRIES. AND I
THINK IT MIGHT BE THE WAY THAT
THEY SHOULD BE DONE BASED ON
THE COMMENT I HEARD JUST A
MOMENT AGO THIS IS TO
SIGNIFICANT. TO JAM THROUGH. IN
AUGUST. WOULD IT WOULD NOT ALL
BE BETTER SERVED IF THIS WERE
BROUGHT IN JANUARY AND HAD THE
FULL WEIGHT OF DEBATE IN THE
FULL WEIGHT. OF THE EXPLICATION
OF THE ISSUES. THANK YOU
SENATOR. ASSEMBLY MEMBER DO YOU
WANT TO ADDRESS ANY OF THOSE AT
THIS POINT- OR WOULD YOU LIKE
TO DO IN YOUR CLOTHES. I'M ON
THE APPOINTED- TO SAY LOOK. AT
THE END OF THE DAY CENTER YOU
KNOW WE COULD JUST. GET THIS
THE ADMINISTRATION HAVE THEM
TELL US. WHAT WE SHOULD BE
DOING OR WE CAN SET THE GOAL
AND ALLOW ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS
FOR AND AGAINST TO BE PART OF
THE PROCESS. OF ATTAINING THAT
GOAL- AND PART OF THE
AMENDMENTS. OR HAVE THE
NATIONAL RESOURCE AGENCY BE.
THE POINT FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION A RESPONSE FOR.
A OF THE METRICS. BUT WE'VE
DONE THIS IN OTHER ARENAS AND
IT'S MAKING ABOUT WHETHER IT'S
CLIMATE CHANGE RESPONSE OR WHAT
HAVE YOU WHAT WE SET A GOAL. OF
AND DAN. HOW COULD I GOAL IS
SET SUBSCRIPT LEGISLATION OR
SUCH COULD MINISTRATION ACTION
IS GOOD. HELPS US ACHIEVE THAT
GOAL AND SO. THAT WE CAN GO TO
ADMINISTRATION I MEAN TO YOUR
POINT. WITH THE MESSAGE I TELL
THEM TO TELL US WHAT. WE WANT
WHAT ONE TO DO WHAT WE CAN SAY
THIS IS OUR GOAL BASS ON THE
SIZE. AND BASED UPON THE
FEEDBACK WE'VE GOTTEN BY THE
WAY. THIS BILL. IS ASPIRATIONAL
THIS BILL. CLICK TO DOESN'T
INTENTIONALLY IS NOT
PRESCRIPTIVE IN FACT SOME OF
THE SPECIFICITY THAT WE STRUCK
RESTRICT. BASED ON FEEDBACK
FROM THE OPPOSITION BECAUSE
THEY DIDN'T WANT THAT LEVEL OF
SPECIFICITY IN THERE AND SO DOT
DOT. IT IS AN EFFORT FOR US TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM AND
EVERYONE ELSE THE SPONSORS AND
THE OPPOSITION SO THAT WE CAN
ACHIEVE OR TWENTY THIRTY THIRTY
BY THIRTY GOAL TOGETHER AND IS
THAT WHAT WE'RE NOT GONNA TAKE
ON THE PER OF OTHER STATES WE
HAVE ARTICLE SOUTH CAROLINA. IN
THE LEGISLATURE NOT THERE BY
THIRTY OF LEGISLATION RIGHT NOW
AS WELL. THE IDEA IS TO GET ALL
STATES ENGAGE IN THIS PROCESS
AS WELL AS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT BECAUSE THIS IS NOT
JUST ONE IT'S NOT SOMETHING
THAT JUST SOUTH CAROLINA JUST
CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO DO. A DEBIT
ASAL EFFORT THAT I THINK ALL
ALONG CENTER PARKS. OF THE- WE
CAN LEAD THE APPS. BY LEE SAID
IN A- AND THEN ONCE GOAL IS WE
WERE WITH THE FITNESS. IS TO
WHAT. IS AS TO. HOW TO BEST
ACHIEVE AS WELL. AS WITH THE
OTHER IN FOLLOW UP LEGISLATION
THAT MAKES SENSE- AND THIS BILL
WAS INTRODUCED MONTHS AGO
THERE'S NOT SOMETHING I JUST
SHOWED UP. LOCKABLE WEEKS- AND
SO YOU KNOW WE'VE WE'VE BEEN
ENGAGING AND ACTIVE I'LL GET
INTO THAT A LITTLE BIT LATER ON
TERMS TO ENGAGEMENT BUT YEAH
THERE'S DIFFERENTWAYS. THIS IS
AN APPROACHES. HEY WE HAVE A
DIFFERENT OPINION ON THE
APPROACH BUT I THINK THIS IS
THE RIGHT WAY TO APPROACH IT.
THANK YOU OUR- NEXT AND- HAVE.
SENATOR JOHN. BY SENATOR CHECKS.
SENATOR JOHN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I DO WANT TO AGREE
WITH MY COLLEAGUES IN AWAY SOON
CENTER BORDERS ON THE CONCERN
ABOUT THE KOBE BUT I RAISE THAT
ALREADY AND- TALKED ABOUT IT
LAST WEEK AS WELL. AND I HAVE.
SEVERAL TO COUPLE WEEKS OF. I
DO THINK THAT THERE ARE SOME
CONCERNS REGARDING HE
PERCENTAGE OF- STATE LANDS
CURRENTLY ARE PROTECTED. I
BELIEVE THAT THE CALIFORNIA
NATURI SERVICES AGENCY PUTS THE
NUMBER CURRENTLY AT FORTY
SEVEN. POINT ZERO FIVE PERCENT-
I'M NOT SURE WHERE THE SCIENCE
IS ON THAT ARE HOW THEY CAME UP
THAT NUMBER BUT- YOU FOR THAT
IS TO BE A PRETTY JUST TO ME
ALSO I DO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING US- AWARE OF THE TERM
MASS EXTINCTION EVENT I THINK
IS WHAT YOU SAID I'M NOT SURE
IF THAT'S THE NEW TER FOR-
GLOBAL WARMING- GLOBAL CLIMATE
CHANGE OR SEA LEVEL RISE- I'LL
BE PAYING ATTENTION TO THAT TO
COME UP- IN FUTURE CONVERSE.
REGARDING THE SETTLED SCIENCE
ON GLOBAL CHANGE. BUT ON YOUR
BILL IN PARTICULAR I DO WANNA-
DIG IN A LITTLE BIT DEEPER ON
THE ACCESS. ACTIVATE I AM A
BOARD MEMBER OF THE BOYS AND
GIRLS CLUB IN MY AREA AND A
FORMER WHEN I WAS A KID A
MEMBER OF THE BOYS AND GIRLS
CLUB SO I HAVE A AFFINITY AND I
KNOW THAT A CENTER HUESO WHO
DOES A LOT IN OUR AREA IN SAN
DIEGO FOR ACCESS FOR-
UNDERPRIVILEGED COMMUNITIES TO
GET INTO OUR- A NATURAL AREAS-
YOU KNOW. ANZA BORREGO STATE
PARK IS THE LARGEST. STATE PARK
IN THE COUNTRY WHICH IS NEAR
BOTH OF ARE ACTUALLY- BORDERS
BOTH OF OUR AREAS. AND IT'S
REALLY A UTILIZED I BELIEVE- BY
LOTS OF PEOPLE I MEAN IT'S HUGE
IT IN A LOTS OF PEOPLE CAN BE
ALLEN I THINK. YOUR GOAL OF
ACCESS WOULD BE MORE.
APPROPRIATELY ACCOMPLISHED IF
YOU YOU KNOW PROVIDED PROGRAMS
AND FUNDING AT TO ACTUALLY GET.
KIDS AND- CAL INTO THOSE AREAS-
ALSO COMMENTED WAS IT. YOU KNOW
GETTING KIDS TO ENJOY THE
COASTAL AREAS WELL THERE AND
THAT IN OUR- THEY'RE ACTUALLY
CLOSER TO THE COAST AND THEY
ARE TO ANSWERING THE STATE PARK
SO. THERE'S BEEN SOME CIRCULAR
REASONING ON THE ACCESS AND.
THIS IS BRIAN FROM YOUR NOSE
PLEASE WELL MY GLASSES KEEP
FALLING UP SO I'M HAVING A HARD
TIME SEEING A TAILOR SO
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT MR CHAIR. I
KNOW YOU'RE TRYING TO KEEP A
BALANCE HERE BUT IF I CAN'T SEE
I CAN'T READ MY NOTES AND THEN
I HAVE TO MAKE THINGS UP AS I
GO. YOU'RE DOING PRETTY WELL
THANK YOU SIR. IF CLOSER.
FELICIANO COULD DO YOU COULD DO
IT. THE WE WOULD CALIFORNIA'S
PUTS ITS OWN CAL OFTEN FOR ITS
OWN SPIN ON THINGS AND YOU'VE
DECIDED TO MAKE THIS AN ACCESS
BILL I AGREE WAS SENT AWAY SO
THAT THERE JUST BECAUSE YOU SAY
IT'S ABOUT A GOAL OF THE BILL
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THERE'S
ACTUALLY LANGUAGE IN THE BILL
THAT MAKES IT DEAL WITH ACCESS.
AND IT'S WELL INTENTIONED BUT
THERE'S BEEN SOME CIRCULAR
REASONING AND YOU WANNA PROTECT
AREAS AND CLOSE THEM. AND THEN
YOU SAY THAT YOU WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY HAVE ACCESS SO
HOW DOES PROTECTING LAND WATER.
AND OCEAN IN THIS BILL EXPAND
ACCESS HOUSE AT A CHEAP IN THIS
BILL. ARE THESE LANDS GOING TO
BE TURNED INTO PARKS WELL THE
WATERS YOU PROTECT IN THE OCEAN
SUDDENLY TURN INTO PLACES. AT
THESE COMMUNITIES ARE GOING TO
HAVE EASY ACCESS TO. HOW DO YOU
ENVISION THIS WORKING AND I'LL
I'LL GIVE YOU A PERSONAL STORY.
I RECENTLY HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TAKE UP- SPORT FISHING OFF THE
COAST OF SAN DIEGO. AND I WAS
ON A ON A BOAT THAT HAPPENED
TO- ACCIDENTALLY MOVE INTO THE
PRESERVE OFF OF LAHORE YEAH-
THE CAPTAIN OF THE BOAT- YOU
KNOW MADE AN HONEST MISTAKE
AND- ALTHOUGH. WE HAD
ENGAGEMENT WITH SOME OF A
CALIFORNIA'S PROFESSION ON
FORSMAN OFF THERE'S UP. TO CAL.
WELL IF YOU. IF YOUR CALL THESE
OFF. AT NOT IF ANY THAT'S MY
ACCESS IT'S A PRETTY. WE HAD
ACCESS TO IT BECAUSE IT'S OPEN
THERE'S NO FENCE THERE'S NO
MARKERS AND WE ACCIDENTALLY
MOVED INTO AND WE COULD HAVE
HAD A YOU KNOW AN UNFORTUNATE
SITUATION- BUT FORTUNATELY IT
WORKED OUT AND WE GOT IT WORKED
OUT TO LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
BUT THERE'S DIDN'T HEAR CLOSING
ACCESS YOU'RE NOT MAKING IT
MORE ACCESSIBLE. MISTER VICE
CHAIR OF WITH THE AUTHOR BE
WILLING TO ADDRESS THAT IN YOUR
CLOTHES- AND YOU WANT TO COME
IN IT IS IT'S A SUPER BRIEF
RESPONSE PAGE TEN OF THE NOW
CISCO'S OVER EVEN FURTHER
AMENDMENTS IN REGARDS TO
IMPROVING ACCESS AND PROTECTING.
PROTECTING LAND IS NOT BEING
CLOSING IT OFF I'VE GOTTEN A
LOT OF OTHER PEOPLE TO TALK
ABOUT CLOSING OFF ACCESS I HAD
AN YOU CAN PROTECT BIODIVERSITY
AND ACTUALLY HAVE ACCESS TO THE
SAME TIME WITH YOUR FISHING
HIKING. CAMPING ABSOLUTELY
CONSISTENT ONE. THANK YOU NEXT
IN ORDER SENATOR JACKSON AND I
WOULD ASK MEMBERS TO PLEASE
COME BACK TO FORTY TWO OH
THREE. SO THIS IS BEEN A
FASCINATING DISCUSSION I HAVE
NOW READ THIS BILL BACK AND
FORTH SEVERAL TIMES WE'VE BEEN
HERE BECAUSE THERE IS AND HAS
BEEN. REAL CONCERN EXPRESSED
THAT THIS LEGISLATION IS REALLY
GOING TO UNDERMINE THE ABILITY
OF OUR SPORT FISHERMEN TO FISH
AND PEOPLE TO HIKE IN AND I'M
LOOKING TO SEE WHERE IN THE
BILL THAT COULD BE. INTERPRETED
AS SUCH AND REALLY THE BOTTOM
LINE IS THERE IS JUST AN
INHERENT DISTRUST. THIS BILL IS
PURELY ASPIRATIONAL AND I'M
REMINDED ON THINGS THAT WE'VE
DONE OVER THE LAST MANY YEARS
THAT WERE ALSO PURELY
ASPIRATIONAL BACK- I THINK
PROBABLY IN THE YEAR TWO
THOUSAND WE WANTED TO BECOME-
USING. NON FOSSIL FUELS I THINK
20% BY TWENTY TWENTY WE DID A
BILL THE CALL FOR THAT IT
DIDN'T SAY HOW WE WERE GOING TO
DO IT. IT JUST SAID THIS IS OUR
GOAL IN FACT WE REACH THAT 20%
FORTY BEFORE TWENTY TWENTY.
WHICH I THOUGHT WAS INTERESTING
HOW DID OUR 30%OF GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS I BELIEVE. BY THE
FORTY HOUR PASHA LEGISLATION TO
FIFTEEN ARE AND THEN IT ALSO
DIDN'T TELL US HOW TO DO IT
JUST THAT WE NEEDED TO DO IT IT
HAD SOME GUIDELINES BUT THERE
WAS REALLY NOT NO PRESCRIPTIVE.
METHODOLOGY OR ANYTHING OF THE
SORT THAT WAS USED. IT I'VE HAD
PROBABLY MORE RESPONSE FROM MY
LOCAL COMMUNITY ON THIS BILL
THAN ANY OTHER BILL THIS YEAR
AND I APPRECIATE THAT THE
PASSION OF MY SPORT FISHER.
INDUSTRY AND IN SANTA BARBARA I
HAVE VERY DIFFERENT WHO ARE.
PASSIONATE ABOUT SPORTS FISHING
AND I'VE DONE IT IS WELL I'M
NOT BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL BUT-
BUT I HAVE TRIED AND I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATED AS A VERY
EXCITING SPORT IF YOU'RE ABLE
TO LAND ANYTHING- BUT I'VE
WATCHED PEOPLE DO IT. AND IT
REALLY DOES TAKE A TALENTED AND
AN INTENSITY OF COMMITMENT SO I
DON'T WANT TO IN ANY WAY
DOWNPLAY. THEIR CONCERNS EXCEPT
TO SAY THERE REALLY. I THINK
BASED UPON THE UNKNOWN.
LAURENTIIS DEPENDING WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE AT THIS BILL IS
GOING TO BE CALLING FOR. I
DON'T THINK IT CALLS FOR MUCH
OTHER THAN A COMMITMENT TO
SEEING THAT THIS HAPPENED AND
SO- AND THEN I SHOULD I WANT
TO. HELLO MY SHOW TO THE OF THE
REMARKS MADE BY OUR CHAIR THERE
ARE SOME REAL LEGITIMATE
CONCERNS HERE- AGAIN WHEN WE
TRY SOMETHING NEW OR THAT SON
KNOWN AND ISN'T AS CLEAR AS
PEOPLE WANTED TO BE- THAT THIRD
THAT THERE ARE CONCERNS BUT I
THINK. THE ASPIRATIONAL GOAL OF
THIS 30% OF MANDATE IS A GOOD
ONE- YOU KNOW I'VE I'VE HAD THE
EXPERIENCES I HAPPEN TO HAVE. A
FAMILY THAT COMES FROM NEW FROM
LAND. AND SO WE VISITED THE NEW
FEES- MANY YEARS AGO YOU KNOW
NEW FROM LAND USED TO BE A
ROBUST COD FISHING AREA- EACH
EVERYWHERE YOU WENT THERE WAS
CARD THIS CARD THA AND NOW THE
COD FISHERMEN LEAST AS OF A FEW
YEARS AGO WERE ALLOWED TO. TWO
DAYS OF FISHING A YEAR AND A
TOTAL OF I THINK FOR CARD.
BECAUSE IT'S BEEN SO TERRIBLY
OVER FISH THERE NO CARDS LEFT.
NO PART OF IT FRANKLY WAS IT
WAS OVERFISHED BY OTHER
COUNTRIES. THAT HAD COME IN AND
SO IT WOULD BE MY HOPE THAT
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE WOULD
CONSIDER. THAT ARE JURISDICTION
ONLY GOES OUT THREE MILES AND
YOU KNOW WE HAVE AS I
UNDERSTAND IT A SUBSTANTIAL
STOCK OF FISH AT THIS POINT
TIME. BUT THAT CAN GO VERY
QUICKLY AS I RECALL OUR FRIENDS
IN NEWFOUNDLAND- EXPERIENCING
THAT ALL NOW FRANKLY ON THEIR
SOCIAL WELFARE PROGRAM BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE A LIVELIHOOD-
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THAT
WE CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO SEE.
I GREW UP IN NEW ENGLAND MANY
YEARS AGO THEY WERE LOOSE THERE
WAS A AN ABSENCE OF LOBSTER
STOCK. AND SO THEY LITERALLY
CUT OFF LOBSTER FISHING. OR
TRAPPING. FOR FIVE TO TEN YEARS
AND NOW THEY HAVE A ROBUST
STOCK SO MY SENSE IS THAT WE
CAN DO THIS RIGHT. AND THAT IS
IN ALL OF OUR BEST INTEREST TO
DO IT RIGHT. SO WITH THAT- I AM
GOING TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S A GOOD
ASPIRATION- BUT I DO
ANTICIPATE. AT THAT WE ARE NOT
GOING TO BE RELINQUISHING OUR
RESPONSIBILITIES AS A CO EQUAL
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT BECAUSE
THESE ISSUES WILL COME BACK
BEFORE US. BUT THE HOPE IS TO
GET EVERYBODY AT THE TABLE AND
FIGURE OUT HOW WE GET TO THAT
THIRTY PERCENT. AND I THINK
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL ATTEMPTS
TO DO. AND BECAUSE OF THAT I'M
A WILLING TO SUPPORT IT TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
JACKSON. I JUST WANT TO OFFER A
FEW COMMENTS AND THEN RETURN TO
THE AUTHOR- FOR HIS CLOTHES.
SEVERAL HAVE COMMENTED THAT
WHAT'S THE NEXUS BETWEEN THIS
IN COVERT NINETEEN I ACTUALLY
SEE A VERY STRONG NEXUS WHEN WE
LOOK AT THE VECTORS THAT HAVE
LED O THE CORONA VIRUS WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS THE
IMPACT OF HUMAN. CONDUCT
IMPACTING NATURAL HABITATS
IMPACTING THE BIODIVERSITY AND
THAT UNFORTUNATELY. THE VECTORS
THAT LED TO THE CORONA VIRUS
THAT THEY WERE DEALING WITH
TODAY. MAY NOT BE UNIQUE TO A
SINGLE CIRCUMSTANCE- OUR
ACTIONS AS HUMAN BEINGS HAVE
MUDDIED THE DIVIDE BETWEEN
NATURAL HABITAT AND HUMAN
POPULATION HUMAN EXPLOITATION
OF RESOURCES. I SEE THIS VERY.
VERY STRONGLY CONNECTED IN THE
OTHER NEXUS IS THE CLIMATE
CRISIS. WHAT BRINGS THIS TO THE
FORE IS A CLIMATE CRISIS THAT
AFFECTS ALL HUMANITY AND
AFFECTS PUBLIC HEALTH AND IT'S
NOT PROST BECTIVE IT'S
HAPPENING TODAY. I DON'T KNOW
HOW MANY READ LAST WEEK IN
BAGHDAD IT WAS ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE DEGREES. HEATS IN
CALIFORNIA THIS YEAR SURPASS
PAST RECORDS FOR THE DAYS OVER
A HUNDRED DEGREES. ALSO SIR AND
I'M REMINDED A HUNDRED TWENTY
NINE IN CALIFORNIA. HI THE
CLIMATE CRISIS IS UPON US. AND
IT WILL NOT PICK WINNERS AND
LOSERS BETWEEN POOR COMMUNITIES
BETWEEN WEALTHY. BETWEEN
FISHING COMMUNITIES BETWEEN
HUNTING COMMUNITIES SO AS I
THINK HAS BEEN OFFERED AN
ACKNOWLEDGED BY MANY OF THE
OPPONENTS WE ALL SHARE A
CONCERN FOR TRYING TO DO WHAT
WE CAN AND MUST DO AS HUMANS
UNDO THE IMPACTS CREATED BY
HUMANS. I SEE THIS BILL AS A
CRITICALLY URGENT REMINDER. OF
THE CRISIS NOT A PROSPECTIVE
CLIMATE CHANGE BUT IN EXISTING
CURRENT CRISIS THAT TO PROTECT
FOR OUR CHILDREN AND OUR
GRANDCHILDREN THE ABILITY TO
HUNT THE ABILITY TO FISH THE
ABILITY TO SURF THE ABILITY TO
DO DIVING- ALL OF THE
RECREATIONAL ACTIVITIES THAT WE
ENJOY- REQUIRE US ALL TO PULL
TOGETHER. AND IN A MEASURED.
SMART COLLABORATIVE MANNER
IDENTIFY HOW WE PROTECT OPEN
LAND HOW WE PROTECT OPEN OCEAN
WATERS AND WE SET A STANDARD
AND A MODEL WORKING WITH NOT
ONLY OTHER STATES BUT OTHER
NATIONS TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE
IS A SHARED COMMITMENT TO THESE
ASPIRATIONAL GOALS IF WE'RE TO
**** OR REVERSE. THE IMPACTS OF
THE CLIMATE CRISIS IN ANYWAY
AND ULTIMATELY. THIS IS ALL A
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS. BURGLAR
WE SOMETIMES. TALK. SPECIES CAN
LEAD TO THE EXTINCTION OF
HUMANKIND. SO I SEE A VERY.
PRESIDENT URGENCY TO MOVING
THIS CONVERSATION FORWARD AND I
WOULD ALSO JOIN IN JUST HOPING
THOSE WHO OPPOSED SO VEHEMENTLY
TODAY AND I THANK THEM FOR
THEIR CONCERN AND PARTICIPATION.
MS CHIEF CONSULTANT PLEASE TAKE
THE ROLE AND REMINDER MEMBERS
PLEASE HAVE YOUR MICROPHONE IS
TURNED ON- AB THIRTY THIRTY TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS INING NINE
AWNING HI JONES NO JONES NO
ALLEN. ALLEN I BOARD. OR JUST
NOTE. URGED HUESO. HUESO
JACKSON JACKSON AYE TAX ICE. HI
TURN ON BY. FIVE TWO THAT HAS
FIVE VOTES IN FAVOR TO VOTE IN.
WE'RE GONNA LEAVE THE ROLL OVER
FOR ABSENT I DID MISS IN THIS
WAS AB THIRD THAT CHIEF CHIU
CONSULTANT GOT IT RIGHT I.
MISTER JUST A QUICK QUESTION
YES HOW MANY TO THE REQUIRED A
OUT OF THIS REQUIRES OKAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU ON WE WILL HOLD
ROLE FOR ME THEM FOR MINUTES
ANY MEMBER OF. NATCH RESOURCES
IN WA WHO WANTS TO ADD ON TO
BILLS. WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN
FOR FIVE MINUTES PLEASE. TO
FORTY TWO OH THREE. IMMEDIATELY
THANK YOU. FORTY FIVE LIVE HERE
FOR FIVE YEAH. THANK YOU. ALL.
YES SO TOO CAN PLEASE CALL GO
THROUGH THE DOCKET FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. FOR ITEM ONE B. THREES
ZERO FIVE THE MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS OF
THE CURRENT VOTE IS SIX ZERO
WITH ONE NOT VOTING HERTZBERG.
HUESO HUESO HI. IN THE NEXT
ITEM- FILE ITEM TWO ABC. THREE
ZERO SEVEN FOUR THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS THE
CURRENT VOTE IS SIX ZERO ZERO
HERTZBERG HUESO BY HUESO HI.
LET'S BACK ON CALL OF A FIRE
LINE THREE AB THIRTY TWO ONE
FOUR MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS THE CURRENT
VOTE IS FOUR TO TWO. KABIRU
HERTZBERG ALL HERTZBERG ARE SO
HI HUESO. THAT SIX BACK ON CALL
THANK YOU THAT BILL BACK CALL.
WE'RE GONNA WAIT JUST A COUPLE
MINUTES I WE HAVE SOME KERR
HEROES FOR. HERE SO LIFT THE
CAR ON THE- THAT ARE STILL ON
CALL. FILE ITEM ONE A. B.
THREES ZERO FIVE THE MOTION IS
DUE TO. AMENDED APPROACH. THE
KERR VOTE IS SO. ZERO WITH ONE
THE- HERTZBERG BY SEARCH FOR HI.
THAT'S EIGHT ZERO. EIGHT ZERO.
THAT BILL PASS. MOVING TO NEXT
ITEM FILE TO AB THREE SEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE IS
SEVEN ZERO. ZERO ZERO AYE
HERTZBERG AYE. HERTZBERG ALL
RIGHT THAT IS NOT ZERO NINE
ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT MOVING TO
ITEM THREE A. B. THIRTY TWO
FORTY. FILE ITEM THREE ABC TWO
FOUR THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS THE
CURRENT VOTE IS. FIVE TWO THE
SORRY SIX TWO. YOU CAN BE.
CAMPERO HIGH THAT'S TWO THAT
BILL IS AN VOTERS SEVENTY TWO
FILE ITEM A BI THIRTY THIRTY
THE MOTION IS DUE TO A AMENDED
APPROACH. OCCUR VOTE IS FIVE
TWO. CAVEA. W. NOT VOTING
HERTZBERG BY HERTZBERG. THIS IS
TO ONE NOT VOTING THE BILL IS
AB THREE SO TWO ONE NINE VOTE
AND THAT COMPLETES OUR DOCKET
FOR THANK YOU TO THIS THANK YOU
SIR. THANK FOR ALL WHO
PARTICIPATED TODAY. NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER STANDS IN
ADJOURNMENT.